e
e e
good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have
several hearings scheduled for today but
before we get to those would ask you I'd
ask you to please join me in the Pledge
of Allegiance
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all thank you
everyone the first bill to be heard this
morning is House Bill
606 Prime sponsor is representative
Ellen Reed and representative Reed is
already at the witness table so good
morning representative Reed don't forget
to put your there you go okay thank you
Mr chair and thank you honorable members
of the committee for the record my name
is Ellen Reed I represent Rockingham 10
which is New Market and new Fields um
this is the third iteration of a bill
that just a few months ago this
committee uh
unanimously uh passed the uh recommended
for future legislation determination out
of interim study I realized that many of
you are new to the Comm or new to the
house in general and so won't have
remembered that but those of you who are
here will remember that particular one
because that's the one where we had a
filmmaker who's doing a documentary on
this issue show up um she is not with us
today she is filming somewhere else I
will say that I've passed out an
amendment that I'll get to the
differences I am very excited about this
language because it addresses everything
that was brought up in the two different
hearings and the interim study it also
um it it IT addresses the opposition in
a way that makes it Broad and yet very
very tailored so um I'm I'm I will get
to the language specifically uh I'm
going to tell my story again because
there are so many new people on the
committee but this uh was this idea this
bill was generated because of my
personal story but I didn't think to put
it in at first until I realized it was a
lot of people's personal stories um so I
started getting my period when I was 13
and since that day it has never been
regular it has never been normal uh a
normal period lasts maybe 3 to 5 days uh
my periods would frequently go 2 to
three weeks and I would maybe have
several months in between periods so uh
so it was a problem my entire life but
at the age of 28 I was finally diagnosed
with PCOS polycystic ovarian syndrome um
um and I started I had known from a
fairly young age that I did not want to
have children I grew up the oldest
sister of four younger brothers and I
did all my parenting when I was a
teenager and I was I was quite happy
with that thank you very much um and I
married a man who also didn't want to
have children and and got of visectomy
so I was begging these doctors total of
six doctors over the next decade um to
go ahead and just take it out I don't
need it it's causing me misery um I then
bled for a year straight over a year 365
days plus I bled every single day some
days were heavy some days were spotting
but there was blood every single day for
over a year and that's when I actually
ended up getting diagnosed and these
doctors tried literally everything
because every single time I said you
know we can just remove it I'm good with
that they would say oh no no you're
gonna want to have kids I'm like nope
I'm I'm quite certain and they would say
well what about your husband doesn't
your husband wants to have
kids um didn't know he had a a say over
my my medical condition but actually no
he has a
visectomy um and they were like well
what if you marry someone else that
person might want to have kids so the
reproductive desires of a hypothetical
man who doesn't even exist were more
important than my literal medical
needs um and so this went on I I changed
doctors frequently um they tried iuds
IUD almost punct punctuated my uh
perforated my uterus they tried
everything nothing would control the
bleeding and then um at the age of 37 I
did something that's I guess kind of
rare it's called shedding a cast and
I've never given birth so I didn't know
what was happening I thought I was dying
it was a tremendous pain but it turns
out I was having
contractions I was having contractions
because I was giving birth to a mold of
the interior of my uterus um it took
hours I was on the phone with 911 in
tears on the toilet when I caught the
said mold of my uterus it looked like
two small bloody chicken breasts if you
wanted that level of
detail um and then finally after that
happened I got a new doctor and that
doctor finally said well you're 38 and
you're old enough
now what other medical procedure
do we wait any any age past 18 to say
that a person is allowed to say what
they
want so anyway I that that happened in
my second term as a legislator and I
still didn't realize because I literally
I think a lot of women kind of were
conditioned like this I thought it was a
me problem I thought that I was just
getting bad doctors or having a bad run
of not being able to advocate for myself
or what have you and it was just me and
then I found an online community of
women mostly women some men um who have
had almost exactly the same issue and
not just for um PCOS largely for
endometriosis these women have suffered
far more than I ever did um
pmdd uh uh a wide range of conditions
cancer and in fact two documented cases
I found one in the UK and one in the US
where women died of cancer
because they well you can say because of
cancer and we don't know what would have
happened but their doctor refused to
remove their
uterus because the doctor thought they
could save their life and their
fertility and so it's it's it's really
kind of crazy making that um it seems to
be primarily women that we think of
their worth is like in their
reproductive abilities and if they don't
have reproductive abilties somehow
they're their life isn't worth living
their pain isn't worth hearing um their
life isn't worth taking care
of and only seems to be women that it's
okay for a doctor or whoever to say what
they are going to want in their personal
lives in terms of how many kids they're
going to want like that's not a medical
thing that is a personal decision
thing so the bill um and I'll go through
the details of the amendment being
different than the bill and how this
bill is different from previous
iterations but um the bill has always
been written in a sex neutral way
because this has affected uh two men
that I've heard of
um
but it does affect women far more and
the problem is cultural and this isn't
even a New Concept like we know in in
days of your doctors were discriminatory
based on race or based on what have you
and we had to take action to make sure
that those cultural things didn't seep
into the medical care and so this is
just an extension of
that but um it it's really telling
because when my husband got a visectomy
he got it not because he had like you
know some sort of cancer or condition
that he needed the vasectomy for medical
reasons he got it CU he wanted it and
not only did he not experience any push
back and was asked well you know you're
too young what does your wife want or
what would your future wife want not
only did you not get pushed back on
getting this voluntary vasectomy but it
was paid for by the
government it was paid for by the
government the government pays for um
vasectomies as it turns out but a woman
who has a debilitating condition and
mine was the least debilitating of the
stories that I know of a debilitating
condition where they are bleeding they
are in pain who needs this treatment and
a doctor will admit yes this will cure
your problem who has it covered by her
insurance can still not get the
treatment because say but you're going
to want to have babies even though you
say
no so getting to the language um there's
only ever been in the two hearings that
this has had over the two iterations
there there's only ever been one person
that ever showed up in opposition and
that was the med uh the Catholic uh
Hospital who at the time the very first
iteration of this bill uh it did not
limit the medical conditions to 18 and
over and so they were worried about 18
and under so this bill brought it up to
18 um the previous iterations of the
bill had it in the patients Bill of
Rights which turns out is more about
facilities so um according to the
feedback I've gotten actually from my
very very bipartisan this bill has
always been bipartisan and actually
there are more Republican wait there
there's been a lot of Republicans on the
bill and there's Republicans on it now
but um based on that feedback I've moved
it out of the patient Bill of Rights um
and then
so the first part basically guarantees
that if you have a medical condition for
which a treatment that happens to leave
you sterile or unable to Bear children
or unable to have children even
temporarily that the physician cannot
deny the treatment on the basis of age
the number of children marital status or
the physician's speculation of the
patient's reproductive intentions
contrary to the patient
statement so the doctor can't say no I
know you said you don't want to have
kids but I know better than you you you
grown person in your 30s for
example um it the doctor can of course
always deny for medical reasons if it's
not advisable to do the doctor can deny
for payment payment reasons the doctor
can deny even for religious reasons but
just not these kind of condescending
patronizing reasons um that have nothing
to do with medical situation of the
patient and everything to do with
cultural and sociological uh
ideas um the second part which used to
be the third part of the bill uh holds
harmless any physician that Pro provides
a sterilizing
treatment that uh gets a assigned waiver
of informed consent from the patient so
you can still sue them for malpractice
they left for steps in you what have you
you cannot sue them for making you
sterile when that is exactly what you
signed that you wanted and just for the
record this is what I said to my doctor
if I regret this decision every surgery
has a regret rate every single one if I
end up regretting this I'll ad stopped
that's fine that's on me give me
something to
sign so the amendment before you is I
really like it because it gets really
really narrow there were questions
previously like two years ago about well
how does this affect trans issues and I
wanted to make sure that we weren't
conflating these issues the reason I put
this in is because so many women
thousands of women across the country
have experienced the same exact thing
like me and the more I talk about it the
more wild it is how many women it is
because literally I'll be talking to a
group of five women one of them like oh
my God that happened to me so it really
has nothing to do with trans issues I
get very uh narrow with the definition
of medical condition here any disease
disorder syndrome symptoms genetic
predisposition or family medical history
or the state of being
medicated um that either affect the
reproductive system or make reproduction
not advisable for either the medical
interest of the patient or for potential
children and then I also include
reproductive care before I was very
focused on surgery um now it's very
narrowly defined as very specific
surgeries but also medications that
affect fertility I was unaware but
apparently uh there are medications for
diseases that if you are a youngish
woman a doctor will not give you even if
you're suffering from the disease
because that medication makes you uh
unable to have children so
um online the support was something
something like getting close to 300 in
favor many of those were very moving
stories of women who almost lost their
lives um to for in opposition there was
no written testimony for the opposition
so um it it's really crazy how unspoken
this issue is and how widespread it is
so with that I'm happy to take questions
I may have forgotten some of the details
I wanted to bring up about the language
but I'm happy to take questions
representative Markel yes thank you for
uh taking my question
um one question ma'am uh as I read this
statute uh this
proposal
um if your if this proposal requires a
physician to treat
um would this have the effect if
assuming there's a procedure which is
going to render somebody sterile and
let's say there's a conflict with the
religious belief of
um uh a physician who may for example
have a sincere religious belief that
this kind of thing should not take place
uh two so I have a two-part question
first can a physician refuse to treat a
patient okay or prospective patient and
second what is your view on a First
Amendment challenge to this based on a
good faith belief that treating somebody
are uh preventing them from having
children uh is a violation of their
first amendment religious beliefs thank
you for the question I thought I
answered it in my testimony but I didn't
go into detail so this is very very
specifically and I'm I'm working off the
amendment but the underlying bill is
almost the same language this this is
saying that the physician cannot deny
for these specific reasons religion is
not on the list so to the extent a a
physician is currently allowed to deny
for religious belief they can still do
that because I did not add religion okay
to that list now the question becomes so
if they like I'm sorry I don't believe
in this first of all there is no
mainstream religion whose Dogma believes
that sterilization is um immoral or a
sin but also it begs the question right
if you don't believe that giving
medically necessary sterilization is
within your personal religious beliefs
why are you becoming an OBGYN when that
is like a major part of the
job okay but having said that yes to the
any extent they are currently able to
deny for religious beliefs I don't touch
religious beliefs it's literally only
they cannot deny for the age of the
patient if they're over 18 they cannot
deny for the number of children they
already have their marital status or the
physician speculation on what the person
wants to do with their reproduction okay
thank you anyone else
representative plaz
off thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I I don't have
Amendment uh at hand do you you
mentioned that you define uh what is uh
medical condition is uh do do I
understand that the definition is not in
the bill but it is in the amendment
because I couldn't find those that
definition in the original Bill the
the definition of medical condition
right it was this is why I really prefer
so that you just got the amendment
that's section three at the bottom so I
read it out loud but I'll do it again
it's one sentence for the purposes of
this section medical condition means any
disease disorder syndrome symptoms
genetic predisposition or family medical
history or the state of being medicated
that either affect the reproductive
system or make reproduction not
advisable for either the medical
interest of the patient or for potential
children so if you're going to
genetically pass on a terrible terrible
debilitating disease then that would be
covered for example um if you're on a
medication which means that or for
example we we focused a lot on
reproductive issues PCOS pmdd
endometriosis other uh reproductive
diseases but one of the people who
testified before you before and I there
was probably over the two years like 10
different people who testified here
including men including men uh
Republican members of the house two
different ones that testified about
their inability to get uh voluntary
vasectomies but we had so many stories
one of those stories and she isn't here
today unfortunately was a woman who had
endometriosis knew that she didn't want
to have kids asked for hysterctomy they
denied her repeatedly she then developed
uh lupus
which you really should not have kids
when you have Lupus you really shouldn't
have kids if you have cancer um it's
really really dangerous um she got an
unintended pregnancy with lupus very
predictably miscarried but in the
process is now at the age of 27 will
forever be on renal medication because
she is in permanent renal failure as a
result of getting pregnant while having
lupus so that is a example of a
condition that's not specifically a
reproductive condition
but you definitely should not get
pregnant while you have that condition
and if the patient knows that they don't
want children honor that honor that the
doctor's job is to deal with the medical
well-being of the patient the patient's
job is to deal with what they want in
life whether or not you want kids is not
a medical decision so um going back to
that yes that's in the definition and
that makes this a lot uh more tailored
than the previous version which was just
any medical condition
um which could have included a wide
range of conditions that really we
weren't trying to capture in this so
this is far more
tailored Al representative Weber thank
you very much thank you thank you for
taking my question it doesn't sound like
this is working particularly well but
we'll try anyway um following up on
representative palazzo's question uh
would you also read for the benefit of
those who didn't get a copy the
definition of appropriate reproductive
care because the sentence you just
highlighted plus this second sentence is
really the gist of your Amendment so
that would be helpful yes uh so I just
it has two definitions that were not in
previous itations of this bill medical
condition and appropriate reproductive
care for a medical condition appropriate
reproductive care for a medical
condition shall include the following a
hysterectomy which is the removal of the
uterus ectomy which is the removal of
ovaries oric ectomy which is removal of
the the testicles salpingectomy which is
the Fallopian tubes an endometrial
ablation which is the removal of the uh
interior of the lining um of the uterus
which usually means that you'll be
sterile or any medication that may
affect fertility and as I said in my
testimony there are medications that
make you less able to have children at
least while you're on them and yet like
I believe malaria is one of the
conditions for which there's a treatment
that they will give you if you're a man
but they will only not give you not
because it hurts you as a woman because
it but because it'll make it hard for
you to get pregnant and if you don't
want to get pregnant and you need that
medication it should be your right to
say you know what I'm fine I don't need
that uh please treat the
condition could I have followup and and
as a followup just because we're
discussing what was in Prior con um
things and is not in this one am I
correct in in
that all the provisions of Prior
iterations which
required a physician should they not
want to do the procedure to refer them
to somebody else those have all been
removed in this iteration right so the
the previous iterations had three parts
the first part is if you have a medical
condition for which a sterilizing
procedure is a legitimate treatment the
doctor can't deny you on the basis that
the doctor knows better than you what
kids you want the SEC the third part was
holding the doctor harmless for doing
that the second part was if you wanted a
voluntary treatment a voluntary
sterilization like my husband got paid
for by the federal government um that
the doctor can still deny you but the
doctor would have to refer you to
another doctor who would do it and
accepted your form of of payment that
has been removed there is no voluntary
sterilization left in the bill it is all
medically
necessary thank you anyone else
representative
Tes uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I agree the
volume is low on this today um I'm
wondering on um Roman numeral 2 line 17
uh can you
explain um and maybe also for the
lawyers in the room uh a patient who has
signed an informed consent or a waiver
um can you distinguish what those would
be or would it be helpful to be and or a
waiver you are indeed going in to the
lawyer side of things it's it is how the
lawyers at OS determined to write that
um so that specific or was not something
I specifically requested um my
understanding is if you're signing a
waiver then you're signing saying that
whatever I don't I may not know what's
going what's happening to me but I'm not
going to sue you and the informed
consent is I you have told me what I'm
going to experience and I'm consenting
to this and in either case whether
you're giving away your right to sue or
you're saying I understand in either
case we're protecting the
doctor anyone
else okay thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is
representative Lauren helig cig rather
from Durham
thank you very much and thank you for
taking my testimony um for the record I
am Lauren selig I represent straford
County District 10 which is the town of
Durham New Hampshire at the home of unh
our Flagship University um and I am uh
very much in support of this bill um
just quickly in terms of my own history
after I had my second child I sought to
get my tubes tied the doctor asked my
husband's permission didn't know why he
needed it told him my husband was
welcome to have more children just not
here um you know so ultimately the
doctor after I told him if he didn't do
the procedure properly I'd be happy to
take his house and his boat made sure
that I was you know fine but for um 10
years uh once I turned 45 I started
asking doctors if I could have a
hysterctomy because I was having so many
problems with my cycle which I'd had
since I was 11 years old and all kinds
of supplemental side effects including
severe migraines with my cycle that
would be
debilitating um it took me 10 years six
doctors to get someone to actually
listen to me I'm actually two days uh
two weeks and two days post having
hysterectomy um but it's literally taken
that many years for me to be able to get
to this procedure um after having told
doctors what my symptoms were and why I
felt it was a necessary procedure for
myself so I finally met with the doctor
who actually took the time to listen to
me ran some tests determined that in
fact I really did need to have a
hysterectomy and upon doing the research
of looking at my uterus and tissues
afterwards determined that there was
blood going in places it wasn't intended
and I don't need to get graphic with you
but the blood was not going through my
uterus just to be clear it was going
into other parts of my body that were um
causing me to have extreme symptoms
including low iron levels um and other
kinds of things now for 10 years I had
been telling doctors I had a problem and
I needed to have this resolved and for
10 years I had doctors say oh you're
fine it's just part of being a
woman male doctors female doctors didn't
matter I had one doctor tell me oh well
when your body stops producing estrogen
you stop being a woman I'm really sure
that's not how it works um to be clear
I'm still a woman even though my body's
not making estrogen right now um but so
I support this legislation I think it's
important that we have doctors that
trust patients I think we need to trust
women to know what their bodies need and
to allow people if they need a procedure
like a hysterectomy to be able to get it
without having to go through as many
ridiculous Hoops as there are at this
point and I'm happy to take questions
before I go exec bills okay thank you
any
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is Jade flad
from
eeping did I pronounce the last name
correctly is that ma'am is that yeah
yeah yeah go good morning f l a d f l a
d
yep uh good morning morning my name is
Jade um and I am here today to support
this bill um much like Ellen um it's
pretty much the same story um I've known
that uh there's a problem with my cycle
since I can never remember since I was
12 um told my whole life this is what
women go through deal with it blah blah
blah um my entire life I've known I've
wanted to have children so I suffered
through um and and had two beautiful
little girls um after the birth of my
second child my husband was offered a
vasectomy at age 30 no questions asked
um it was something that he wanted the
doctors were all for it um not an issue
around the same time my cycle started to
get worse and I was pretty sure I had
endometriosis I had all the symptoms and
signs um and when I went to my
doctor same thing what if you want to
have children uh more children
and I told them well my husband has a
vasectomy that's not going to happen now
they my doctor had the audacity to say
what if you get remarried what if I get
remarried who cares I'm in pain I am
suffering there is a week out of every
month where I cannot be a mother I
cannot work I cannot take care of my
house I can even take care of myself um
after 5 years of begging at the age of
35 when I finally aged out of my Prime
fertility I was offered um a hysterctomy
um during the hysterctomy they found
endometriosis uh all throughout my
abdomen and um it was a
really crappy feeling waking up from
surgery knowing that I've had this issue
my entire life and it took me begging
and pleading for years for them to
finally open me up and realize oh you
have one of the most debilitating and um
painful uh diseases that a woman can
experience um
we really need something to support
patients especially women because there
are thousands of us that I that have the
same story it's so sad um when I was
denied my hyam the first time um much
like Ellen and others I went online to
look for support and came across the
same thing um I was denied because what
if I wanted to have more children I was
denied because of my age I was denied
blah blah blah I don't understand
how this is legal I don't understand how
women are being denied appropriate care
for their pain and for their suffering
based on an opinion of somebody who
doesn't even know them um the doctor's
job is to take care of their patients to
make sure that their quality of life is
a good good one um and I really feel
that and it's really sad that something
like this needs to be put in place
simply
because doctors have opinions Society
has opinions on whether or not women
should be pumping out
babies thank you you're welcome ask
question
questions seeing none thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is Charlotte
Montgomery
good morning my name is Charlotte
Montgomery and I need a
hysterctomy I started bleeding
uncontrollably at the age of 10 and the
pain that I experienced was so terrible
that I ended up passing out and even
then at the age of 10 I was told I was
being dramatic this is normal this is
what every girl goes through and just
need to get up and get on with my day as
time went on I spent a majority of my
time during those years on the cold tile
of my bathroom flooor ring in agony
sobbing unable to get up due to the pain
I experienced I was later diagnosed with
Stage 2 endometriosis and adenomiosis a
condition in which the only cure is a
hysterctomy I went on to search for
doctors who would perform this needed
medical procedure and I was denied again
and again and
again I had had doctors mock me I've had
doctors laugh in my face and tell me
they are happy that I've been denied
this and Meanwhile my quality of life
has plummeted I am no longer able to
live a normal life I know I am no longer
able to work a normal job I cannot even
lift over 10 pounds otherwise my uterus
falls out I have had to be wheelchair
out of stores after collapsing in aisles
from extreme blood loss and from my
uterus falling out which has done so
many times more than I can count now
I have been begging doctors to help me
for years
now and I have bled miscarriage levels
of blood every single day for over half
a year only for a doctor to look me in
the eyes and tell me think of your
future husband think of your future
children and they always say this this
is a common theme across all the doctors
I have encountered they tell me to think
of this hypothetical child a child who
will know not ever exist because I'm
already infertile they tell me to think
of them their lives their lives what
about
mine I am a living breathing human with
a quality of life issue my dreams have
been stripped for me they're stripped
from me daily as I become sicker and
sicker a hysterctomy is my only chance
to save my quality of life and yet I am
denied it I come to you today as a woman
as a woman who is in debilitating Agony
On The Daily I come to you as as a woman
who has had to beg on my hands and knees
on a cold Hospital floor for a doctor to
take my pain
seriously and I beg you today I beg you
to support this bill and I beg you to
pass it so that women such as myself can
finally receive the medical care that we
so desperately need thank you thank
you any questions yes representative Paz
off thank you uh Mr chair and thank you
for story sorry that you have to go
through it um my understanding uh this
bill if enacted it will affect uh only
New
Hampshire
and uh if I remember correctly some
other states might be more open to idea
of treatment that um uh might uh have
side effect of
sterilization so do you know if it's
easier to get the treatment in other
states and if it and if
so
uh what stops
uh for example we know that some uh
medical marijuana patients in New
Hampshire they shop in other states
because it's easier or cheaper uh in in
this case uh is it possible to do the
same and just to go to another state uh
thank you that's a great question so
I've actually lived all across the
country I've lived in New York I've
lived in South Carolina I've gone for
medical care not only in New York and
South Carolina but also in Florida I've
sought it in other states and I'm
currently seeking in Connecticut even
though I'm already living in New York um
the thing is doctors all over they have
the ability to deny even if you need the
medical hysterectomy such as myself I
have gone to doctors all across the
country and it is the same thing all
over I have not been able to receive the
care that I need in any of those States
so hopefully if this bill does Pass New
Hampshire could be a leading voice in
that anyone
else representative
Theus thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question I just want to know
how old you are now and um were you
seeking before if you're 18 or and older
when did you start to seek the medical
care that you need yeah I'm 19 years old
um I have been searching for a
hysterectomy since I was 17 um so I've
been going to many doctors since then I
think it's about six doctors that have
denied me thus far um and yes but I'm 19
but i my symptoms and my intense pain
began when I was
10 anyone
else see saying no one thank you thank
you no one else has signed up to testify
on HB 606 does anyone else wish to
testify seeing you want to testify in
606 okay by my representative Betty gay
okay yeah you can fill it out after you
testify thank you or we do need
it oh
okay well I'm going to assume that the
amendment has the same intent because I
couldn't get the amendment the same
intent as the bill which is to allow
patients to
receive U yeah move your mic a little
closer representative I hate that when
you can't hear people
okay I'm apologize that I'm going to
assume the amendment has the same
purpose as the intent of the bill and
that is that you're protecting you're
protecting
providers uh who are uh will will have
proof written proof that what services
they provide to a patient were what the
patient really wanted and they cannot be
held uh liable for permanent
sterilization if they do a procedure
that renders the patient unable to have
children which sounds like an open and
shut sensible thing to do so that people
don't get frightened from doing
something that obviously they would give
an awful lot of thought to that's a very
serious repercussion of surgery but if
you need the surgery that should be your
choice and you shouldn't have to worry
that you're going to be le legally
liable uh or somebody legally liable
upset with you so this just sounds like
a really good protection for both the
patient and the
provider okay thank you anyone have any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you don't forget the pink
card anyone else wish to
testify okay seeing no one I'm going to
close the public he on HB 606 the next
hearing is scheduled for 10:30 on HB 621
FM and we will
um okay we're going to um we have about
20 minut minutes before our next hearing
so we're going to go into executive
session and consider HB 455
okay
does everyone have a copy of the
amendment I know you need a moment to
look it over I just want to make sure
you got a
copy it's very simple I think my
explanation okay representative Weber uh
do you want to move your Amendment thank
you Mr chairman yes uh did we open the
executive session we did okay um I would
like to move uh
Amendment
0645 H and I would like to speak to my
Amendment please okay is there a second
to the motion I will representative
Maser seconds and representative Webby
are
recognized thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for a second um the issue here
was that with respect to the Medicaid
enhanced program for pregnant women and
children
uh we had provided that the uh
Department of Health and Human Services
was going to report to the Health and
Human Services oversight committee on a
quarterly basis going forward uh on how
that program was working it's only just
gotten
started and so uh sorry about that and
so
um what the original Bill did was said
that the quarterly reports would last
until
2027 and then end and what the amendment
says is that uh on line 10 beginning
July 1
2027 the reports shall be submitted
annually which means that we keep a
record of what's going on with the
program and it lines what then will be a
program with which we have some
experience up with the kinds of
reporting that we ask for on health and
humans Services oversight for any number
of other department Pro uh programs so
there will be a report going forward
doesn't have to be every quarter because
we will have had two years worth of good
uh careful data about what's been
happening and so I would um ask that you
adopt the amendment and then react
positively to the
Bill thank you any other
discussion seeing none uh when clerk is
ready I would ask him to call the rooll
motion is ought to pass on Amendment
d645
h r merer
yes R mlan yes rep damus yeah rep um
Hill rep palazov
yes clerk votes yes rep marel yes yes
rep McGrath yes rep kessing yes rep
Weber yes rep McKay yes rep Woods yes
rep Palmer yes rep TZ yes rep lontine
yes rep hartnet yes rep Lucas yes and
rep McDonald yes
voted 17 to zero motion
passes thank you representative Weber do
you wish to make another motion I do I
would like to move out to pass as
amended by Amendment
45h on House Bill
4555 is there a
second representative Maser seconds any
discussion on this
motion being none and the clerk is
ready motion again is ought to pass is
amended on House Bill
455 rep merer yes rep mlan yes rep damus
yes rep uh Hill is not here rep poov yes
clerk votes yes rep marel yes rep
McGrath yes rep kessering yes rep Weber
yes rep McKay yes rep Woods yes rep
Palmer yes rep taes yes rep lontine yes
rep hartnet yes rep Lucas yes rep
McDonald yes vote is 17 to zero motion
passes and I would move consent any
objection to
consent I will do that thank you
yes excellent
okay uh do we dare to consider another
um Bill we still have almost 15 minutes
representative lontine would you object
to moving with of going have with 7:31
or
okay okay that's fine okay
um just looking for something that might
go quick
um I know there's several amendments
pending on a number of the other bills
and some of them are a bit controversial
so okay I there's nothing leavs to mind
here so why don't we just stand in
recess for the next um uh what 13
minutes or so we'll be in recess thank
you
so has representative Hill uh replac
representative kofalt just today oh just
today
gotcha repl anybody well I mean I know
that his duties have changed so right
yeah well
unless
e
e e
the hearing uh and the uh committee uh
next up to be considered is HB 621
FN and um I recognize the prime sponsor
representative Bill Bolton
thank you Mr chair and thank you members
of the committee my name is
representative Bill Bolton and I
represent the towns of GRA Grafton I'm
Grafton District 8 representing
holderness Plymouth and
Ashlin and I'm here today to um speak in
favor of the bill 621 FN and and I want
to touch into some background about me
I'm the former State registar excuse me
before you continue can anyone everyone
hear him okay a little
closer
okay oh wow okay how's that better yeah
I think I nailed it so um I'm the former
State regist uh in uh
1999 I was given the position and I took
my position very seriously and my my
position itself was basically to oversee
the collection of birth death marriage
divorce and Fetal death records and to
deonate them to uh individuals and
organizations that have a direct and
tangible interest in those
records and uh for me the um my job was
taken very seriously and I became
concerned because our department our
Bureau was within the uh division of
Public Health Services and health and
Human
Services and there was an issue uh with
dissemination of some data that I
thought was outside of um privacy
actually it kind of it was basically not
compliant with how I picture or how I
picture how um the law allowed me to
protect the data and I had long
discussions with um the New Hampshire
City and town clerk Association
regarding my and their role in
disseminating data and we discussed
actually moving to the Secretary of
State's office um and in 2005 we put
forward legislation to uh move the
division of Vital Records Administration
to um the Secretary of State's office
and I worked under uh Bill Gardner and
and Dave
scanland and when we did that we
essentially shut off the data for 2
years
um there was a nightly push of all the
records of birth death marriage divorce
to Health and Human Services from our
secretary of state
servers and when we shut it off I mean I
was pleased um I was concerned about how
um data was um basically um utilized by
many agencies that we had no control
over and there was some discussion about
how uh we penalized
people that might release data and on
many occasions I've heard the fact that
Health Human Services operates under
Hippa and Hippa itself is um initially
was just a misdemeanor at best uh maybe
a financial uh issue as well they
tightened up the I guess first offense
that you may have to like pay I think
20,000 or 50,000 based on the infraction
that you release data um whereas in
Vital Records we we didn't do Hippa in
fact um when I was State registar there
was no other
um you know registration area in the
nation that utilized Hippa because we
all uh had a penalty of a class B felony
so you know I was basically concerned
that we might have releases of data
without our ability to basically put
people in
jail so I did pursue um bills most
recently um a couple years ago and I was
after shutting off the sharing of of
identifiers from birth death marriage
divorce and that bill failed and this
bill considering I was mostly concerned
I guess with the information regarding
the birth mother during birth
registration um I felt that at least I
had a to submit a bill that would uh
allow the birth
mother the ability to basically shut off
the data sharing of her very private
information with other agencies to
include Health and Human
Services and you have a copy of the of
the birth worksheet and actually uh
Kristen Kennis and our state registar um
provided that to me and I I handed it
out but some of the information you can
see on there um um are such items like
other terminations of pregnancy anytime
after conception date of last other date
of last other termination of
pregnancy indication from one parent oh
um and then there was like alcohol usage
and um oh
goodness let's see if I
can oh
now I'm not looking for Sy but I had
cataract surgery uh yesterday and I
surprised myself by I understand what
that's
like um so even domestic status I mean
you know a birth WEA may not like the
fact that the fact that she might be
like unmarried to follow her to all
these a agencies where this data is
shared
um alcohol use during pregnancy
um yeah a number of other pregnancy
outcomes um infections present and or
treated during this pregnancy like goria
syphilis herpes chamia Hepatitis B C and
other and even um information like the
attendance name and title uh that means
that the physician's name would be
shared as well and I'm not certain if he
appreciate he or she would appreciate
that too and
then um there was concern that there if
this data was shut off that or basically
if the birth mother checked a box
perhaps saying that she does not want
this
data being ident all the know all the
identifying information um she wanted
that to be shut off when the data gets
re-shared
um you know I found that important for
the birth mother to be able to do that
and there are currently the ility for
that mother to opt in such
as uh Social Security admin
Administration uh they have a program
called enumeration of birth and on the
birth worksheet they have a a checkbox
saying yes um I'd like for the state to
provide the Social Security
Administration data from this form
issued to the SSA and that would allow
um her the ability to do things remotely
that otherwise she'd have to go into to
a social Social Security Administration
office and do it you know dragging a
baby in toe and so I
mean there is a familiarity with
checking a box saying I do want to have
this data going forward or I do not
um
so that's basically um why I'm going
forward with
um at least making certain that the
birth mother on a birth worksheet would
be able to stop data or identifying
information to go to the many many
agencies that you know this data is
shared
to
um that's pretty much it I'll take
questions if there are any thank you
representative thank you very much uh
and thank you for taking my questions uh
or my question so just to be sure I'm
understanding the workings of the bill
clearly all the data is going to be
continued to be collected so the data is
there and resides at vital
records and what the bill is ensuring is
that when data is shared with the
Department it's simply done on a
deidentified basis is that correct
correct um
and when we say deidentified
is
there it it says all personal
identifiers shall be redacted so am I
right in thinking that's name
address yes um well how about how about
things like age
or I'm just trying to find the extent to
which the redaction I think I had I had
a brief conversation with our state
registar earlier and I think we would
need to probably provide an amendment to
show exactly which Fields need to be
redacted that would be very helpful
thank you very much and yeah but um like
age would not be redacted I mean there's
a lot of like uh so it's very helpful to
have like age or I mean there's a lot of
um individual um pieces of information
that would be most helpful for data
analysis and followup but
other questions representative Lucas and
then representative mlan thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
um could you for my benefit and perhaps
others listening um follow the
completion of this
worksheet from when that
happens I guess my question
is where and when is the worksheet
completed well the State regist can also
I mean I'm I'm an old State regist she's
a young state registar so I mean she's
more um I guess you know regardless it's
completed in the
hospital followup follow up and as long
as that as this work sheet is in the
hospital setting is it subjected to
Hippa um the worksheet
itself the information on the worksheet
I mean it's it's my opinion that that
worksheet contains information that um
should it be released then it would be
subject to a classy felony so it would
be uh because that's essentially a vital
records
document um may may I the hospital is um
operates under Hippa correct
yes
and what happens when this worksheet
leaves the hospital is it still covered
under Hippa where um from where it's
headed next our state regist I can
update you for most recent law but it
used to be it's probably still is
maintained in the
hospital the department may be able to
answer that also they they'll be
testifying soon yeah um one one more
followup uh when it reaches the
Secretary of State's office um are they
hippoc compliant okay no doesn't
reaching mean meaning that it's uh
basically saved in the software and
electronically transmitted to the
division Vital Records Administration so
are they hippoc compliant no because
their their data is protected by a class
B felony should you release that which
is quite more more significant than a
hippo
violation thank you you're welcome
representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and have a
couple of questions so um this this is a
a pretty comprehensive form
um does the the birth mother have to
fill out all of this you you're talking
about questions of how many prior
children did she had does she use drugs
what was the form of payment all that
stuff so like I said it's there's a lot
in
here does the birth mother have to
answer all of this or can she choose not
to
thank you for asking that question
because um a couple years ago I think it
was like rep or Senator rosenal
submitted um a bill that essentially um
cleaned up the fact that the form used
to have a class B felony should you not
provide the answer to the questions
we're asking you and that class be
felony language got
removed and you know so the mother can
basically refuse to answer you know any
any these questions and therefore um it
she won't suffer a classy felony however
the the hospital um provides all that
information as well so all the
information that the birth mother thinks
she's stopping from being transmitted to
the birth worksheet it gets saved in
Vital
Records um even backfilling the
information that she didn't want to have
go so okay follow
follow up so so maybe have a couple
follow-ups based on that answer so if if
that's the case and she's choosing not
to answer this stuff but it is being
collected anyway um would would that not
be maybe a more
appropriate a direction to take the bill
because as I understand what this does
she already has or she thinks she has
the right to opt out but what this is
doing is this is separating you know the
ability to link the child and the mother
together and and so I'm just kind of
wondering what what is the in what what
is the intent of that versus maybe
addressing the other point that you
bring up where she thinks she's opting
out but really she's not so what are
your thoughts on that so if she were to
say no do not share my identifi
identifiable information and apparently
um I would like to work with our state
registar to come up with the actual
fields that that would mean so once that
happens the DHHS or whoever that would
be you know receiving this data from
Vital Records would have all the
information on the mother on the the
baby without the identifiers on you know
from the mother or the father so it
would be deidentified and
th this is very similar to how the data
in Vital Records gets shared with a
national Center for Health statistics
because that's been going on for decades
and we send or vital record sends birth
and death data to
nchs and that birth data is deidentified
you know so they get what they want
which is all the statistical information
that allows them to do you know research
and provide um output uh interested you
know people to see outcomes of certain
things without the mother's name or
identifiable
information like I said it's been going
on for decades so there are a number of
other agencies within CDC that also
receive data um through the Department
of Health and Human Services and it's
unknown how they safeguard that data so
you know it's kind of like of a concern
as well
but I don't know if that answers it or
offers up more questions or I'm actually
going to chew it around in my head for a
bit thank you very much okay
representative L montin thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um so much of this seems like
uh that a lot of the data that's
collected um should be going to Health
and Human Services can you explain go
back again and explain why uh V record
was moved to the Department of State and
not Health from Health and Human
Services this is historic um I arguably
there may be more safeguards involved
but there was um some releases of data
that I was aware of that um you know
really concerned me and um it was
probably
less I guess
overseen back and less of an open um you
know Quest it was
basically I mean the thing that really
kind of like um got me more concerned
was the fact that and this is back
historically so in 1999 I became the
state regist in 2005 I believe is when
um RSA
5c um
became the vital records uh statue under
uh Secretary of State and there was a
release a basically a C you know CD
containing all the the data of birth
death and marriage to go to a a
Massachusetts uh researcher and it
contained you know the records of my
daughter and my son and I'm thinking
okay well there were no constraints on
this release it was basically you know
not under the table but without concern
about the privacy of of the people on
that
CD so that was probably the one that
really kind of sealed it but um you know
I'm more concerned about the ability of
privacy on behalf of a birthmother to
keep her her data private or at least
her you know identifiable so the DHHS
would still get the data um it just
wouldn't get the
identifiers representative Paz off thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question uh it was helpful to see what
kind of data uh could be
concerning uh so first part of question
is a racial statistics uh could be
concerning that both uh mother and
father uh have to provide data about uh
race and uh certain uh maybe ethnical
groups and uh if you could uh
explain in general what drives this data
collection because maybe some of it is
federally mandated or some of it is uh
for purpose of DHHS statistics and some
of it may be needed in hospital for care
for mother and baby so what drives this
data collection to to your
knowledge um primarily um the questions
that are asked are part of a uh you know
National worksheet that uh Most states
uh abide by and again I'll refer to the
our recent um State registar uh to
describe any changes but there have been
questions that we put on the have put on
the form that were unique to the
Hampshire um you were talking about race
think you know race is like a a
universal you know question that's asked
um I don't you know that would not be
considered like an
identifiable in my in my opinion
um so that should go with all the other
non or deidentified data um there was
well what was the it was early hearing
detection
um you know there were there were a
couple of um questions that were added
to the form that were specific to
um you know New Hampshire and there was
like an early hearing detection field we
wanted to make sure that U babies were
tested for their ability to hear before
they were
discharged and I I I think the last
hearing similar on a similar Bill there
was a a question or concern that that
data would not you know go to the
DHHS and any form that contains um
information that were kind of unique to
DHHS and their programs would just be I
would assume just still be pushed to uh
DHHS similarly as the question for um
enumeration at
Birth I mean if there is an agreement to
push it we'll push it or they'll push it
and again the department will be
testifying shortly and the advances
those questions
also um anyone else representative mlan
again just a just a final followup and
um because I know that the department is
going to be testifying but I won't have
a chance to talk to the prime sponsor
again so um but so the the the bill
allows for the fact that I'm
notifying um the mother how the
information is going to be used and the
mother has um the option to provide or
not provide except things like you know
the the about the child itself because
you have to have citizenship and all
that stuff so given the fact that
they're notified and they have an option
to not provide some of the information
do you have any concerns about the
separation again of the the mother from
the child in terms of being able to
provide follow-up
care okay the mother and the child will
both be like you know
provided all the information of the
mother and child will be sent to
DHHS but oh sorry except for the fact of
identifiable information and then your
question is like so say DHHS indicates
that there should be like some followup
with yes Mr Jer can I just sure try to
clarify with it so yes so I think you're
on to it so so when it's redacted it I
think it has an anonymized statistical
value um but it ceases to have value you
know to provide care in a specific case
because everything is all now redacted
so um so I'm just saying is there any
concern that that might erode some of
the delivery of services um and is it
necessary given the fact that the mother
is informed that it's going to be shared
and she has the opportunity to opt out
of providing a large chunk of the
information so I'm presupposing that um
the the testimony from DHHS will
indicate that that is a
concern but um the focus on you know
this bill is personal
privacy so I you know I think um
predominantly um you know if
there I would imagine that if DHHS were
to identify and this is like you know as
followup with our state
registar to see if there might be some
need for
exceptions um in a critical medical
nature you know I think that could be
worked
out okay any last questions
representative
tez thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um are you aware of
any data breaches that have occurred in
the last 10 years of in New Hampshire no
I think um Florida you know they had all
their birth records um you know hacked
into uh this past year and I'll go ahead
well a follow follow yeah follow up um
would your privacy concerns be addressed
if uh the function moved back to the
divisional Public Health Services since
that's where it resides in Most states
if not all so I think the um location of
idal Records
is relatively unimportant I think my
concern though is you know should it
reside back in DHHS there might be kind
of an or more of an argument to um be
able to tap into MCA or Maternal Child
Health um you know not nurses and you
know people that that go go train
hospitals and you know capturing data
correctly but the the the the issue
would still remain that uh the privacy
of the S you know of that information
should be retained within Vital Records
even the vital records was in a
different agency so if the birth mother
wanted that her name redacted uh her
identifiers then that is how it shall
be okay so no other questions um thank
you thank you very much
also signed up to speak is
representative Paige bman from
nsha thank you Mr chairman and thank you
to the committee and thank you sir for
pronouncing my last name you've gotten
good at that so my name is Paige B
I am a legislator I'm a State Rep from
NASA W 4 I am also a Maternal Child
health nurse for the last 15 years and I
am the nurse who was in the hospital
talking to the mom and doing these
hearing screens the newborn screening
Etc um I I first want to say that um as
a nurse I absolutely understand the uh
the importance of privacy you know any
healthc care professional has Hippa
ingrained in them from day one so that's
always a very very big concern um
unfortunately I think that this bill is
much too vague and holds too many risks
of unknowns for us to be sure that we
will be able to as representative McLean
said or I'm sorry I forget who it was
but the ability to connect mom and baby
um we're really concerned about that
given the vagueness of the bill now I
would actually like to read a letter um
from uh some somebody who is not able to
be here today his name is uh David llam
he is a PhD and MPH and uh
he uh is a lifelong resident of New
Hampshire with a family Legacy of Public
Health his grandfather served as mayor
of Manchester and uh he served as New
Hampshire State maternal and child
health epidemiologist for 14 years 2003
to
2021 and continues to work in applied
Maternal Child Health epidemiology at
the state and National levels he earned
his PhD in public health from John
Hopkins University uh the top School of
Public Health in the world and was
inducted into F Beta Kappa for academic
Excellence he h uh we will get this to
you but he is submitting this testimony
in opposition to this bill and I'm going
to read in his voice one introduction
and background during my nearly two
decades as New Hampshire's Maternal
Child Health epidemiologist I worked
extensively with birth certificate data
to shape and evaluate programs that have
improved Health gums for countless
mothers and infants accurate linkable
birth data is critical to understanding
atrisk populations securing Federal
funding and ensuring that targeted
interventions reach the families that
need them most while privacy is
undoubtedly important this bill
undermines essential data sharing
practices by providing an opt out that
removes personal identifiers from birth
worksheet data this legislation
jeopardizes the state's ability to
fulfill its Public Health obligations
and may place especially vulnerable
mothers and infants at risk two the
importance of birth data and identifiers
the maternal mortality review linking
birth and death records I do have a
little more if I can go on uh I'll give
you another 15 seconds can wrap it up
well there's a lot and you will get it
we do have concerns in terms of we can
read it you know if you want to just
summarize that's what yeah in newborn
screens and hearing tests identifying
disparities one of the biggest concerns
is our impact on federal funding and
what I would like to bring attention to
uh the committee is really to look at
the fiscal note because there's almost
two pages of risks that DHHS has
identified I'm not sure if it's in what
you have but it is uh in the bill online
so I really that yes yes just to make
sure that you take a look at that um and
I can end there I'm very happy to take
any questions especially if you have
questions on how things work in the
hospital interacting with moms and baby
Etc if not totally fine but uh very open
to questions if you have them thank you
so much thank you any
questions representative palaz off uh
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so I see that facility
worksheet includes some information that
I don't see in mother's worksheet so is
it something that uh mother answered
before in the facility or is it is it
coming from some other sources uh for
example I think some um some information
that uh we might deduct about abortion
so for example cannabis use I
in facility worksheet on page six but
not on mother's worksheet so where is
does this
information came from the information on
abortions I'm sorry could you repeat the
question yeah yeah for example I I don't
see uh
um induced
losses uh of pregnancies I see this
language on facility worksheet but I
don't see it on M's worksheet or for
example on page six I
see uh if uh penal substance exposure to
cannabis uh so and on mother worksheet I
see only only a question about alcohol
exposure so was it was there some other
question yes to mother that is being
used by facility or is it from uh some
other sources I don't have the
worksheets in front of me um I'm not
sure if this answers your question but I
would like to add that with the birth
records the information that not the
birth records but the health history
that we get there is um it's called
gravit and that we get a series of
numbers that lets us know how many times
has this person been pregnant how many
live babies did they have and there are
a few numbers there that indicate any um
miscarriages and there's another one for
abortion so I'm not sure if that's in
there but if there's a spot that says
gravit parid with numbers that is what
would be indicated there that's where
that information would
be representative Lucas if I could
follow up Mr chair on representative
pv's question um there are two parts to
the worksheet that seem to be one coming
information coming directly from the
mother and another coming from the
facility and I think the question is how
is that information reaching the
facility if not through the
mother I believe that that's coming from
the medical records my understanding on
say the unit is that there's usually a a
secretary or somebody who's filling out
part of that information from the
medical records and then we also go to
the mother and get the rest of the
information that is needed thank you MH
I would like to say I have this is
personal experience I've never had
anybody concerned about that most people
are very happy because they want to make
sure that they're getting the
information that they need especially
from the testing that happens they want
to make sure that they can be reached
and they want to get a birth certificate
and I think as written we're not sure
how that would impact
that representative
pazo thank you Mr Chan thank thank you
for indulging my second question so in
Ma's worksheet uh many fields have
unknown uh uh under it so um in your
personal experience getting information
from mother and we heard that uh certain
penalties were removed from ma for not
providing information so uh do mothers
have uh opportunity to refuse provide
certain information
but provide other information or are
they being enticed to provide all
information available and
possible as a nurse I can tell you that
maybe one of the friendliest units is a
postpartum unit um we're very aware of
Mom's recovery her being tired and um
you know when we go in there and ask for
information
we're if they say I don't know or I
don't want to give that information I
could not imagine somebody that I've
ever worked with trying to entice them
or or coer them again I haven't been
there for every mom but that would be my
experience as a
professional any last
questions saying none thank you thank
you so
much okay we have several people from
the Department of Health and Human
Services here today to testify on the
bill uh first up will be Whitney Hammond
and um Courtney Kane and Shi
chaa all right oh okay you guys can hear
me am I close enough yep we can he you r
hi um thank you chair McDonald and
members of the committee for allowing us
time to
testify um I want to introduce myself
first I'm Whitney Hammond I'm the intern
deputy director for the division of
Public Health Services I'm joined here
today by Courtney Keane our bureau chief
for family health and nutrition and I'm
also joined by J uh chawe chaa who is
our bureau chief for public health
statistics and health informatics we're
coming here today to speak in opposition
of HB
21 I um appreciated a lot of the
questions that have already been asked
about the birth worksheet I wanted to
just do a little bit of a level set for
everybody to try and clarify some of the
questions that have been asked already
so the birth worksheet is um something
that is completed by the Hospital
Birthing Center or attending providers
to collect key birth details as you guys
have kind of sused out there are two
components to the birth worksheet one is
called the mother's worksheet and for
any of us um who have had a baby you may
be familiar with it I remember um a a
person coming in in the hospital when I
had children with the green worksheet
and saying what's the baby's name going
to be and what's your name and what do
you do for work um so that's one piece
where you're very clearly aware of that
data is being captured and actually just
anecdotally I asked if I could leave the
hospital without a name for my baby and
was told that I could and I would just
need to follow up so that gives you a
sense of the flexibility just to the
point of you know these are very
friendly places where moms are very
empowered to make decisions um the
second part of the birth worksheet is
What's called the facility worksheet and
that's the part where there's a lot of
additional information about a mom's
access to prenatal care a lot of
information about the actual delivery
and information about the child's health
and well-being at Post delivery that is
generally information that is gathered
from the facility via What's called the
electronic health record and that's
information that many moms myself
included have provided over the course
of prenatal care and so you're not
necessarily sitting there with your
newborn baby saying yes I use tobacco
you know some of those other questions
this is information that's already
gathered under a hippoc covered
entity um this information is really
important um it's submitted then from
the hospital or provider to the
secretary of State um where you've heard
about the Privacy protections that
they're beholden to and then through a
memorandum of understanding those data
are then shared with the Department of
Health and Human Services I want to just
highlight for people because again this
is a little new to me myself New
Hampshire is the only state that has
this kind of a design and setup for our
Vital Records all other states house
those records under the health agency um
as a good sort of bureaucrat myself and
a and a real person who supports privacy
and and has that need and desire for
myself I can tell you that from a hipper
perspective the fewer people that touch
and access data that are not necessary
the safer and more secure it is right so
as few people that it passes through the
safer and more secure um the purpose
behind that total birth worksheet the
mother and the facility is to then
enable the production of a birth
certificate so most of us are probably
familiar with the birth certificate and
if you think about it it's an incredibly
important uh piece of identification for
children um that's going to be the the
main way that they can uh verify their
identity it's the way that they can
verify who their actual legal parents
are and you'll hear from others um in
future testimony about how the
department uses that for things like
connecting child support and child
protection and then another big piece of
the the value of the birth certificate
is that it establishes citizen
ship um we understand that this bill is
largely intended to protect privacy and
um as you've heard both vital records
and the Department of Health and Human
Services really uh value the importance
of privacy and have a number of
different Security safeguards in place
to protect privacy including which I
know has been brought up the fact that
the Department of Health and Human
Services is a HIPPA covered entity and
what that means and I think some people
were getting at with their questions is
that the department is beholden to the
same federal and state standards as that
provider who is collecting the data and
submitting it as a part of the facility
worksheet so we are beholden to those
same standards of privacy and
security um there's also I wanted to
draw people's attention to another bill
in session currently called s sp92 and
that's actually very much focused on is
it okay if I keep going sure you would
ask for five minutes and we can give you
some we usually allow three minutes a
person so okay thank you you can have up
to nine if you need it okay thank you um
so s sp92 is currently in session and
proposes removal of personal identifying
information from the birth worksheet
prior to submission to the CDC Centers
for Disease Control and prevention which
operates the national Vital Statistics
system so there's already a bill
underway that would address some privacy
concerns with regard to as the data
shared
federally um I wanted to cover some of
the major reasons that were opposed to
HB 621 and many of the others who are
prior testimony has covered that there
could be some major unintended
consequences related to this
legislation um while it's well- intended
it would very much harm Public Health um
it would impact our ability to do our
newborn screening program which I'll
have Courtney speak to in a moment um
removal so there was a statement said
that all information would be shared
with the department but this bill
specifically would enable the data to be
shared without personal identifying
information which you know to questions
that were received would absolutely make
it so that the department cannot do the
work that we do to serve individuals um
so it would actually not provide all
data that is necessary for us to operate
public health programs
um I do want to draw people's attention
information on the impacts of this
legislation to um the department in
terms of access to Federal funding are
articulated in that fiscal note
worksheet those are the known impacts
that this legislation would have and
that it was costed at about $12 million
annually in federal funding um and
there's much broader impact to funding
to the state of New Hampshire that would
result from this
legislation um it's important to not
that a part of the value of the birth
worksheet to the department is actually
in helping us to do Fraud and Abuse
investigations and the actual impact of
funding would would be to all of us as
taxpayers so in addition to Federal
funding being impacted this would also
impact the Department's ability to do
our work under state
law
um let's
see so if I have a couple more minutes I
do want to delve into a minute and 40
seconds 40 seconds um a minute and 40
seconds do you want to I would like to
just highlight one of these really
important programs that would be
impacted by not getting personal health
or personal identifying information to
the
department good
morning we often see on the highway one
death is too many this is a critical
mission of newborn screening one death
or disability from a heritable condition
especially caused by incomplete
information is one death or disability
too many the newborn screening program a
vital public health program screens all
infants born in New Hampshire unless the
family chooses to opt out for 37
heritable conditions that might not be
apparent at Birth the primary goal of
newborn screening is early
identification and intervention allowing
for timely treatment that can prevent
serious health issues developmental
or even death if the program does not
receive the birth mother's information
there is no way to know what infants are
not
screened without the match of the
mother's information to the infants
information critical Health
interventions may be delayed and the
lives of newborns with heritable
conditions would be put at risk the
program screens 98% of infants born in
New Hampshire and follows up on over 500
infants annually with approximately 35
identified with a her heritable
condition each year it is essential that
the department receives complete birth
data thank
you do we have like 20 more seconds to
talk about 20 more seconds sure thank
you yes thank you so uh DHHS the
department and the Secretary of State
are also both the state agency um under
the state so we use the same doit
Department of Information Technology
standard in our infrastructure other
than that for the Department we work
with doit to adopt the National
Institute Institute of standard and
technology which is n ISD 853 standards
for security and privacy controls for in
uh for information systems and
organizations so other than hipot the
department act uh did take does take uh
another level of pro of protection in
the um privacy and security control the
department also implement the data
governanc and data management system um
approach and also the data stewardship
approach for user access control and
also review process and other than that
in addition each users or each um DHHS
state employees will need to take the
cyber security and information security
annual training as well as monthly
training to ensure that they all follow
not only the hipop but also uh the
National Standard and the state standard
to protect the information and privacy
so this is a part that I would like to
address with the department does take
another layer of protection and approach
for the privacy and also the record
level not only just for the vital
records but for all the health uh
Records that we overseas in the
department thank you questions
representative paza
uh thank you uh Mr chair and uh thank
you for taking my question so um you
show that certain
programs could be
affected but I think uh sponsors of the
bill believe that uh uh some uh non
nonidentifiable data will still be
provided and maybe it will be enough for
at least of some of those programs and
also uh similar question about new Bor
screening
program if ma already can uh if there's
already ability to opt out and and uh by
giving them Second Chance of opt out I
don't see how it destroys the program if
parents already if some parents already
opting out of it and now they I might
opt out of sharing uh some
information maybe percentage will
slightly increase but I don't see it as
a threat to the whole program because
they're already not
100% thank you so I'll start by
addressing the second point and then
I'll go back to the first so um this was
interesting information to me many of
you may have heard about closures of
Labor and Delivery units in the state so
we have less and less access in certain
areas of the state so actually an
increasing percent of women are giving
birth outside of a hospital facility so
part of the followup that the newborn
screening program does is with
individuals who gave birth not in a
hospital facility who may not have opted
out of newborn screening but may not
have been offered newborn screening um I
think the percent is somewhere it's
actually a little bit shocking I think
it's up to 25 to 30% of birds are not
had in birthing facilities in the state
um so that's part one part two um I had
mentioned uh s sp92 which talks about
limiting personal identifying
information being submitted as part of
the CDC data submission and the
department feels that that's an
appropriate level of um you know
safeguard for privacy without impacting
the funding to these different programs
and Services I wasn't able to touch on
the national Vital Statistics system is
a system that's used to actually monitor
Trends on uh maternal and child Health
in the country and then sets priorities
for funding and then more importantly
decides where the funding will be
allocated and so New Hampshire's sort of
slice of that pie is informed by the
data that's submitted to the National
Vital Statistics system and that also
helps to even have medical underserved
shortage designations and designates
facilities for higher Medicare um
reimbursement rates so again it's very
critical that we be able to share that
data with
CDC thank you follow
up thank you Mr chair uh uh it's uh a
separate question uh so we heard uh
about four different um organizations 30
or4 so can you provide the full list of
organizations that
receive uh this data so we heard that in
New Hampshire division of Vital Records
originally receives it and then it goes
to Department of Health of Human
Services we also heard from you that it
goes federally to CDC and I don't know
if National Center of health statistics
is the same organization or not uh does
it go anywhere else and could you give
the full list sure um so I maybe uh
secretary of state would have a more
inclusive list but I know um and
actually jawe you may be able to speak
to I it's my understanding that the so
the data goes from the hipac covered
entity which is the provider goes to the
Secretary of State which is um then the
steward of the data throughou it is
given to the Department of Health and
Human Services that's the extent of like
what we're testifying on the use of it
as I believe submission to National
Center for Health statistics is done by
Secretary of State not not the
Department of Health and Human Services
and that would feed into the national
vital statistics system so there's
there's really only those there's to CDC
and there's to the Department of Health
and Human
Services and yes so based on the New
Hampshire law RSA 126 uh 24 25 um the
department also performed as a kind like
a uh as a data release mechanism for the
health related research so for the vital
records data currently we have a vital
record privacy board that is a
collaboration between the department and
the uh Secretary of State uh the
division of V Rec Administration it's a
a review board to review all the health
related research request that require
more granular Vital Records uh data for
their own research with IRB approval
with all the very comprehensive
applications um and also address the
purpose how they Safeguard the data
though this kind of request will all go
to to the V record privacy board uh for
us to release after the Board review and
approve and also after the data sharing
agreement established then the
department would be able to release the
data as necessary as request to the
researchers so that is another channel
that uh um for the health related
research um we do have this mechanism to
release the
data representative Castle W and then
representative mlan
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I I'm looking here a
lot about what it says here in RSA
5-c and the question that I have is
specifically to the question let's say
the questions on this sheet What
specifically would be required because
under the RSA it looks like name age and
sex is all that's required so can you
give me on depending on who it is yeah
so um in the written testimony that we
passed around we flagged what we
considered to be the technical defects
of the legislation and one of those um
that was called out was the definition
of minimum amount of information is not
clear it's used in lines 710 and 20 of
the legislation but it's not defined and
um as you've heard from like the newborn
screening program personal identifying
information would be a minimum amount
required to do that program so that's
unclear and would need to be articulated
follow up could you clarify what that
personal information might be based on
this to you yes so from the uh
statistical report uh standpoint that uh
we will need to have like a raise as
necessity and also data birth in order
to calculate the mother's um age at
Birth as well as the town Zip Code or
and also the uh residential area so uh
residential address excuse me so that we
can do GE coding uh to identify the
census TR sensor block for more granular
statistic reporting so those type of
personal identifiers is what will be
needed uh what would be needed for the
statistical reporting but for other
identifiers such as um infant in
newborns names and mother's name date of
birth Etc are utilized by not only
newbor screen but later on you will hear
the uh testimony from other divisions uh
under the department that they use that
for the eligibility for public service
Etc representa
mlan yeah thank you Mr chair and I
actually have two questions one on
providing of information and the second
on providing of services so do you know
at at what time the written notice would
be given to the mother and the reason
that I ask is because a lot of the
personal information that goes really
deep is on that that second part um and
you're saying that's actually not
provide that's provided from the
facility itself and so I'm wondering um
the mother being notified may not want
to provide this but it's already all
being done anyway even without her doing
it so does she have an opportunity to
review this final worksheet to say I
didn't provide that and can I get that
gone or is it too late at that point so
I'm just trying to understand the timing
and since some that stuff doesn't come
from her I don't want that but it's
there anyway you know you know what I'm
saying so could you maybe talk to that
and then the second question would be
about providing a service is going a
hold
on um
so the data that's collected in in the
electronic health record I can't speak
to what each provider or office or
Hospital does in terms of dis you know
notifying an individual about how
they'll use the data but certainly a
woman has a choice of whether to share
data at any point in time you know um
some of the things that the facility
reports I would guarantee that a woman
is declining to share anyway with her
provider so they all they already have
that choice at the point when they're
having that conversation or getting
clinical care is generally like the
context in which they're Gathering that
information in terms of the proposed
legislation and the in the um
requirement around notification that is
not clearly spelled out when or where or
how that notification would occur so it
could certainly occur at the point of
data collection which would be between
the clinician and the the mother or it
could be at that point when somebody's
just given birth and they are with their
newborn baby and trying to you know go
home and it could be there that they're
being shown this worksheet and making
decisions about um I do want to say
though that the the law was changed I
believe last year to an enable women to
decide not to supply certain data so
that's already an option so um and then
when the birth worksheet submitted it
would just indicate you know declined to
provide this information so so they're
notified as it's being
asked and so the second question with
respect to the services provided I kind
of understand um your point about we
have a lot of births that are happening
outside of healthc care facilities so I
can understand how throughout a extended
chain there may be gaps in being able to
provide service um
but for those folks that are born in a
hospital setting um I I would think you
know they're right there so um does the
linkage problem exist even at that point
or is it
just those born outside of the
hospital thank you for your question so
it happens outside of the hospital so
there is linkages that happen at the the
hospital as far as newborn screening
goes that is after so a test is done for
these 37 heritable conditions it is sent
to our contracted laboratory to run the
test from there we need mom's
information to link with the results so
that we make sure all babies are
screened who want to be screened just
put follow follow up so does this mean
then that you go and you do the testing
on the Bab
and you've got the info but I have no
way to notify the mother so the program
notifies the provider okay so what it
means is that if we don't have Mom's
information we don't know what babies
are not screened so we would only
receive those who are so there could be
a chance that a baby would go home and
missed by accident and those are the
ones that we are trying to catch through
the linkage thank
you anyone else representative Castle
ring just a quick followup on the
previous question uh when it comes to
opting out you mentioned is there any
can they opt out to anything on that
list or is there anything that they
can't so as it's my understanding and
I'll let y way chime in um there are
certain components that are related
specifically to issuing the birth
certificate that are not optional so
that goes back to my story of like I had
to give my kid a name you can't opt out
of naming your child because then you
can't produce a birth certificate but
then uh the majority of what's in the
facility worksheet is not tied to the
issuing of a birth certificate and can
be opted out of I'll just let Jo chime
in if anything's
missed that's correct that is our
understanding as well uh so if the model
does not fill out uh the race as
necessity then you know there's no
penalty on that but they do need to
based on the current um bus worksheet
that they do need to provide the
accurate um the truthful information to
be utilized on the certificate so they
do have the chance to not to fill it out
whether they smoke whether they how how
how tall they are or how heavy they were
when they pregnant so those are the
information they can um they don't need
to provide and then um I cannot speak
for how that will be recorded recorded
in the v record statistic system but it
will be unknown or not available this
type of
information okay any last question
questions seeing done okay thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak from the
Department is Karen
Hebert good morning morning my name is
my name is Karen Hebert uh and I am the
director for the division of economic
stability at
DHHS and I'm here joining my colleagues
in opposition to this bill uh which
would essentially lead to an inability
to access
uh data points that are documented at
this time on the birth record
worksheet this would have adverse uh
impacts on services from this division
in a couple of different programs so the
division accesses vital records
information including birth death
marriage and paternity status via the
system that includes the file
date the mother's name father's name
Child's first middle and last
name the date of birth of all parties
whether a paternity affidavit has been
filed and when and the mother's marital
status at the time
the department must be able to verify
the legal relationship between an
applicant for Public Assistance programs
and a child for whom they are applying
on behalf of this includes but is not
limited to the temporary assistance for
needy families which is a cash program
supplemental nutrition assistance
program which is food stamps child care
and
Medicaid the child's birth record is the
verification document required by the
federal government for eligibility in
these
programs self attestation is not
acceptable the department must also be
able to verify the legal status of a
child born to a
non-citizen If the child were born in
the United States then the child's birth
record is the verification document
required by the federal government for
eligibility for public assistance benef
benefits without access to this vital
record data the state will be at risk of
uh federal financial penalties or loss
of federal funding without this
verification benefits to individuals and
families could be
denied for services and child support
one of the primary responsibilities of
this program is to establish parentage
and paternity also referred to as legal
fatherhood paternity establishment is a
necess first step in the child support
enforcement process in cases where a
child is born out of
wedlock we must be able to establish the
relationship between the mother and
child and father and child access to
vital records information by this
program is required by the Social
Security Act under title Roman numeral
4-D the Department's Child Support
Program serves approximately 30,000
families at any point in time in a year
the department collects if I may I under
underestimated the child support program
collects about $78 million annually for
the families that we serve for some
families this is their only source of
income the unintended impacts of this
bill would impact Children and Families
from receiving financial and medical
support that is due or owed to them the
department cannot establish a legal
order for child and medical support
without first establishing and verifying
paternity in addition to providing a
basis for legal orders for child and
medical support establishing legal
parentage can provide important
necessities and entitlements for that
child please wrapping up I will that
includes soci Security benefits pension
benefits life insurance benefits
father's legal history medical
history without being able to verify
this information the state would
ultimately see an increase in the
utilization of Public Assistance
benefits as well as Financial penalties
by way of the tanif block
grant okay thank you any
questions representative
mlan so I haven't seen Senate Bill 92
but there was um discussion about it
earlier and that it does an anonymize
data um have you seen that bill and um
uh the people who spoke previously seem
to be supportive of it does it address
your concerns I will have to take a
closer look at that particular bill I
apologize I've have not reviewed
it any other questions representative
Castle ring thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question has there ever
been a case where you've had an a parent
that has opted out of any information to
the department like for what you said is
vital for the Department to
have yes so the birth record worksheet
as I said will contain the names of uh
both parents um however we have
certainly seen circumstances where the
mother will refuse to provide who she
believes is the father's name um and uh
or sometimes providing the name of the
husband so in those circumstances there
is a process in place to S reconcile
that should that parent then later apply
for public assistance benefits or Child
Support
Services you're welcome anyone else
saying no one else thank you thank
you also signed up to speak from the
Department is Matt
Hayes thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee uh my name is attorney
Matthew Hayes I'm a Staff attorney with
the Bureau of Child Support Services
which is under DHHS um also their
legislative liaison um I believe
director uh Karen Herbert's testimony
covered pretty much all I was going to
say so um I'm certainly happy to answer
any questions committee might have but
otherwise I have nothing further to
add thank you does the committee have
any
questions yes representative paulov
uh just uh thank you uh Madame chair and
thank you for taking my question do you
have any further uh comment uh on my
question
whether uh
unidentifiable uh aggregate data will be
enough to support some of the programs
uh
mentioned thank you for the question um
in terms of the medical data I'd have to
defer of my colleagues that had already
provided quite a bit of testimony um my
my testimony would have been geared more
towards the vital statistics and the the
birth certificate issues that uh
director Heber already
raised thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you next next we have Janelle
leagan did I say that right
okay good my name
is yep can you press the red button and
pull it closer to your yeah there we go
there we go thank I got to learn the
rules
here good morning my name is Janelle
leian I am the attorney for and general
counsel for for the
Department's estate Recovery
Unit I want to talk about a few things
today that I think are different from
what you've heard but one thing I want
to emphasize and I cannot emphasize this
enough all of the department every
single one of us is restricted by
numerous confidentiality Provisions in
the law not just Hippa um there are
numerous State statutes as well that
protect protect data and we take it very
seriously the estate Recovery Unit is a
federally mandated practice to recover
from Medicaid correctly paid under
certain circumstances from Mostly
deceased recipients of
Medicaid it is something that is
required for the state and federal
partnership in the Medicaid Program to
exist to accomplish this we must have
birth death marriage and divorce records
in order to properly carry out our
federally mandated
function Federal this is so because
recovery must be done consistent with
the federal law the state law as well as
probate
law if the estate Recovery Unit fails to
properly perform its function not only
will recovery decrease and at this point
I'd like to add that at this point on
average we recover about $6.7 million a
year approximately two to $3 million a
year it goes to the state general fund
that recovery that we do is on behalf of
the federal government the state
government and the counties if
recoveries decrease because we can't get
the data that we need we not only expose
the state to reduce General funds but we
also expose the state to litigation by
the federal government most seriously
but if we're inappropriately recovering
from individ ual as well the federal
government has the capability and has
done so in other states to come in to
and shut down medicaid where the state
has not properly not in New Hampshire
but where a state has not properly
engaged in a state recovery
practices so I guess the key point I'm
going try to keep this as short as I can
the key Point here is that we're not
just collecting this in information the
department is not collecting this
information just for the heck of it or
willy-nilly we are performing an
essential Public Service in every way
not just what I do but what all of my
colleagues have said before
me it's important for the public good
and for the public
welfare there are so many safeguards
already in place we do this we take it
seriously and it's essential and
important work to be able to not be able
to have this data will shut so many
things
down so I guess I'll keep it at that if
there are any questions thank you
representative we Weber sorry and I'm so
sorry I had to step out for a couple of
minutes but could you give me just a few
examples of what would have to be shut
down so I will give you examples my
colleagues have already spoken to their
programs but if I cannot get proper
birth records for example I will not be
able to perform Medicaid recovery
properly I need to be able to know
whether someone is survived by a spouse
or not I need to know who that is same
as Miss Hebert testified to earlier self
attestation is not something I'm allowed
to
accept I have to have the official
record I need to know who surviving
children are and I need to know their
status because it is inappropriate for
me to recover when someone is under the
age of 21 and they are the surviving
child of a recipient or when that child
is blind or disabled I have to get that
right in order to carry out what we do
properly and I take it very seriously
thank you thank you representative
paulov thank you Madame chair thank you
for taking my question so you were
talking about proper birth
records so and but uh Bill sponsor here
he outlined several different uh types
of information he's concerned with so do
I understand correctly that your concern
is mostly with uh domestic status and
marriage and you wouldn't be so concern
if mother say says that she doesn't want
you to know that she has clamidia or
some other
diseases well my colleagues do have
those concerns and they're very legit
legate concerns that is not something
that affects this unit my
unit thank you representative mlan so
just to clarify then the portion of the
bill that you're really concerned with
is the last portion that is the
memorandum of understanding that
basically is limiting the sharing not
some of the stuff where we're having the
anonymized about the others the whole
memorandum of understanding basically
throws a
wrench it does I have to be able to link
mother to child and father to child
marriage divorce I have to be able to do
that to do my job properly yes I'm one
small Cog and a bigger wheel but it is
important thank you any further
questions thank you thank
you right next I see Francesca Hennessy
and Lindsay
bio from d HHS yes yes good morning good
morning and how much time do you need
for the both of you three minutes three
minutes total yes
okay my name is Franchesca Hennessy I am
the um administrator for fraud waste and
abuse at the Department of Health and
Human Services and I have here our
special investigations administrator
Lindsay bio and so we are I want to talk
about how we use personal identifiers in
investigations for special
investigations and how we would be
hamstring without those personal
identifiers so if we don't have the
social security numbers of parents and
children we cannot identify families who
should or should not be in a household
this would infect our investigations and
it would ultimately affect our
recoveries um we would not be able to
put or the staff would not be able to
put cases together um other examples of
this is if we don't have a Social
Security number to validate income with
employers we would not be able to prove
income and again put an income based
case together um we also use in property
information such as where um a person
individual lives um this is Vital
Information for a special investigations
case if we don't have that name and date
of birth and where they live we can't
put that case together um if we don't
have pii including name social security
number and date of birth and address we
may pursue the wrong individual based on
limited information which could cause
delays in our investigation again I end
all of these with it would affect our
recoveries to the state um and again I
know we talked about what are those
personal identifiers the ones we are
concerned with since it's not defined in
the law are social security numbers
address date of birth um is there
anything else Lindsay um I'd just like
to add all the uh all the information on
the mother's birth worksheet such as
those deeply personal questions those
aren't something that we have access to
in the system all we have access to are
those those pii um identifiers linking
the mother the child the father together
as one unit all that other data we don't
even see when we look into the
system and that's all I have to
add thank you does the committee have
any questions
saying none thank you thank
you all right next we have Neil
Kirk good morning Madam chairman and to
members of the committee good morning
for the record I'm Kirk I live in we and
I'm representing myself I'd like to make
eight points Point number one if you
look at the 34 uh 25 um copy of the bill
you'll see there are two pages of uh
listing of federal funds that may be
lost varying from 25 12.5 to $25
million um please note that there are
two assumptions on this on which that's
based number one that the feds will in
fact deny the money and number two that
100% of the of the mothers in this state
are going to opt out under the bill both
of them are totally
unrealistic if you're serious about
looking at the money then require DHHS
to provide letters from federal
officials stating that they will not May
which is some cases will cut the funds
or leave the financial consequences to
house finance because if this bill
passes because of the fiscal Noe it's
likely to go there point two
the assumption that all birth mothers
are going to opt out is unrealistic the
department of safety has a variety of
opt outs for your photograph and for
your social security number and when I
checked several years ago uh
approximately 3% of people were opting
out of those Provisions 3% not
100% point
three
um the world will not end if some
portion of new mothers opt out indeed uh
the Department states that it has a
procedure in place when new mothers
refuse to provide information but notice
how deceptive this is because while the
mothers May provide the information the
hospital is going to fill in the blanks
where they can so it's only some
information that in fact the mothers
refus to provide that don't end up on
the bir
sheet um
so DHHS is already dealing with the
purported loss of Revenue and lack of
100% participation from mothers who
refuse to provide information
so why should the department object if
it tells new mothers that they may opt
out why keep the practice a secret it's
terribly
unfair point
four the department can fulfill its
public health and other responsibilities
with almost the same degree of accuracy
with this amendment assuming the 3%
optout rate Five personal privacy is an
important value in our state in 2018 80%
of the people amended the State
Constitution to provide that quote an
individual's light right to live free
from government intrusion in private or
personal information is natural
essential and inherent unquote six this
bill implements that Amendment it's a
determination by the general court
balancing the state's need for personal
information and citizens desires to
maintain their privacy in that
information seven an issue with the bill
that is that it doesn't set out the
specifics of the written notice in my
experience the department has a dismal
history 20 more seconds if I may a
dismal history of dealing with
legislative required notices its
practice is to make the notice too
complex for a reasonable person to
understand to make it so lengthy that no
one will take the time to read it let
alone understand it and three to bury
the notice in a sheath of papers so that
no one will ever see it let alone read
it I have proposed amendment which deals
with these issues and I will submit it
to the chairman thank you Mr chairman
that completes my testimony and I'd be
pleased to answer any questions if there
are any okay thank you representative
Weber I got to number seven as being the
department should um the bill should set
out specific notice um I think I have
lost number
eight oh I have an amendment that deals
with the
issue okay and I will present that to
the chair I'm sorry I only have three
copies but okay it has the specific
language
that um here I'll I'll read
it since this doesn't take away from my
three
minutes uh the Noti is as follow quote
the information you are asked to provide
about you and your baby is shared with
several state agencies for statistical
and other purposes if you wish to limit
this information sharing and have all
personal identifiers removed please
initial in the space below quote I wish
to limit the disclosure of personal
information blank space for initials
this notice shall be on a separate piece
of paper or separate page and shall be
in at least 14o
type thank you thank you anyone
else representative CLE ring and then
representative mlan thank you Mr chair
so I I want some clarification if you
can help me with understand this so I'm
looking at this birth sheet I'm hearing
from the Departments and different
things that that there is the ability to
opt out but I don't see it anywhere
listed on this form that you can opt out
of any of this information so could you
clarify that a little bit based on your
testimony there is no specific provision
in law or on the form to allow you to
opt out but human beings sometimes
refuse to provide information in that
case there is a provision in in on the
form as to how that information will be
provided and by whom if the information
is available from another source so a
mother who refuses to provide
information um does not know that the
information will be provided from this
other source and she may leave the
hospital thinking I protected my privacy
but in fact she hasn't does that answer
the question or did I miss something
yeah I guess I guess to extent to that
is there any other Provisions in the law
that you know of that would basically
make it to the hospital adding that
information would be against the
law no um I could see a law suit on the
basis of the Constitutional privacy
Amendment if that information were added
but there's no statutory provision the
the problem with with this information
with this situation is that uh the
department can deal with this even if
there's no criminal penalty as was
stated by the department there used to
be a used to be a felony to provide the
information to refuse to provide the
information that is eliminated now so
women uh May refuse to provide it but
they don't realize that it's going to be
provided on that form and distributed
however based on other sources so it's
somewhat misleading there is no
statutory provision for an opt out this
bill provides it that's the purpose of
the Bill thank you representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I remember
working with you on that Constitutional
Amendment so um but with respect to some
of the concerns that were raised about
the the linkage of the mother and the
child and also recognizing your concern
about the fact that the woman thinks
she's not providing the information not
realizing that another source is would a
better approach not possibly be um to
have this final birth sheet which the
mother may not see um have to have that
authorized you know and you know provide
some clarity because she's not seeing
the finished document would that not be
a better approach um because because I'm
not so worried about I am concerned
about the linkage but I'm also concerned
about you know the fact that this is
information coming from another source
and I don't know about it and I just
don't know how how anything we've heard
bridges that
Gap I think that would be an improvement
but I don't think it really solves the
problem on its own you'd have to do some
other things as well
um the the department seems to think
that it should have this information
because it is doing God's work and in
some respects it
is but the real responsibility for one's
health is oneself and one's Health Care
Providers not the department you heard
testimony that the department uh on
newor screenings was getting all of this
information and it went to the provider
and it's the provider and the mother who
need to decide what to do it's nice that
there's a back stop that the department
provides but the primary responsibility
for our Medical Care is ourselves and
our provider not the Department of
Health and Human Services the department
wants this information to fulfill what
it considers to be important obligations
and they
are but there's a balance that has to be
struck this bill is a small step in the
direction of writing that balance um I
take your points I think they could well
be added to this bill as an improvement
but I still think the basic fact that a
woman can opt out now should be known to
women and not just based on the few who
say I won't give you information I think
all women are entitled to know what they
have a right to
do any final
questions saying none okay thank you
thank you Mr chairman
uh the hour is noon and we still have a
few more folks to testify on this bill
and then another one actually three more
before the day is over so in order to
keep on schedule as closely as possible
we're going to once again to our rolling
lunch and members are invited to go to
lunch at their convenience so that we
can try to stay as close to our en time
as possible our next signed up to speak
on this bill HB 621 is deputy secretary
of state Ain Hennessy
so the five minutes would be for the two
of you I take it thank you thank you Mr
chair uh my name is Aaron Hennessy I am
the deputy secretary of state and so you
can get to your lunch I brought my dep
entire department up with me um you may
have another pin card for Kristen you
don't need to call her again um with me
is Kristen Kennison Martino uh she is
our state Register of Vital Records um
the um Department State takes our job as
um our constitutional Duty um as listed
in the New Hampshire constitution of
keeping the records of the state very
seriously um and one of the fundamental
records um is birth records um Kristen
is happy to answer any questions you
have about the vital record collection
process um dealing with this bill I know
that you are not the finance committee
but I just want to let you know that we
have had discussions with the sponsor of
the legislation as he mentioned and
depending on how the amendment um comes
out there may be additional um cost to
this legislation for our department
related to system
changes and thank you my name is Kristen
Martino former Le keniston and I am the
state registar and director of Vital
Records um I just wanted to let you know
that we are taking a neutral stance on
this but I wanted to provide some um
important information on some of the um
consequences and potential
contradictions with some statutes just
so that we can be clear um so first of
all we have no concern with providing
the birth mother with any information
just letting her know that this is what
happens with your health information we
are happy to work with the Department of
Health and Human Services to draft up a
document such as that from an
operational standpoint we have no
concern with adding an opt out feature
both to the birth worksheets that would
be checked off and signed by the mother
and then into our data collection system
so if you hear me refer to something as
Nan nean is our data collection system
that's the software that we use for all
vital records in the State of New
Hampshire so you you hear me use never
and that's what that is um so we
respectfully request um that a
definition of personal identifiers be
provided which I know we've already
touched on um with representative Bolton
and others have stated that we do need
that to be very clear within our
statutes we don't have administrative
rules we follow the the statutes and so
therefore we need them to be very clear
and concise when we're following
them um there are some possible
contradictions and the unintended
consequences so by limiting the
disclosure of information you should be
aware that it might contradict RSA 5c4
Roman numeral 2 and 3 the handout that
just came around I've highlighted the
areas that there could be a potential
contradiction so I won't go into it too
in depth but essentially there are
existing statutes that say that the
Department of Health and Human Services
does have direct intangible interests to
all of our records and then that Co um
that pulls in on their statute which
says that they should have 24/7 access
to our information so um by having
something that says we can't give that
information but then something that says
we should be giving that information
could potentially create a
contradiction um and then just to touch
base on the birth registration process
is it leads to my next concern with a
possible contradiction um after
everything is collected on these
worksheets the worksheet is given to a
birth registar at the hospital that
birth registar is uh has been vetted and
is accessed to our system to enter the
record into nean and they go through and
they enter all of the information on
everything never is used to not only
create the birth certificate for the
child but to also collect all of that
statistical information and then
disseminate it as it should be
disseminated whether it's to the federal
government or to
DHHS and then from there once it's in
the system and we have it it's the
division that actually gives that
information to the dep Department of
Health and Human Services the one of the
things that I'm concerned with with the
way that this current language is
written it has removed the onus from the
division of Vital Records to submit the
information to the Department of Health
and Human Services and now has put it on
the hospital it's saying that the
hospital is going to redact this
information before it goes to
DHHS um the what that contradicts with
is 5c4 which is my duties as a state
regist which allows me to set up this
never system and also how our
information is not only registered but
collected and then disseminated so that
needs to be looked at and addressed um
it it's almost as though it removes us
from the entire registration process I
know that wasn't the intent of the bill
and speaking with the sponsor but when I
gave this bill to my staff to review
they even shared that concern they they
were nervous that it meant the hospital
couldn't even put the information into
our system so we just respectfully
request that that is looked at and and
possibly revised um and then on a final
note just um to make sure that the
effective date it we're given 60 days we
would we would like to see that maybe up
to 120 days to comply that just gives us
more time to make our software changes
and to reprint work as needed so I try
to move through that as quick as I could
for you if you have any questions let me
know you have 5 Seconds to
spare any
questions and you covered it so well
there aren't even any questions very
good
excellent also signed up to speak is
Courtney Tanner from Dartmouth health
hi there for the record uh Courtney
Tanner from I'm the senior director of
government relations at Dartmouth H um
and um I was G to say move the micophone
of course uh we have concerns with the
bill as drafted um as has been stated
there's another bill Senate Bill 92
that's that will likely be crossing over
to this body that we um have been
working on and would like to continue
work to work on with this committee um
some of our concerns are stated in the
written testimony that I submitted uh
and is being passed around from um one
of our providers Daisy Goodman who um is
the recipient of um does a lot of work
does Direct Care work with um women who
are navigating substance use uh
disorders and other health challenges um
and Daisy also is doing a lot of
extensive work in our rural communities
and has concerns that if this bill moves
forward as introduced that a lot of the
um work that we're doing to understand
the maternal Health needs in our state
will have to fall away because we won't
be able to um track and and understand
where the areas of opportunity for
improvement are um as introduced
questions some of the questions that I
have around the bill are um which
personal identifiers questions around
what information needs to be kept in the
medical record I'm very concerned about
requirements for us to enter any
information into our medical record
because not only is that an
administrative burden but a medical
record is a um technical uh record that
needs to be um we need to keep really
careful uh information in there and so
um opting out is an is uh just what
would need to be kept in the medical
record would be a question um and then
question questions around you know what
is the minimal amount of statistical
information you've heard that testimony
before this this morning now we're in
the afternoon and would have those same
questions and concerns the only other
point I would raise up as you know
Dartmouth health is is a system um one
of our system members is chesher Medical
Center and that is a um Medicare
designated health uh Health hospital and
we receive an enhanced Medica Medicare
reimbursement rate because of it because
of its rural designation
and when we're not able to track our
maternal health and health Improvement
Trends in the state um we are at risk of
losing that designation here um in New
Hampshire and so that's a really
important um designation so that we can
ensure that there's access to care in
our rural
communities um I'm happy to answer
questions I know you've heard a lot of
testimony on this bill today thank you
any questions representative Kastle ring
thank you Mr chair I just have one
question it was specifically said in
another statement that um the facilities
can add more information that was not
provided by the the mother um is that a
practice of any of the Dartmouth Health
Systems to add any information that's
not provide or that's not provided by
the birth mother um no I think I uh we
would have to make sure that we're
following the letter of the law very
strictly and we would there would not be
additional information added that's
outside of the state and federal laws so
patient privacy is something that we
take very seriously and we want to make
sure we're in compliance with state and
federal regulation so as a follow-up
question there to to very Point andly
say this yeah there's nothing that is
added not outside state and federal
regulation but I mean there might be
information added though some specific
information but at at all there's you
know you said within the law but is
there anything that could be added
within the
law I I would have to come Circle back
with you but again strict clients with
state and federal regulation in terms of
what information needs to be added and
also that we're balancing that patient
privacy that's the that's a question for
my general
counsel anyone else representative
M thank you Mr
chairman would you tell us Professor
Goodman what all those initials mean
after your name as I think it deals with
your
excessive credibility yeah well Daisy is
a certified nurse Midwife she also is a
doctorate in nursing she has a masters
in public health and she's a
board-certified um uh nurse practitioner
thank you Daisy also is our vice chair
of our OB GYN department and so she does
extensive research um and has an holds a
number of federal grants one of which is
a an arm mom's Grant which is looking to
expand our ability to provide obstetric
services to the North Country uh and
because as we know we're navigating
maternal Health desert so um we would be
concerned about our ability to keep
those federal funds here in New
Hampshire if we if some of those um some
of our data fell away with this bill
she's extremely well qualified I I ask
her a lot of questions all the
time thank you anyone else
seeing no one else okay thank
you also signed up to speak is Kristen
Martino from Vital
Records oh you already did
oh did you have two did you have two of
oh okay that's fine makes it easier also
signed up to speak is Brianna hankle
from new futures
hello I'm Brianna Hinkle I'm the legal
policy fellow at new Futures I focus on
maternal Health policy um a lot has
already been said that is in my
testimony that I have um written copies
but um one program that will be affected
if this bill passes is the maternal
mortality Review Committee which is
vital for helping um L the landscape
like help um moms across New Hampshire
from the maternal mortality crisis um
I'm open to any questions thank you
anyone have any
questions seeing no questions thank you
very much yeah you can feel free to
distribute those if if you
want okay rep former representative
Betty gay had signed up but I saw her
leave so I don't think she's I believe
she signed the blue sheet so um
representative gay has left does anyone
else wish to speak on uh HB 621
FN seeing no one I'm going to close the
public hearing on HB 621
FN uh next up and I don't know if
representative Lloyd is in the
room
what's uh we'll give our we'll um
actually could someone does you you know
what she y i do could you check out
maybe y we'll see if representative
Lloyd is nearby and and then we'll
convene that
hearing
e
e e
I'd like to reconvene um the next bill
to be heard is HB 636
FN and the prime sponsor representative
Lloyd I do not believe is in the room or
nearby and uh accordingly I I I've
requested and she's agreed
representative Lucas is going to sit in
and bring the bill before our committee
and introduce it thank you
representative
Lucas thank you Mr chairman and thanks
for the opport
I will be
introducing uh House Bill 636 FN for the
record uh I represent uh Grafton County
district 7 which is Campton New
Hampshire uh I just want to uh point out
that I am not involved with this bill
and I am simply introducing it so that
it becomes part of the
record thank you representative l
because appre we appreciate it very
much okay uh bill is now before the
committee uh we have a couple of people
who have signed up to testify first off
is are Jenny ohiggins and Rob Barry from
the Department of Health and Human
Services
good afternoon for the record I'm Jenny
O Higgins legislative liaison for
Behavioral Health at
DHHS robberry General council's Division
of Medicaid
DHHS and we're here this afternoon to
oppose House Bill 636 so this
legislation would allow Community Mental
Health Providers to receive the same
rate of reimbursement as community
mental health programs so you will hear
those two different words back and forth
in my testimony I just want to clarify
for you this afternoon um that the this
legislation has a change to the the
definition of community mental health
programs and today um the department
provides critical quality of care
oversight of community mental health
programs as outlined in both our
administrative Rule and through our
Contracting and there are currently 10
Community Mental Health Centers who meet
the term of community mental health
program um these are reviewed through
through a designation process every 5
years and are monitored through ongoing
uh contract oversight and Community
Mental Health Providers that second word
that was is within the legislation that
makes a little bit of confusion here are
not subject to these high levels of
regulatory and quality oversight to
deliver services to individuals that are
diagnosed with severe mental illness or
severe emotional dist disturbance so the
high level of monitoring and oversight
standards that are required Ed of
community mental health programs ensure
that this population receives
highquality services that are tailored
to meet their unique treatment needs so
this legislation could result in those
individuals that are diagnosed with
severe mental illness or severe
emotional disturbance disturbance that
are accessing supports and services from
community mental health programs to
actually being able to access Services
through other types of community mental
health providers for treatment which
could impact their quality of
care there are significant concerns that
without consistent oversight the
department will be unable to guarantee
safe and effective treatment provided to
children youth adults and families that
are receiving intensive mental health
and substance use Services um the
department is assuming that the intent
is to create additional provider types
and to have them be able to access the
enhanced rates that are set for these
community mental health programs uh
however those rates are set considering
the unbillable services that are
required by this provider type uh to
implement their evidence-based best
practices for the specialty population
with severe mental illness or SE severe
emotional disturbance and additionally
more than half of services delivered by
our community mental health programs are
community- based and the delivery of
those community- Based Services the high
regulatory oversight requirements and
the um requirements to serve all
individuals who me who meet eligibility
are in part the reasons for that unique
provider specific rate schedule that's
why those rates are enhanced um so that
would not be true for the Community
Mental Health provider so it's that
difference again between program and
provider um so to implement this
legislation the department would need to
undertake a thorough review of all of
our administrative rules that are
pertaining to the community mental
health treatment and to evaluate our
existing statutory authority to ensure
that um it's in alignment with any of
these legislative changes we believe
there would be significant fiscal impact
however we don't have oversight over the
Community Mental Health Providers uh to
have a sense of how many might be
eligible for the enhanced rate or the
number of people or services that they
might offer so hard to determine that
impact and the only other thing I would
add from the Medicaid perspective is
that um we believe this would have a
material impact on the capitation rates
in our MCO contracts because as as of
now we pay providers based B on certain
um we pay pay rates based on what
they're qualified to do and this in
essence would increase those providers
from one section to another the higher
rate uh which would have a material
impact on the MCO contracts uh the
capitation
rates so we're happy to take any
questions thank you representative Lucas
I'm sorry could you repeat that last
point that you were making about
reimbursement
rates so our MCO contract
we have um if we expanded the scope of
providers that can be Community Mental
Health Program providers that would in
essence put them in a higher rate of pay
which in turn increases the capitation
rate and which would increase the cost
of the MCO
contracts thank you anyone else any
other question representative Woods uh
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
my question I um I I think I understand
but uh would it um clarify if I have the
wrong impression that if enough of the U
uh providers were to sort of come into a
particular area some of the mental
health centers um into the area where
there's Mental Health Center the
providers would take the clientele
away uh and therefore they wouldn't the
centers wouldn't get as much sort of per
um reimbursement um I'm I'm not sure how
that
works so I think we we all want to have
expanded Workforce and have many types
of providers to for all of us to be able
to access different types of on the
center the the the problematic part is
being is that the enhanced rate of the
community mental health programs is
there because of all of the unbillable
Care it's there because of the of the
way that they have enhanced services
that they need to provide to all those
that are eligible
and other types of Community Mental
Health Providers can and should be
operating in the in any area of the
state but they but the enhanced rate is
set out specifically for that unique
provider type that's a mental health
program because of all the additional
services that are offered so it's not so
much that we that we don't want people
accessing both but rather for for those
who have severe and persistent mental
illness or severe emotional disturb
disturbance we wouldn't want them to be
accessing care without the quality
oversight or without the types of
wraparound services and additional
supports additionally one piece that I
neglected to mention is the change from
Psychiatric to psychological within this
legislation and under our community
mental health programs um that that
medical or psych psychiatric screening
and evaluation is critical to the
current way that the the community
mental health programs provide care and
especially for that specialty population
mentioned
represent I'll representative hartnet
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking the
question uh that uh issue of psychology
or psychologist versus Psychiatry uh
this may be new content for some of the
members can you explain what the
difference would be on a at a street
level so the re I mean it's in our
current definition under our community
mental health programs because we are
serving the community mental health
programs are specifically serving those
with severe mental illness severe
impersistent mental illness severe
emotional disturbance and they may need
psychiatric or medical care including
oftentimes medications so there's a
specific need to have that provider type
and have folks be under Medical Care the
change in psychological um we do want to
again have psychologists operating in
our communities of course and we're not
looking to restrict that but under this
program type um it is critical that it's
that medical provider
type it's about medicine yes
yep anyone
else representative
McCay thank you Mr
chairman
um uh I hardly know where to start with
the on this bill but I was a licensed
clinical social worker I was on the
licensing board and I was in private
practice for about 35 years which tells
you something about my age probably uh
I'm concerned about this bill because I
don't understand what it's supposed to
do uh it sounds as if uh that somebody
could be in private practice which this
this bill provides services
independently I think that maybe means
private practice and if it does are they
allowed to do that without being
licensed so I do still believe this
would fall under the regul licensing
under oplc that folks would be licensed
it's more about the rates as far as I
can tell from the this piece of
legislation is that people are currently
if you're a Medicaid provider um you can
Bill Medicaid for these services at um
the standard rate and that there are
separate unique rates for our community
mental health programs based on the high
quality oversight and the additional
unbillable services and the requirement
to serve all who are eligible follow
follow
up does that mean that
non-licensed practitioners can be in
private practice no I do not believe so
that that's very important I agree thank
you any representative
haret thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking this question too um uh I'm uh
familiar with at least three Mental
Health Centers and uh over the past say
half dozen years there struggles in
recruitment of Staff um are you aware of
any Grand influx of psychiatric social
workers counselors into the state that
would uh make this kind of initiative uh
a possibility a successful Poss
ability boy do I wish I could say yes we
had an influx of providers uh no I do
not think we have an influx of providers
we certainly are doing a lot of work on
Workforce Development and Behavioral
Health um and I I I think there's this
is specifically about a need for
probably uh additional rates for those
practicing in the community I we're
making a lot of assumptions because I'm
not sure of the intent of the
legislation and if we able to better
better understand that we may be able to
work on what would need to to happen but
we don't think that it is an editing the
current definitions of the community
mental health programs followup just a
clarifying question then so you don't
know where the heck the workforce would
come
from correct however I think it might be
that they're saying those who are
already operating as Community Mental
Health Pro like as providers in our
community today could now build this
enhanced rate those are my ass
assumptions from the way I read this
legislation thanks anyone
else seeing no one else thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is Dr
Melinda Asbury from the New Hampshire
Community Behavioral Health Association
you've asked for five minutes if you
could keep closer to three that'd be
great hello everyone thank you chairman
and thank you honorable committee
members for allowing me the opportunity
to testify today which will be opposing
House Bill
636 please allow me a moment to
introduce myself as I know
representative McKay will ask uh my name
is Dr Melinda Asbury and I have a
medical degree
wherein I trained at Duke University
School of Medicine I also have a PhD in
the field of Neuroscience and I am on
faculty at the University of North
Carolina school of medicine and I'm also
an instructor at geil school of medicine
at Dartmouth in addition I'm the chair
of Psychiatry at one of the
regional uh hospitals here in New
Hampshire so when I think about changes
to healthcare policy such as those that
are suggested within House Bill
636 I always ask myself two questions is
this going to be in the betterment for
the
community and will this be in the
betterment for those of which this
possibly will affect and those will be
our friends our neighbors our colleagues
our teachers our family members who are
affected with serious and persistent
mental illness today this is an easy
question to ask because the answer to
both of these things is no the
Amendments proposed by House Bill 636
will not be to the betterment of our
community and it will not be to the
betterment of those who suffer with
serious and persistent mental
illness we have had over 60 years to
study the impacts and to know what does
and does not work in community-based
mental health care and over those 60
years we have been able to identify four
core critical components of
community-based Mental Health Care those
are comprehensive team based approach
evidence-based psychiatric
Rehabilitation peer support and then how
Faithfully do we Implement models of
care three of those four elements
require either a psychiatrist or an
advanced practice psychi Patric care
provider the Amendments proposed by
House Bill
636 would not require these programs or
providers to have on staff a medical
personnel therefore rendering it
impossible to deliver three of the four
critical components we have seen over
the years what happens when that occurs
and that is an increase in cost to the
communities it is an increase in cost to
family members it is an increase and
utilization of our criminal justice
system and most importantly it's an
increase in suffering to those who
struggle with
spmi individuals with spmi and there are
12,37 of them in New Hampshire closely
making up 1% of our
population they have a medical illness
and this illness is a brain disease it
is a disease that most often times
starts before birth and it continues to
progress throughout a person's lifetime
think stop wrapping up please yes sir
therefore making it no different than
anyone else with a chronic disease or
cancer so I ask you honorable members if
you had a family member that had cancer
would you want that person to get
treatment at a Cancer Center that did
not have a cancer
doctor I ask you to please oppose and do
not move forward House Bill 636 thank
you thank you anyone have any questions
representative hartnet thank you uh if I
understand your question ly your uh
testimony concludes that if this bill
were to pass those who are most
vulnerable with severe and persistent
mental illness would get a much lesser
if any good quality standard of care yes
sir you are correct thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you chairman
also signed up to speak is is uh Cynthia
Whitaker representing New Hampshire
Community Behavioral Health
Association and as I explained to the
last individual if you could keep it
closer to three minutes instead of five
that'd be great yeah sure thing uh thank
you uh honorable chairman uh McDonald
and the committee members uh thank you
for the opportunity to testify today I'm
Dr Cynthia Whitaker I am a psychologist
not a
psychiatrist um I've dedicated my U more
than 20year career to Community Mental
Health Center work here in our state so
I'm very familiar with rules regulations
and the things that we have in addition
as a resident of the Wear Community my
child received services from the
Community Mental Health Center uh in the
conquered region um so House Bill 636
changes uh things related to the system
I mean you've heard the difference
between provider and program uh so for
me there's two big things on here one
folks have already talked about the
change from um psychi psychiatric to
psychological which we know does not
make sense for individuals with severe
and persistent mental illness um you'll
hear um or read in uh nami's um
testimony about first episode psychosis
as a specific program that really
requires specific oversight by a
psychiatrist to make sure that we're not
overmedicating young individuals who are
experiencing that the other piece that I
would like to point out within the
legislature is that um in the proposed
Bill the idea of that shift to other
Mental Health Providers doesn't just
allow Medicaid providers in our system
but essentially allows for profit
providers in our system this goes
against all the work that has had
bipartisan support in our legislature
thus far around the improvements to the
system of care here in New Hampshire
moving toward certified community
behavioral health centers uh the gold
standard really in our country around
what community-based care could look
like that Federal standard requires that
Health Providers be
nonprofits I feel if people were here
and there had been such a bill to change
community health centers or
fqhcs and allow those to be for-profits
we wouldn't be having a
conversation but because of the stigma
against mental health we want folks that
you know for profit let's a increase
access to care but Mental Health Care
should not be for-profit on the backs of
individuals who are very
vulnerable um and so for those reasons
we're very against um Against The Spill
again others have spoken to the
psychiatric piece the current
regulations um the HMS that we have 403
they require community mental health
programs to have a chief medical officer
to have specialized programs for uh
individuals who are older adults and
that that must have a specialized
provider who is familiar with medical
necessity in that population as well as
specialized providers for children um
because giving medication to Children
also requires that oversight so we are
against people coming into our state um
for profit taking the state's money and
then us needing to require the state to
look for more because we are the ones
who are required to treat people
regardless of their ability to pay so I
am open to your questions and again
thank you so much thank you any
questions representative Lucas um so if
if if I could just um make sure I
understand the point you're making
so if if a for-profit
center um that is super supervised by
psychologist um designs sees a patient
and Designs a program of care if it
involves medication then that individual
would then have to see a
psychiatrist and determine whether or
not that that recommendation for medical
medication is appropriate and then to
receive that actual prescription and
treatment from the psychiatrist so
doesn't that add another layer or extra
visit it AB it absolutely does and thank
you for that question um because a lot
of the the standards of care the
research that uh Dr Amesbury spoke to
suggests that the best care people
receive is when it's coordinated so we
have specialized teams that have case
managers therapists doctors that work
together so that there's a team that
coordinates that care so to remove or
separate that psychiatric care would not
provide the best care to individuals
with severe and persistent mental
illness and could potentially increase
costs because now you have to see extra
providers for extra visits because the
care is not
coordinated anyone else representative
Tes thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um could you my
understanding uh is that we have for a
very long time had a Workforce shortage
um and especially trying to recruit
Mental Health Providers to New Hampshire
so would a solution to what we're uh
inferring is being proposed as the
problem to be solved uh these mental
health providers could probably find
work at the community health centers
rather than setting up competing
shops yes thank you for that question I
mean certainly right and and currently
any other providers can provide as um uh
DHHS testified to they can provide
therapy medication and Medicaid services
but because they don't have the
coordinated Specialty Care that we do
because they don't have the teams
working together which allows us in some
ways to mitigate some of the um
Workforce shortages and and I would also
add um that because the 10 community
mental health programs have an
association and work very closely with
the Department of Health and Human
Services many of us have made strides um
in our Workforce shortage and a lot of
times I think as a legislature hear
about the negatives and not the
positives um but the ccbhc work has now
expanded to three out of our 10 centers
um all of whom um are doing a lot of
work um to bring in uh new staff from
other places um so yes there's
opportunity instead of
creating um competition which would then
require more oversight from the state
potentially more cost to our consumers
um to to coordinate together to
collaborate rather than to
compete anyone else any other
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is Sam
Hawkins from Nami of New Hampshire
thank you chairman members of the
committee for the opportunity to testify
today for the record my name is Sam
Hawkins I'm here today representing Nami
New Hampshire uh to really urge some
caution with this bill and share our
concerns around the two key changes that
it makes to state law so as you're
likely aware the community mental health
centers are required to provide services
to all of their patients all of their
clients regardless of their ability to
pay as such they serve plenty of
individuals who are uninsured or
underinsured and one key population that
they serve is Medicaid beneficiaries who
have a monthly spend down before those
Medicaid benefits kick in so uh these
folks do incur bills for those Services
before the Medicaid benefits kick in um
but many are unable to pay them and
essentially these bills become
uncompensated care incurred by the
Community Mental Health Centers uh our
concern is that uh as these new programs
uh presumably would not be held to the
same requirements to provide uh care to
everyone regardless of their ability to
pay they may be essentially uh taking
clients who can pay accessing that
enhanced rate and then leaving the
clients who cannot pay to the Community
Mental Health Centers uh so it's taking
away the crucial uh financial support
for the Community Mental Health Centers
leaving them with the uncompensated care
furthering the financial strain on those
centers and potentially jeopardizing
their ability to continue providing
services to the community I'll also
speak briefly about the uh change to the
requirement that a psychiatrist to
provide the medical oversight um this is
extremely concerning for us uh one key
example is in cases of first episode
psychosis uh these individuals require
close medical oversight um so as a way
of background the evidence-based
treatment for first episode psychosis
calls for starting individuals on low
doses of medications and increasing them
at uh very slow increments so is not to
unnecessarily overmedicate these uh
these clients with anti-choicers
this is such a careful process this
practice requires a psychiatrist onsite
to carefully uh review regularly uh and
make these medication changes so
removing that psychiatrist oversight for
these very complex psychiatric cases may
result in individuals receiving improper
care and becoming
overmedicated uh in closing again I
would just urge the committee to use the
utmost caution when considering these
changes um so that folks really get the
high quality care they need uh and and
that we don't uh to put it simply
destabilize our entire Community Mental
Health System and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you any
questions representative
McKay thank you Mr chairman thank you
for your
testimony uh the community mental health
system has developed over the
years and has grown positively
uh even though we're having extreme
difficulty with getting well-qualified
people I think the
system and if you agree that it is a
very
unusual system in the sense that they
have
qualifications on all
levels and that a variety
of care is needed depending on the
individual a person with severe mental
health problems that ended up in New
Hampshire hospital requires a team
approach others may not uh so that we
have a welldeveloped
system and that uh any changes to that
uh I would ask if that's appropriate
thank you very much for your question um
I would absolutely agree that treatment
looks different for every person um
treatment is possible for every person
but it looks different and it does
require uh oftentimes a
multi-disciplinary team of providers I
think we have a very strong uh Community
Mental Health System here in New
Hampshire I think our community mental
health centers are uh well well prepared
um and uh really the best equipped in
the state to handle these issues I think
obviously there are always we can
improve any system to ensure um everyone
can access the care they need but uh we
are severely concerned uh that this
would jeopardize the great progress we
have made in our community mental health
system thank you very much thank
you anyone
else saying no one else thank you thank
you very
much no one else has signed up to
testify on HB 634 FN does anyone else
wish to
testify seeing no one I am going to
close the public carrying on this bill
uh we uh will we next scheduled to have
uh a bill uh the next bill to be heard
is at 1 p.m on HB
664a so we are in recess until
then
e
e e
I'd like to reconvene uh and recognized
representative Yuri palazov who was a
member of this committee for the
introduction of Bill 664a of which he's
the prime sponsor representative
palazov uh thank you Mr chair uh for the
record my name is uh y po representing
Mary Mark hook Dan Barton and I am here
to introduce House Bill
664a relative to to Childhood
immunization
requirements uh New Hampshire overall is
one of the most religious states uh and
it is natural to have uh certain
superstitions uh and uh we can see how
old superstitions go away and new
superstitions became popular but as we
are here legislate or even mandate
certain Medical Treatments it's
important to try to follow
science and not
superstitions and uh otherwise and this
bill is an attempt to go back to the
gold
standard of Science and uh this is
Placebo trials
uh I I gave you uh this uh uh handout uh
from uh I I can uh sorry for the small
font but the idea is like to follow
different uh vaccines available and uh
uh on
the uh I think it's 7 column it's uh it
shows uh in dark color now uh when
was not uh tested against Placebo during
trial so you can see uh this uh sad
situation when science is not uh
followed and
um I can think of different ways of like
testing certain medications or
specifically
vaccines uh but let's
uh review two major
ways and uh why why this
bill uh is the the
solution uh why why it should be the way
of
placebo uh so about a week ago this
committee already heard from the
Department that there could be two major
ways to ensure vaccine safety it's a pre
pre-roll out trials and this is what
this bill is trying uh to address and
second way is uh after vaccine was roll
out uh State epidemiologist mentioned
that CDC has this database the systems
called called buyers uh to track for uh
aders
reactions and uh one of the points of
people who trying to
oppose uh this bill that uh in front of
you they say that the passage of this
bill will result in preventable
deaths and many of you heard about that
uh in the last few
years suddenly we we have uh two DES in
texes that were
uh correlated with positive uh misles
test and we are being told that uh it's
a it's a correlation and
cation and what happened with second way
to test uh vaccine
safety uh uh actually you can check CDC
vies database and find not two but
hundreds dead kids dead
patients uh who are dead after receiving
mles vaccine so why we are concentrating
on on two
kids who are dead with misiles versus of
hundreds
of recorded vires uh
records and um uh
so so uh one options is like uh I think
we shouldn't but one of the reason why
one of the excuse we are being told that
uh correlation doesn't mean
cation so basically CDC
virus database for post relase vaccine
safety data is not being
used and uh it's not providing safety
protection even when we see strong
signals I don't know if you heard about
P RR it's basically a simple Mass
equation it's a mathematical standard
that was being created to evaluate
safety signals uh between between
different vaccines and CDC virus
database so it's not just account for
volume of adverse reactions but also for
volume of vaccines
administered and what happened when
covid vaccine was rolled
out the volume of reports went through
the
roof and uh what happened with PR
criteria yeah it showed that covid
vaccine is not safe according to PR
criteria what was done it was just
ignored there was decision like to
ignore the pre-established safety
standard and try to establish some
different standard and go along so
basically CDC virus
database is more distraction we don't
have a good system to track safety of
vaccine after they roll out so we need
to go back to the main uh alternative
that is being uh
suggested which is
uh uh which is
uh safety data before all out
so uh research and uh what what happened
here what what what what parents expect
yeah we know that most uh people uh and
most parents in New Hampshire are
believers they believe that vaccines are
safe and effective and most of them
believe that uh it it was well
researched according to science uh but
uh what what what as a parent what would
I expect I expect it like with other
medications many years of studies
with large groups and against placeo to
to find if it's actually effective and
if it's actually
safe and uh if if you go uh to the E
column you can see uh for example
duration for vaccines it's often uh just
days or months they're not being looked
for uh uh long trials if if it's like uh
3 days research can you in three days uh
prove that it doesn't cause autism no
you you you cannot and uh some uh can
you in three days prove that it causes
my carditis no you wouldn't be able to
catch that safety signal but more
importantly what what's used in control
so I suggest gold standard of using
placeo as a control and
most often uh it's some other vaccine
that is used to be as a control and
those uh vaccines who are used as a
controls are often also known to uh
cause a
significant uh number of side effects
and significant volume of side effects
so that comparison doesn't bring uh much
confidence so uh that's what this bill
is about uh let's not go from uh beliefs
unfunded beliefs but if we are mandating
something let's go from gold standard of
uh research uh some opponents of this
bill were saying that uh if this bill
would be uh enacted we won't be able to
uh roll out flu vaccine because we don't
have time to research it for flu season
uh but uh more accurately would be
saying that uh all of these vaccines
that uh had no proper study for their
safety and efficiency they should not be
mandated thank you thank you any
questions for representative
palazov representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so is the
intention because we already have a a
mandatory vaccine schedule um so is the
intention that those vaccines that are
already on the schedule would stay on
the schedule or is this uh the intention
of this to be retroactive representative
p uh thank you it's a it's a good
question uh uh uh and uh this bill now
in committee so you can amend it uh
uh as you feel uh uh appropriate but my
my view that uh if safety and efficiency
was not
scientifically proven we should not
mandate it so I I I'm fine with it going
retroactively anyone else representative
Woods um just for our edification um are
are there one on that would
qualify um that we currently use I'm
thinking of um something like small poox
vaccine the
polio
um those kinds of things that we have
been seemingly very effective uh can you
give some examples that did have
Placebo uh
tests yeah what what what shocked me as
I was researching this bill like
when we deal with some other
superstitions
like people would claim that something
is happening but they wouldn't like post
data that contradicts it but in this
case like we are hearing claims that
they safe and effective but then you
actually can go to FDA website read the
insert read the research volume and
settings and see that uh it's uh
it's not
uh scientifical scientifically sound
data there was no uh proper lengths of
safety reviews know
Placebo uh and so on and often control
group was very small uh so that uh and
uh and yes most vaccines had no Placebo
trial in this table you can see that uh
there was some attempt to do Placebo
trial for covid-19 commun uh vaccine but
then on the last column you can see that
there was unproper unblinding and when
people were vaccinated even in the
control group so uh and uh some other
problems with that research and on the
bottom of that table of vaccine you you
can see uh vaccine from uh and sorry if
I mispronounce it from D vac uh and uh
That vaccine uh
uh I would say there was honest
scientific effort to do uh a proper
research with fiveyear trial against
Placebo and now they
don't advise it uh really nearly only in
certain
circumstances uh EX L because that
research showed that children and six
had severe harm and death uh and uh
children so so only if there's some
specific health risk of exposure and so
on Then That vaccine uh could be used
but with understanding of severe side
effects uh and I would pose for you from
reviewing uh uh even like uh CDC virus
database uh uh uh in previous ter I
presented uh this committee with data uh
on uh New Hampshire CDC data on covid
and covid-19 vaccin that uh maximum
numbers that CDC came up for New
Hampshire residents who are minus and
who did died with Co is uh one uh but uh
if you go to CDC virus database you can
find at least three kids who died uh
after receiving a covid-19 vaccine so so
uh I would uh I I I I don't see any of
the mandated vaccine uh that uh showed
uh safety and efficiency from scientific
point of
view I represented
farmer well I'm going to pick one cuz
covid vaccine is not required for
children you move your mic up a little
bit close a little
closer or grow taller thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um but I just I'm looking at
measles and I'm trying to figure out
exactly what you're trying to get at so
the measles vaccine was studied Placebo
control back in the 60s it's been
revised um and it's been very
efficacious measles was essentially
eradicated and so I guess are you
suggesting that somehow measle the
measles vaccine should be restudied
before making it acquired in New
Hampshire and if so who's going to re
study it and how would you do that
because it's not really ethical to to
study a vaccine that's been shown to be
efficacious again with Placebo because
you'd be giving Placebo to people that
you should be
protecting
uh that's a that's uh the last part is a
good question how you uh I can see some
problems but also um we have different
slices of population some
population uh want vaccine some
population don't want it at all and I
I'm sure you you would be able to find
people who are ready to study it
especially for disease that has uh very
low mortality for uh otherwise healthy
kids and uh I must say uh uh uh even in
the latest uh CDC uh data sheet on
misles outbreak in Texas um you you can
read about history of this issue and
that uh mortality from
misles was reduced significantly even
before any misles vaccine was
available uh so uh there's
that any other questions representative
delus thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um does
this bill as amended re uh stop people
from getting vaccines any vaccine that
they choose to to
use yeah absolutely not uh if uh people
believe in vaccine and uh most uh people
and most parents in New Hamshire believe
uh uh that vaccines are safe and
effective I I I don't share that believe
because it's not scientific but if they
believe they are free to get those
medications any final
questions I'm seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak at Colleen
Smith and Dr Benjamin Chan from the
Department of Health and Human Services
it works it works
yes uh good afternoon Mr chair members
of the committee uh thank you for the
opportunity to come before you and and
testify on this uh Bill House Bill 664
my name is Dr Benjamin Shan I'm the
state epidemiologist could you get a
little closer please at the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services and I'm joined today by collean
Smith who's the chief of our Bureau of
of Infectious Disease Control within
Public Health um we are uh opposed to
House Bill uh
664 um because we believe that this
legislation would prevent the department
from requiring any of the vaccines
currently required under RSA 141c and
the associated uh administrative rules
um uh for vaccines required for
attendance at New Hampshire schools and
childcare agencies none of the vaccines
currently listed none of the 10 vaccines
or diseases that vaccines protect
against uh that are currently listed and
required for attendance at school or
child care agencies uh have been studied
against an inner Placebo meaning none of
the currently licensed um and
recommended vaccines uh these required
vaccines have been used and studied uh
for decades including in clinical trials
including in randomized controlled
clinical trials uh to ensure that they
are safe and effective um but the
currently licensed vaccines have not
been studied against Placebo controlled
randomized clinical trials um Placebo
controlled randomized clinical trials
are just one type of study but they are
not the gold standard for vaccine
approval and recommendations because it
is not possible or ethical to conduct
these types of studies on the vaccines
currently in use when an existing
vaccine is available um it becomes the
gold standard against which new or
updated vaccines are compared not
placebos but the existing vaccines uh
that that are out there
already the currently required vaccines
uh that are listed under RSA 141c and
the administrative rules have changed
over time to make them safer and more
effective and so when new versions of
these vaccines have become available
they can't be compared against placebos
rather they are compared against older
versions of vaccines newer formulations
uh or other formulations of the vaccines
sometimes even unrelated vaccines that
are part of normal preventive care
recommendations because those preventive
care recommendations are part of the um
what we call standard of care um and to
give you an example the inactivated
poliovirus vaccine uh currently in use
today um the first iteration of that
vaccine was introduced in 1955 after
being studied in one of the largest
placebocontrolled clinical vaccine
trials um history uh That vaccine
however was updated to an enhanced
inactivated polio virus vaccine that was
introduced in the
1990s uh which is currently in use in
the US today this updated vaccine didn't
undergo a new Placebo controlled
clinical trial uh rather in fact was you
know used in fact studied in other
countries before being um more widely
adopted in the US um but rather it
efficacy was evaluated by the vaccine's
ability to produce neutralizing antibody
protection against the virus um because
Decades of use and study had shown that
the vaccine was was safe and effective
so in summary all required vaccines um
have been in use for decades with an
excellent safety and efficacy record and
while none of the currently required
licensed vaccines or licensed version
have undergone Placebo controlled
clinical trials they have been studied
in various types of different clinical
trials over Decades of use to show that
they are both safe and effective and
these vaccines have led to dramatic
declines in diseases preventing millions
of infections and saving uh lives so uh
with that let me end my formal testimony
and thank you for your attention and
we'll be happy to answer any questions
that the uh committee may have thank you
thank you any questions representative
Kastle ring thank you Mr chair so I'm
looking at the this it looks like a CDC
report that was handed out um picture
and there's a thing that says
vaccinations of us children born between
90 1994 in 2021 says these estimates uh
there's prevented disease like different
statistics here and they're all saying
estimate estimate can you tell me how
those estimates are created or where
these studies are from because it it
seems that there's not a lot of
information where these studies come
from yeah so I I'd have to go back and
look at the rest at the reference to uh
see exactly how the estimates were done
um many of these uh most of these
diseases are reportable diseases um in
Most states uh and so there's data
coming in at a at a national level on
these um on these infections or on these
diseases uh but it's not always 100%
capture and so there's different
statistical methods for how in this case
I think the CDC estimates the total
burden but I'd have to go back and look
at the at the reference which I think is
at the bottom of this fact sheet to okay
give provide more details on how those
estimates were provided or made follow
up follow up so does New Hampshire
specifically have any other calculation
method or method to be able to get these
statistics versus what you've handed us
here um so so New Hampshire is not
creating these these estimates I mean
they getting any statistics from
anywhere else or do you utilize anything
specific sorry to clarify for for
estimates your question is about
estimates at uh preventing disease
preventing infections where did where do
you get the statistics from what
statistics do you utilize as the
department let's put it that way um well
I think it depends on what the the
question is if it's about disease
occurrence New Hampshire has data on
disease occurrence because um it's
they're these are reportable diseases um
if the question is about estimates on um
preventable diseases from vaccines those
are not produced at a state or local
level those come from our national
federal Partners primarily the CDC
although there are other um agencies
that are out there there are other
states that are are doing more
calculations but New Hampshire has never
estimated or done our own estimates on
number of preventable diseases uh
averted from vaccination one last one
okay so you're saying that you you you
use the cdc's information here as your
guide so so we we use the information
coming from the CDC in this case in this
in this infographic uh but certainly we
use information and data for multiple
different sources not just the CDC you
know when it comes to looking at vaccine
safety vaccine efficacy um many of those
studies are are done by other states
academic organizations the
pharmaceutical companies that are
funding the clinical trials to get them
approved Etc okay thank you
representative Woods thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
I'd like to refocus on sort of the
central part of this bill and that's the
issue of
placebo you
sort of uh went over that a little bit
but I think it might be worthwhile just
going over again you know the concept of
placebo being the quotes gold standard
that that we hear uh versus other
techniques of uh double blind studies
Etc and so forth how they fit into you
know making it a as a good trial and uh
if you could just expand on so we can
clarify the difference in getting
something to a patient uh safely um Etc
thank you yeah uh representative thank
you for that question so I think the the
bottom line is that there are uh
multiple different types of clinical
trials a placebo controlled randomized
clinical trial is just one type of study
or one way to conduct a study using a
placebo um but as mentioned uh those
studies cannot be done um they're
unethical to be conducted um on the
currently used
vaccines um because there's already
vaccines available that are in use those
are the standard of care so anytime a
new drug a new therapeutic comes to
Market they they it goes through a
series of different types of clinical
trials sometimes but not always that
ends in you know what we call a phase
three clinical trial where you have a
placebo controlled randomized double
blinded clinical trial but even before
that there are you know phase one trials
which are looking at you know dosing you
know different doses of a medication you
get into phase two studies uh which look
at safety of vaccines in a population
these are not Placebo controlled
clinical trials but they're still
clinical trials um when you're not able
to do a placebo controlled clinical
trial as in the as is the case with
existing vaccines there are other types
of trials that can and have be done have
been done on these vaccines um you know
using uh other other measures to look at
safety and efficacy of a vaccine um
measuring infection rates in between
different populations um looking at uh
antibody responses some of these
diseases have been around for so long
that we know that at a certain antibody
level in a person's body they're
protected from a disease so some of the
clinical trials will look at you know
the vaccine's ability to induce or
create a body's immune response
specifically looking at the efficacy of
the vaccine um and then as I think was
referenced last week in another bill
there are you know postmarketing
clinical trials that are done again not
Placebo controlled uh but they're
looking at uh studying the vaccine in
real world use um you know many of these
clinical trials that are done more
formally have maybe you know tens of
thousands of people when you get the
vaccine out into real world use you have
hundreds of thousands millions of people
getting the vaccine which allows further
opportunity to study and so some of
these
uh all of these vaccines that are
currently required under RSA 141c have
been in use for decades and hence have
Decades of study and decades um of you
know clinical study in use um behind
them so I I think the requiring a
placebo controlled clinical trial is
somewhat metaphorically missing the
forest for the trees right the tree
being the placebo controlled clinical
trial the forest being all of the other
clinical studies and trials that have
been conducted on these vaccines over
Decades of
use any other questions representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so you know so I
understand your point and as
representative Palmer also really
pointed out the moral problems with
having an existing vaccine and you know
insisting on having a placebo but you
know and I'm just trying to understand
ultimately you need to have some kind of
Base line and you talked a little bit
about the enhanced polio vaccine and we
didn't have a placebo with that but it
was compared I guess back to the the
prior polio vaccine now that prior polio
vaccine it was done by a placebo so
there is a baseline there so you have a
kind of chain of custody back to a point
where there is this Baseline so um if in
the history of that you don't have an
inert an inert placebo
what other methodology do you have in
order to establish that Baseline I'm I'm
just trying to understand absent that
how do you do
that
yeah excuse me well I think that likely
will vary vaccine by vaccine um and
disease by disease right and there's a
difference in studies for safety and
studies for efficacy or effectiveness of
of a vaccine at preventing disease um in
terms of you know and they're studied
you know both aspects of vaccines are
studied sometimes in different studies
or different trials sometimes in the
same trial um when it and there's more
detail in I think the testimony that was
um circulated in terms of how some of
the different vaccines um might have
been studied in clinical trials there's
some um bullet points that we've
provided in terms of um how you know
vaccine efficacy specifically might be
assessed um but goes back to some of the
testimony I gave about comparing ing it
to an older version of the vaccine
comparing a new formulation to um uh
other formulations of the vaccine right
the the other issue we get into slight
tangent here is that um you know it a
lot of times the um the first vaccine
that comes out might be studied in a
placebo controlled clinical trial but
there are multiple pharmaceutical
companies that might make a for example
the measles vaccine and so the first one
of the market maybe is studied with
against a place Placebo controlled
clinical trial but then a company comes
out with their own version of the
vaccine they can't study that against a
placebo they have to study it against
the vaccine that's already in use to
make sure it's providing the same level
of protection and efficacy so sometimes
vaccines different formulations of the
vaccine are compared against one another
um uh we can look at you know infection
rates uh in vaccinated versus
unvaccinated persons uh some diseases as
I mentioned there are known antibody
levels that we know provide a high level
of protection against disease so
sometimes vaccines will be compared
against you know their ability to
promote or induce antibody levels in a
person so there's a variety of different
ways that vaccine Effectiveness can be
studied um and it's going to really vary
vaccine by vaccine and disease by
disease and what other vaccines might be
available follow up so so just to set
everybody's mind at these in and you may
not may know may not know the answer to
this but if you look at the vaccines
that are on our current schedule like
the measles vaccine as we discussed the
current version isn't Placebo controlled
but if I look at these vaccines that are
on the schedule if I look at the history
do they at some point tie back to a
placebo or that kind of Baseline are you
aware um I I don't I don't have 100%
data on that some of them I know are
others I I'm I'm not sure or how how far
back you go what uh what kind of
clinical trials you will find uh again
some of these were studied back in the
1950s
1960s um
so any final questions representative
Weber thank you so my final question
would be so am I wrong to read the
language of this
statute as saying that any
new variant of any
vaccine would require the inert
Placebo uh study before it could be used
we've talked a lot here about the chain
of you do a placebo study and then you
establish a certain effective rate and
then you compare the new formulations to
the last approved vaccine but wouldn't
we be required if we adopt this
to require a new inert Placebo study
before we mandated any new
vaccines um if I understand your
question correctly representative I I
believe so and I I read this as also
applying to um you know historically or
look back at currently required vaccines
and specific to their current licensed
version so any new vaccine going forward
um or any of the currently required re
ired vaccines uh and their currently
licensed versions would be required to
have been compared in a clinical trial
uh against an inner Placebo that's how I
read the test uh the legislation thank
you okay one more question
representative TZ last question thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question um Dr Chan can you speak a
little bit to what I heard in the um in
the um
and sort of the motivation for uh this
bill is maybe a concern about uh safety
or harmful side effects can you shed a
little light for us on sort of that
Dimension because we know that vaccines
have saved millions and millions of
lived and prevented millions and
millions of infections so some people
seem to be concerned about the amount of
potential harm I guess can you shed
light on that from sort of a population
and public health perspective for us
please uh yes uh representative thanks
for that question and and I I guess I
would um say that safety is studied at
multiple levels uh in clinical trials
both before a vaccine is approved and
recommended and also um after it's
approved and recommended what we call
postm marketing um study uh of vaccines
and and I think I heard I was having a
hard time Hearing in the back but I
think I heard reference to some of the
systems uh that uh CDC and F da use um
to monitor vaccine safety th those are
systems um that current are in use
currently in use for all vaccines uh
that collect data on um adverse side
effects after uh that could be related
to vaccination after somebody is
vaccinated I I heard reference I think
to some some death numbers um I will
just say that uh that it is
required that any person who died
after receiving a vaccine regardless of
the cause of death um get reported to
some of these National systems like
theirs V uh vaccine adverse event
Reporting System there's also vaccine
safety safety data link and others um
and so having um a report made does not
mean that uh vaccine caused that
reaction or that death it's a simply a
way of collecting information so that
further investigation can be done to
ensure that the vaccine is safe post
marketing or after lure after
recommendation because clinical trials
themselves are limited right as I
mentioned clinical trials usually the
larger ones are conducted with tens of
thousands of people but that may not be
enough to identify very rare occurrences
of side effects or disease that might
only come out after millions of people
are vaccinated the only way you get that
data is by having these National
surveillance systems in place uh
requiring reporting of any potential
adverse reaction whether or not it's
related to a vaccine so many many of
these numbers that you may um hear
quoted about deaths after vaccination um
is what we call Raw data um it's
required to be reported uh but most of
the time if if not the majority of the
time um the vaccine is not contributing
to or causing a person's death it's
simply part of the required reporting
for monitoring after a vaccine is put in
use and um used in a population
hopefully that was
clear okay thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is Julie Kim
from The New
Hampshire American Academy of
Pediatrics you've asked for five minutes
again if you could keep it to three I'd
appreciate
it thanks so much for having me today um
good afternoon I'm Dr Julie Kim I'm a
pediatric hematologist and oncologist
here in New Hampshire I also serve as
the president of the New Hampshire um
chapter of the American Academy of
Pediatrics I represent over 200
pediatricians in this great state I've
been an oncologist in our state for over
20 years and I've had the fortunate uh
opportunity of raising my own children
here I'm here today to urge you to
oppose House Bill 664 the provisions of
this legislation if enacted would
unnecessarily and unethically expose
children to life-threatening vaccine
preventable diseases in the initial
development of new vaccines and the
ongoing distribution of vaccines in New
Hampshire child and adolesent
immunizations are already subject to R
rigorous levels of testing that are
unrivaled by other interventions that we
as pediatricians use to keep our
patients healthy as we talked about as
Dr Chan talked about clinical trials for
vaccines follow rigorous scientific
standards Placebo controlled trials are
only a gold standard if there is no
other previously proven vaccine
available on the market however when
approved vaccines exist regulators and
scientific ethics committees would not
typically accept a placebo controlled
trial design because doing so would
prevent access to actually approved
vaccines for clinical trial PR
participants and leave them vulnerable
to vaccine present preventable diseases
as a pediatric oncologist this would be
equivalent to somebody trying to get the
newest chemotherapy we couldn't just
tell people they couldn't get any cancer
the chemotherapy just to try out this
new one so we always tested against
what's the most uh recent and what is
considered the current standard of
Care at a time when we are seeing a
Resurgence of serious diseases like
measles and whooping cough alongside the
spread of respiratory diseases like
seasonal influenza and RSV it is
important for us all of us to remember
the role that vaccine confidence plays
in ensuring uptake across this popula a
large population to bring it to a
personal level my own patients are imuno
compromised as are many elderly people
or adults in our state who have chronic
diseases a few years ago one of my own
patients who had leukemia suffered
terrible seizures and ultimately died
from an overwhelming Chickenpox vaccine
or overwhelming chickenpox disease after
being exposed to an unvaccinated child
this child's death probably could have
been prevented had the other child and
those child's contacts been vaccinated
against chickenpox so undermining
vaccine confidence through unnecessary
actions such as this in the legislature
gains us nothing and it puts much at uh
at unnecessary risk especially children
so I urge you to um protect continue to
protect children and to vote no on House
Bill 664 thank you thank you any
questions um representative Drew then
representative delus thank you Mr chair
if these vaccines were
recommended by DHHS and not mandated by
Statute would that change your practice
in any way
uh my practice as a pediatric oncologist
my patients cannot get vaccinated so the
more kids that can get vaccinated to
protect my patients and also protected
elderly people um would be beneficial
for my patients
directly representative
delus thank you Mr chairman I think my
question actually would would be for a
pediatrician who um does vaccinate so I
don't believe that this witness is can
answer my question I can try you want to
try okay well my my question was how
many um parents or Guardians actually
refuse uh vaccines oh you're right I
can't answer that since I'm not a
general pediatrician but my patients um
who are have oncologic diagnoses their
parents do ask if their child can get
vaccines but just because of the imuno
compromised state they're unable to
follow up so there is a desire there to
vaccinate yes there very much is so okay
and and is that um more common than not
that's I think that's the only thing I
know all my patients their families want
them to get uh vaccinated to do whatever
they can to protect their child while
they have this disease okay thank you
representative Castle ring thank you Mr
chair just because you have that
experience can you elaborate for us uh
specifically on those patients that see
that I mean I can understand that
they're imuno compromised so they can't
get vaccines but is there other
conditions that they could get because
you said chickenpox but like is there
are they susceptible to everything be
susceptible to any kind of vaccine
preventable illness I mean it's
influenza um it could be hepatitis uh
I've had a patient who died of hepatitis
actually um as well and that's a vaccine
preventable disease um so I mean any of
the vaccine preventable illnesses they
would be at risk for okay anyone else
okay thank you thanks thank
you also signed up to speak uh riser
Evans representing herself and the
Children's Health
defense good afternoon can you can you
hear me okay thank you
um I um am speaking in favor of this
bill
um I think that we can all agree um from
an ethical standpoint that a
non-negotiable prerequisite for any
vaccine mandate is vaccine safety um and
I think simply put that nobody in this
room would want to require a healthy
child to be injected with a vaccine that
is not proven to be
safe um and so obviously the goal of
this bill is to make sure that we have
um data signed ific data about the true
safety profile of a vaccine before that
vaccine can be
mandated now um people have already
spoken a bit and we'll speak some more I
think today about the shortcomings um in
the vaccine manufacturers clinical
trials for vaccines that are currently
on the cdc's recommended childhood
schedule um and in particular about the
lack of inert Placebo controls in those
trials which makes it impossible to know
what the true safety PR profile of those
vaccines actually what those profiles
are because you can't tell what the
actual rate is of whatever the adverse
event is being measured if you don't
have an actual control group that's not
getting the um that's not getting the
the intervention that's being tested and
you know this is recognized there's just
no substitute for an inert Placebo
control and I believe and and and I urge
you to take a look at this book if
you're Ed it's called Turtles all the
way down um and it's got incredibly well
sourced data about the actual trials
that were controlled that were that were
conducted for all the vaccines on the
childhood table and and some of the
shortcomings of those trials and also
some of the shortcomings of the type of
retrospective epidemiological studies
that I think have been suggested here as
an alternative to real true PL Placebo
controlled trials so um but um but I'm a
lawyer I'm not a doctor and so I'm
actually here to talk just a little bit
about the broader legal context for this
bill because I think that that is also
really important to understand um and
that is the federal government's virtual
elimination of manufacturer liability
for injuries that are caused by vaccines
first through the 1986 childhood vaccine
injury act and then second through the
2011 US Supreme Court opinion um in uh
Bruth versus WTH um so both the national
vaccine Act and the and the bruis withth
case I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing
that correctly um but they both
recognize that vaccines inevitably have
side effects and cause injuries but
taken together the vaccine acts and the
Supreme Court opinion hold that even
when an injury caused by a vaccine on
the childhood schedule is caused by a
design defect that is the fault of the
company that developed and manufactured
the vaccine please please stop wrapping
up the the the the company has no
liability and so just to think about
what this means in terms of incentives
what are the incentives to prove vaccine
designed to make vaccines safer for
children when there's no liability at
all and I'll just leave you with a quote
from Justice Sodom mayor who dissented
in the bruis witz Kates and said that
the decision to eliminate manufacturer
liability leaves a regulatory vacuum in
which no one ensures that vaccine
manufacturers acur adequately take
account of the scientific and
technological in Advan when designing or
Distributing their products and that's
why it's so important for you to step in
and fill that regulatory Gap thank you
any
questions I'm saying none thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Victoria
Shaheen for the New Hampshire families
for vaccines
thank you uh committee members thank you
Mr chairman um I'd like to introduce
myself if I could uh my name is Tori
Shaheen uh I'm here on behalf of New
Hampshire families for vaccines uh we're
an organization dedicated to advancing
evidence-based legislation and opposing
legislation that is based on
misinformation and misrepresentation of
existing
procedures um so I uh I have a degree in
microbiology from the University of New
Hampshire um I also have a degree from
the University of North Carolina and
Chapel Hill in microbiology and
Immunology um I've worked for 16 years
um for a clinical research organization
um you know managing clinical trials
essentially um but actually today I'm
here as a parent um of a 5-year-old son
it's my pride and joy uh so I'm here to
voice my strong opposition to Bill 664
which places unrealistic expectations on
the steady design of vaccine trials um
while ignoring critical ethical
guidelines that govern the process the
bill states that any vaccine required
must be tested using ner Placebo um I
believe that this bill would revoke the
approval of many safe and effective
vaccines on the existing schedule that
keep our children my son his friends our
families safe um and I I don't suspect
that any parent um or Community member
would want that um I think there might
be a some misunderstanding um in terms
of what a placebo is um I think previous
testimony has really covered that very
well I do have a very brief synopsis um
of the three types um so an inert
Placebo uh for example saline would be
appropriate to use if we were evaluating
a brand new technology uh for example
the covid vaccine trials did use uh a
saling Placebo for their control group
um second one that I actually didn't
hear mentioned earlier was that active
placebos which would be uh vaccine
ingredients absent the actual antigen so
the weakened or attenuated bacteria or
uh viral protein that would would
trigger the immune response um the
reason we use those active placebos um
in randomized controlled uh double blind
trials is because sometimes the
ingredients in a vaccine can cause a
little bit of a skin irritation a bump
um um some swelling a sore arm and you
really want the control group if they
rece were to receive a a saling Placebo
they would have no irritation and
effectively the study would be unblinded
so to truly have a double blind uh trial
you really want the uh control group and
the active uh vaccine group to have like
the same reaction on their arm at the
injection site so um you know this would
be the type of trial if we were looking
at side effects which you know there are
trials that specifically examine side
effects immunogenicity reactogenicity of
a vaccine um the circumstance um where a
new version of existing vaccines are
being Tri stop wrapping up certainly
there the comparator vaccine which has
been well covered by a previous
testimony because it was unethical to
leave um people especially children uh
without the standard of care which would
be an existing vaccine leaving them
vulnerable to uh potentially fatal
infectious diseases um so in closing so
clinical trials are governed by strict
regulatory oversight um robust
methodology Bound by strong ethical
guard rails and driven by sound
scientific reasoning um to suggest that
we deviate from this framework um to put
an unrealistic and unscientific uh
requirement that a saline Placebo be
used when it's not appropriate to do so
would make trials actually less safe um
so this bill creates a problem that
doesn't exist in order to further limit
access to vaccines which are critical to
keeping our community safe especially
our children thank you so thank you very
much representative Maser thank you Mr
chair are you taking questions
or excuse oh sorry yeah I'll take
question thank you for taking my
question so what vaccines would be
revoked if this bill passes um so I have
some some expertise on vaccines but less
so in legislation uh this this is my
first time here so I think in my reading
of the bill if I'm reading it literally
that this would essentially eliminate uh
all vaccines um on the existing schedule
because um you know to Dr Chan's point
they were initially studied using an
iner Placebo saline um but then because
we are in the circumstance in the year
2025 where we have safe and effective
vaccines that have been backed up at
clinical trials we are often improve
proving them or putting new formulations
on the market for example um it's always
a goal to reduce reactogenicity of a
vaccine so less than the side effects so
um you know if you develop a new MMR
vaccine measel boms rebella vaccine you
want to have less side effects you would
need to test that formulation against
the existing uh vaccine that is
available on the market because you
cannot create a study where you would um
put use a saline Placebo in a cohort of
children and leave them vulnerable to
measles which as we know you know can be
fatal but can also have lifelong result
in lifelong disabilities
so any else and sorry it would
effectively I believe eliminate the flu
vaccine as well because um you know
someone um maybe representative uh Woods
earlier asked about variance or maybe it
was representative
missing up um someone had asked about
variant I think it would it would
eliminate the flu vaccine as well
because um immuno bridging studies are
done each year to pick the flu strains
actually it should be going on now uh
for next Falls flu vaccine you pick the
strains that you want to immunize
against and use the existing vaccines as
a comparator so we would essentially
after a very deadly influenza year be
potentially without a flu vaccine for
next year if this bill to pass thank you
anyone else
representative representative mlan thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um are you aware like from a
regulatory framework or anything of any
vaccines that are being approved where
the history of the control does not lead
back to an inert Placebo or as you
mention the second type where I have
essentially all of the ingredients
except the inactive component are you
aware of controls where in the history
that does not
exist I am not aware and in fact um
after Dr Chan uh testified I uh looked
up and made sure that um the initial
vaccines of the following were all
tested against a placebo in their
initial init initial trial uh the
rubella vaccine the pacle vaccine the
Hib vaccine for hemophilus influenza B
the HPV vaccine the so polio vaccine the
measles vaccine
Tdap um vaccine and the covid vaccine
all against uh inert saling placebos to
establish their first safety
trials any any final questions see
representative merer yeah thank you
again so would you believe that this
bill is only about mandating vaccines
and not vaccine
availability I believe that this bill is
intended to um create an impossible
standard uh that no vaccine currently
available could meet uh which would lead
to access um limited access um and as we
know um as vaccine coverage
Falls infectious diseases come roaring
back so for example a community needs a
95% uptake rate of the MMR vaccine in
order to PR prevent measles outbreaks
and once coverage Falls below that
whether it is just from organic vaccine
hesitancy um or a lack of access to
vaccines you will start to see uh
measles come back and we're seeing that
happen in real time right now thank you
right thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is Melissa
white from Peterboro
good afternoon thanks for having us here
today um I'm here as a mom and I suppose
since no one else was able to make it
other moms um I'm I'm representing the
other moms that couldn't make it um we
don't have a lobbyist we don't have
anyone to represent us like the moneyed
interests that are here so um I happen
to be on vacation this week so that's
why I get to be here um so um the 1986
Act was already mentioned that took away
um liability from vaccine
manufacturers uh from the industry so if
the federal government is going to keep
that law in place we as a population and
we moms must demand that no corners ever
be cut when it comes to the health and
safety of our children um I do have
several friends who have vaccine injured
children um and it's not
just you know a couple days or a week of
a little rash and a fever it's like you
know my friend's 21-year-old son is
still not talking and he can use the
bathroom but he still wears a diaper
just in case um but um to that end this
bill is not about removing any shots
from the schedule it's just taking away
the mandates that you know so parents
will have a choice if they choose and
what I've read even recently um I don't
I didn't mark the study down because I
wasn't planning to be here today
necessarily but um there's literally I
think it's 1% or maybe 1% of the entire
population of our country that is
choosing not to vaccinate so you've got
your 95% you've got your
99% um most people are vaccinating so
just not having a mandate is not
removing them from from the choice um so
um I think I think that's it I just just
wanted to say those few things so thank
you thank you any questions
representative
delus thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so do you
believe that yourself and your the rest
of the moms that you refer to would have
chosen to
vaccinate anyway at first or how you
feel um the ones I know a lot of moms
who well people like to call people
antivaxers if they don't vaccinate but
usually they're ex vaxers they're
they're not anti they they did the shots
and they were injured um I don't know
I'm I'm I guess I'll speak for myself
but I was fully vaccinated growing up um
I'm in my 50s now and I have several
autoimmune challenges um those aren't
studied because and fouchy himself said
that you know back back when we were you
know he was defending the lack of
studies on the actually I think it was
even before I think it was several many
years ago maybe 10 years ago maybe the
H1N1 shot or whatever that 2009
pandemic Panic was about um he was
saying oh no we have to study these for
years because you just never know like
what's going to pop up later and it's a
challenge I mean I eat
perfectly I I my whole life is wrapped
around my health because my body just
can't handle things and not everybody is
like that but that's you know there's
different different things that go on in
us and so we're all different and you
can some people can take a flu shot
every year and I would probably die if I
took one so all right thank you
yeah also signed up to speak is klen fer
from the New Hampshire Nurses
Association
good afternoon chair McDonald and
members of the
committee I'm sharing testimony today on
behalf of TW over 1250 nurses who are
members of the New Hampshire Nurses
Association our mission is to improve
the health of the people of New
Hampshire as a nurse for over 36 years
serving in multiple Public Health roles
I have witnessed the societal benefit of
childhood vaccinations in preventing de
disease and death vaccines help children
grow free from preventable disease
decrease hospitalizations and save money
as you know vaccinations are one of the
greatest Public Health achievements of
the 20th
century sadly vaccine hency is leading
to lower vaccination rates and this
proposed legislation will only EX
exacerbate the problem research shows
that children living in or near poverty
experience persistently lower
vaccination rates making them
disproportionately at risk for vaccine
preventable
diseases this bill provides that
childhood immunization requirements
shall not require a vaccine that has not
been tested with an inert Placebo in
clinical trials in fact most childhood
immunizations have not re recently been
tested with an inner Placebo because it
would be unethical most childhood
immunizations have been available for
more than 50 years therefore clinical
equipoise is an absolute standard that
requires participants in clinical trials
to receive at least the existing
standard of care a placebo controlled
clinical trial is Justified only when no
safe effective vaccine exists for the
disease for the safety of New Hampshire
children their families and communities
please vote itl on HB
664 thank you any
questions uh representative
Drew you stated in your testimony that
you've seen the effectiveness of
childhood vaccines have you seen the
adverse effects of childhood vaccines
have you dealt with that in your work at
all I have not um
early on in my career I worked in a
federally qualif qualified Health Center
um which was an outpatient Primary Care
Health Center and we gave many many
vaccines daily we were required to
report as was mentioned earlier in the v
system and during the time that I was
there I never saw any V vaccine Adverse
Events okay any other
questions okay thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is
representative Janet Lucas who's
testifying on behalf of Meg obaba I'm
not sure if I'm pronouncing that
correctly
but thank you Mr chairman and members of
the
committee I'm reading a testimony of a
constituent and I will not be taking
questions to the members of the
committee my name is Meg over I resign
died in Campton I am a lifelong New
Hampshire resident and I'm a pharmacist
in a multihospital health system I am
submitting this testimony in opposition
to HB
664 as a pharmacist I am deeply
concerned about this bill to be frank it
is a direct attack on the lives and
health of New Hampshire children the
bill proposes in addition to RSA 141-a
it requests to add the following
paragraph nothing in this section shall
require a vaccine that has not been
tested with an inert Placebo in a
clinical trial as a reminder RSA
141-a States the following all parents
or legal Guardians shall have their
children who are residing in the State
immunized against certain diseases these
diseases shall include but not be
limited to deia Ms prus
poliomyelitis rubella rubiola and
tetanus collectively these vaccines
comprise the MMR rubiola more commonly
known as measles mums and rebella
vaccine the DTaP diptheria tetanus and a
cellular prosus vaccine and the ipv
inactivated poliovirus vaccine these
seven diseases are highly contagious
deadly and can cause serious long-term
disabilities in survivors a very cursory
review of these same vaccine package
inserts readily available on daily Med
shows that the exact vaccines that are
explicitly required under RSA 141c col
20-a were not evaluated clinically with
Placebo controlled trials do you suppose
that this is a coincidence you may ask
yourself why these trials were not
Placebo controlled you may also be
wondering what a package insert is or
what daily met is package inserts are
documents required by the FD day to
provide detailed information about
prescription medications daily Med is an
invaluable nah run website that I use
nearly daily at work to quickly find
specific medication information this may
be a good point to reflect on your own
knowledge of medicine physiology
microbiology and Immunology it is not
whatsoever the scientific custom to use
a placebo for a vaccine trial it is UN
ethical to do so especially when
alternative vaccines are already
available which is the case for all
seven vaccines listed in RSA 141c 20-a
not every clinical trial needs to be
Placebo controlled to be scientifically
sound finishing up this bill aims to
completely upend Children's Health and
Public Health in the state and to render
RSA 141 d c 20-a useless the passage of
this bill will result in preventable
deaths thank you for your consideration
Meg overball doctor of Pharmacy
rph thank you very
much also signed up to speak is Dr Gary
York from
Hopkinton and you have about 3 minutes
Sir Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Gary yor I live in
Hopkinson New
Hampshire uh have a background in
science I consider myself a scientist of
sorts uh my interest in vaccine safety
uh started about 40 year ago years ago
when my son had a severe reaction to the
TPT shot uh probably the
protest necessitating a medical
exemption for a him and and future uh
siblings uh to be clear I'm not an
expert in the field of vaccine safety I
I would guess that there's no one in
this room or probably in the state that
is qualified as or considered an a
vaccine safety expert I would argue that
the uh qualifications ought to include
like a PhD and immun ology to start
with uh in medical school uh the amount
of time we had uh training under
information about vaccines were zero
hours zero minutes it wasn't many years
ago
nonetheless uh it was only five years
ago in the midst of the covid thing that
um the timely book that Miss Evans has
referenced the turtles all the way down
talking about safety I was so Aston
wanted to find out that uh the current
vaccine schedule uh none have been
tested against a
placebo uh it seemed uh crazy that you
would inject substance into somebody
that isn't tested against the placebo
and by
Placebo uh I want to just remind
everyone that is the gold standard for
testing and whether it be a drug Placebo
being a sugar pill or an
injected uh uh injection would be uh uh
normal saline something like
that uh I also want to uh uh clarify
that um some of the studies that have
been done uh relying on uh
either previous iterations of the
vaccine or uh
um another type of vaccine as a control
group is is flawed in that the the the
goal of Cl clinical trial trials is to
determine that there's no significant
statistically
significant difference between the
control group and the trial group so if
you're using the previous iteration of a
vaccine against the current
iteration you're you're looking at
differences in in adverse reactions say
there's 10% reaction ctions in the
previous
iteration and there's
12% uh certain adverse reaction let's
call it uh a seizures or something uh
for discussion uh you
can't 10% versus 12% may be not
significant but 10% versus 0% that is a
true Placebo is significant and please
stop wrapping
up um
uh I have hard time with the concept
that the
uh Placebo issue is unethical uh
certainly there are families here that
don't vaccinate their children for
obvious reasons um also any form of
mandate is against all my principles uh
it doesn't make sense to have and we're
talking and this bill addresses a
mandated vaccine not just all vaccines
as someone had said said
before um so uh I'm I'm going to pass
out at the end just um a summary of the
book and you can look at it sure and uh
be curious if you like to and Fe look at
what the other side has to say uh I know
it's hard to wrap our uh wrap our brains
around things that we've believed to be
true for so long uh the Flat Earth ET
any questions for this gentleman yeah
representative Damas
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question just briefly um do
you believe that the uh vaccine act may
have directly caused what we're dealing
with
currently in that in that there's no
liability for any vaccine companies that
produce vaccines at this stage most
certainly and you know big farmer big
profit uh no liability what's wrong with
that
picture thank you anyway else seeing no
one thank
you also signed up to speak is Louise
Spencer uh representing herself in Kent
Street no red button there we go uh
thank you hi Mr chair um um thank you
for taking my testimony and to the
committee thank you for taking my
testimony my name is Louise Spencer I'm
from conquered New Hampshire and I'm
here today as a mother and a grandmother
and also um representing the members of
Kent Street Coalition which is an all
volunteer Grassroots advocacy
organization and the overwhelming number
of our members who oppose not only this
bill but also um the next bill HB
679 my testimony I applies to both um of
these bills as does my opposition
because these two bills when taken
together really um seem to be aimed at
making it um nearly impossible to
enforce any sort of uh vaccine
requirements um and um my heart does go
out to the parents and especially to the
children that may have been injured by a
vaccine and and we know that is possible
and compensation should be available um
but also I'm aware of the harm that
comes to children that are uh not yet
vaccinated and exposed to those who are
unvaccinated or in not fully vaccinated
my daughter at four or 5 months old uh
developed W who cough and uh it became a
very dangerous situation acutely uh
where she um could not catch her breath
where she um I guess babies sometimes
stroke out I could see the the veins in
her head in a very scary way um but she
lived with the squilla of that infection
for years she developed a coughing
asthma and had to use nebulizers and
really out only outgrew that in her 20s
so there are harms that we know of that
come from children being exposed to
preventable
diseases um right now I have a
9-month-old grandson he is not yet
available to get the um measles vaccine
and it's very scary to have a
unvaccinated child when measles I
believe it's like a one one person with
measles can infect 28 people whereas
covid it's one to four and the the virus
apparently hangs in the air for two
hours I've been reading about measles
because I'm also very concerned about my
grandchild uh her practice her
pediatrician is considering lowering the
age um from one year to 9 months because
of their very deep concern about the
measles so I speak as a parent as speak
as a grandparent I am not a lobbyist I
am not with big
Pharma and I understand these are
difficult issues but I really think that
we need to protect the community and our
children at large so thank you thank you
any
questions thank you thank you so just to
clarify um I I also am opposed to the
next bill but can this testimony serve
to cover both uh well we've got your the
clerk taking notes so that that can be
part of his notes okay so maybe I should
put the the um other bill on the card um
or does it matter it doesn't matter okay
do okay thank you so much thank you no
one else has signed up to testify on HB
664a I'm afraid to ask does anybody else
want to testify seeing none um I'm going
to close that public hearing and open
the public hearing for HB
679 uh the Prime sponsor is in the room
representative Kelly
Penza and and uh representative Penza we
do need a pink card from
you and
know hey
me proceed when you're ready
representative thank you Mr chair uh for
the record um my name is representative
Kelly Penza straford District 19
um so I'm here today to
introduce what I consider a simple bill
but um nobody else in this room will um
is to add one line here which uh or
actually becomes
two um underneath RSA 141 C20 nothing in
this section shall require a vaccine
that has not been shown in um to prevent
transmission
so right now the list of vac vaccines
that I know for um certain that do not
prevent transmission are polio Hib and T
um and if we are saying that vaccine
mandates or
requirements uh are in place for a
community benefit when they cannot
prevent transition uh transmission then
there's no Community benefit it is a
personal protective decision and we
don't mandate any other personally
protective
medication so the argument um that is
against mandating vaccines that do not
prevent transmission for children
revolve around these key points lack of
public health justification the primary
justification for vaccine mandates is to
prevent the spread of infectious
diseases and protect the broader
Community if a vaccine does not
significantly reduce transmission the
public health benefit of mandating it
diminishes individual risk benefit
assessment when a vaccine primarily
protects the individual rather than
reducing community spread the decision
to vaccinate should be left to parents
and Guardians based on the child's
specific Health needs and risk factors
ethical and bodily autonomy
concerns mandating a medical
intervention especially for children
raises ethical concerns when the
intervention does not provide a direct
Community
benefit parents should have the right to
make medical decisions for their
children when the choice does not
significantly impact others
potential side effects and unknown
long-term risks even well- tested
vaccines can have side effects and if
they do not prevent
transmission the argument for mandating
them weakens further parents should be
able to weigh potential risks and
benefits without
coercion erosion of public trust
mandating vaccines that do not clearly
contribute to hurt immunity uh
undermine um trust in the public health
authori
and future vaccine programs transparency
and voluntary participation May
encourage greater long-term trust and
compliance and then of course
alternative protective measures if a
vaccine does not prevent spread other
strategies treatments hygiene measures
targeted protection for vulnerable
populations may be more appropriate than
mandates I passed out five different um
pieces of information here of course I'm
not going to go through these I wanted
to um
first in the article that talks about
pusas on the last page which would be it
says 528 on here but it's the last page
of the document under
conclusions this is what's very
important the effects of wholesale
protestas vaccine wne after 5 to 10
years the infection is in a vaccinated
person causes non-specific symptoms
vaccinated adolescents and adults may
serve as reservoirs for silent infection
and become potential transmitters to
unprotective infants the whole cell
vaccine for petasus is protective only
against clinical disease not against
infection therefore even young recently
vaccinated children may serve as
reservoirs and potential transmitters of
infection
that's
huge why would we be mandating
that in the other article here which
talks and I never pronounced this
correctly dpia dpia dpia maybe I did it
um under uh right on the first page
under the results vaccinated individuals
can become colonized and transmit
consequently vacillation alone can only
interrupt Transmission in 28% of
outbreak settings making isolation and
antibiotics essential while antibiotics
reduce the duration of infection they
must be paired with diptheria deferia um
antitoxin to limit
morbidity
in polio now I want to preface this with
um we are only using ipv here um in the
states and so the document that I
um I have two pieces here um this is a
and I can send you guys this
electronically so right here on um this
document which is called polio the
beginning of the end um the author is
the World Health Organization it crystal
clear in activated polio vaccine works
by producing protective antibodies in
the blood thus presenting the spread of
polio to the central nervous system
however it induces only very low
immunity to polio virus inside the gut
as a result it provides individual
protection against polio paralysis but
only marginally reduces the spread of
wild polio virus in a person immunized
with ipv Wild Virus can still multiply
inside the intestines and be shed in
stools because of this ipv could not be
used to eradicate polio right here on um
Poo's Global eradication ini itive
website I made it big on that page right
at the bottom it says however as ipv
does not stop transmission of the virus
opv is used wherever a polio outbreak
needs to be contained even in countries
which rely exclusively on ipv for their
routine immunization program once polio
has been um eradicated use of all opv
will need to be stopped to prevent
reestablishment of transmission Mission
due to
vdpvs now these are real hard stories
and if you are not familiar with them I
just there's many that are out there I
gave you guys two examples and um these
are from a science um basically a
science
publication
so this was when um um they basically
did an
experiment um on the polio
vaccine so something momentous happened
in the history of polio eradication in
April of
2016 over a period of two weeks 155
countries and territories started to use
a new version of Albert sabin's classic
oral polio vaccine opv that no longer
protected against one of the three types
of the polio virus type 2 virus that had
been eradicated by then and the only
remaining type 2 polio cases were
touched off by the live virus in the
vaccine itself dropping the type two
component from the vaccine would end
those cases as well the thinking went
but the switch as this Global move has
become known became an unqualified
failure according to the unusually blunt
draft report commissioned by the global
polio eradication initiative gpei
that is now open for public comments
unexpectedly vaccine derived polio type
2 has continued to circulate after the
switch paralyzing more than
3,300
children that is literally insane to
me even after that they still say in
this article this report is a real hard
read says John I can't pronounce his
last name for the fool director of the
cdc's global immunization Division and a
member of the strategy committee that
governs gpei but he says I also think it
will lead us to forging very effective
paths to finish the job of
eradication I don't need to read any
other um Snippets from this other
article but I think that that's just a
wakeup call about how important it is to
be very serious with vaccination
efforts um it this putting this line in
doesn't stop anything it removes things
from a schedule because it doesn't
prevent transmission everyone is still
free to get as many vaccinations as they
want for their families it's clear the
reason why they're in there as a mandate
is because it's it's supposed to stop
transmission it does
not I'll take any questions thank you
any
questions see no questions okay thank
you also signed up to speak at Colleen
Smith and Dr Benjamin Chan from the
Department of Health and Human Services
testing all right uh good afternoon
again uh Mr chair members of the
committee thank you for this opportunity
yet again to come and testify before you
on House Bill 679 again for the record
my name is Dr Benjamin Shan I'm the
state epidemiologist at the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services and I'm joined by Colleen Smith
who's the bureau chief uh for the the
Bureau of uh Infectious Disease Control
in public health um before I jump into
some of the details on this um testimony
I know these uh these hearings can get a
little bit technical especially when
we're talking about scientific studies
and different types of scientific
studies so I I want to bring us back to
the fact that uh the department only
requires a subset of all recommended
vaccines 10 uh vaccines to protect
against 10 different diseases uh for
entering into school and child care um
and these are vaccines that are highly
effective at preventing disease uh and
hence keep kids and schools and child
care agencies and communities safe and
that there are uh medical and religious
exemptions available for um for people
to uh balance the requirements with uh
medical need and religious right and Rel
ious Freedom um I I do want to however
uh be clear I think that the department
uh opposes House Bill 679 um for a
number of reasons the first is that the
wording on the bill is
unclear um depending on how the
legislation is interpreted uh if adopted
House Bill 679 could prevent requiring
many important childhood immunizations
again based on the intent um I want to
highlight again that the primary purpose
of any vaccine is to prevent sickness
and disease
uh especially more severe illness that
can be life-threatening or
incapacitating um and all vaccines that
are currently required for entry into
school or Child Care do prevent illness
and do prevent the spread of disease but
vaccines are not 100% effective at
stopping transmission of pathogens um
and even vaccines that are effective at
preventing some transmission many if not
most are not going to be 100% um
effective at preventing the spread or
the transmission of the actual pathogen
that causes
disease so it's unclear whether House
Bill 679 intends to limit vaccine
requirements to only those vaccines that
have been shown to be effective at
preventing the spread of disease which
is all vaccines or vaccines that have
explicitly been studied and shown to be
effective at preventing the spread of
infectious pathogens um if the intent is
to have proven efficacy at preventing
spread of the pathogens themselves uh
then again the department may not be
able to require um any vaccine because
no vaccine is 100% effective so some
examples and the other important point I
want to note is that clinical trials um
the clinical trials that are used to
study vaccines um usually don't look at
uh transmission of infectious pathogens
as the clinical endpoint that they're
studying right they look at prevention
of disease um and so the absence of a
clinical trial
uh showing prevention of transmission
doesn't mean that vaccines aren't
effective at doing that this is one of
those gray areas where there may not be
data because that's not how the clinical
trials are designed uh so some examples
I think you heard in prior testimony uh
concern that uh hemophilus influenza
type B or Hib and deia vaccines are not
effective at preventing transmission I I
would counter that these are diseases we
don't see anymore in clinical medicine I
can't remember the last time we had a
report and these are reportable diseases
to Public Health I can't remember a time
when we had a a case of Hib infection or
deia infection in New Hampshire because
the vaccines are pre are effective at
preventing disease and even when you
might pick these up on routine throat
cultures for example they're they're
just not found anymore these pathogens
are not routinely out there and
circulating but if vaccination rates
fall low enough as we've seen with other
diseases they could make a comeback um
you've heard mention of the Polar
vaccine the polio vaccine is uh more
than 99% effective after three doses at
preventing paralytic polio but the the
uh sponsor is correct that the
inactivated polio vaccine the vaccine
the shot does not necessarily produce
the gut immunity or the intestinal
immunity that would prevent the the
virus from passing through a person's
feces to somebody else if they were
exposed but again we have seen
remarkable strides globally in
eradicating polio there's only one other
disease out there that has been
eradicated small poox uh and yet we have
a uh vaccines plural and a global
strategy by which we can achieve Global
eradication of a disease and in
potentially in the future not require
the vaccine anymore but that work is
still ongoing uh you also heard mention
of uh pertusus it's true that pertusus
uh is not the most effective vaccine
that we have but it is 80 85% effective
at preventing uh severe illness um and
that could cause you know weeks or
months or potentially longer term uh
symptoms and complications of disease um
so again I think it comes back to the
fact that um you know clinical trials
are not usually designed to study uh
prevention of spread of a pathogen they
are used to study prevention of disease
and all of the required vaccines that we
have uh listed um do that um so the
bottom line is I guess again uh vaccines
prevent disease prevent the spread of
disease prevent severe disease keep
children and staff healthy and in school
and in child care and it protects the
individual but also the people around
them um with that let me stop and happy
to uh we're happy to take questions
thank you two seconds had two seconds
left perfect timing representative
Drew so I asked this question before but
I'd like to ask you if if vaccines were
recommended by the state and not
mandated by the state would that change
your job in any
way um maybe I'll start and I'll see if
uh Colleen Colleen wants to chime in
here as well uh will that change our job
in any way you know I think the answer
is yes and it's not about changing my
job I think it's about you know
protecting the the health and the
well-being of schools and children and
communities and uh you know we've
already seen that as uh requirements are
relaxed over time that exemption rates
have increased and certainly if if this
bill or the prior Bill are enacted it
would um likely do away with many if not
most vaccine requirements which would
further uh decrease vaccination rates
leading to increased diseases new
introductions of disease new outbreaks
of disease um all of which are um
investig by public health um you know
there have been estimates that you know
a single measles Outbreak on average
costs $30,000 the the one back in I
think 2018 2019 in New York City cost
them over a million dollars to respond
to so you know there is both a health
aspect as well as a time and cost aspect
to responding to infectious diseases I
don't know if you want to
add anyone else representative delus
then representative Kastle thank you Mr
chairman than thank you for taking my
question so do you do you know how many
parents or Guardians refuse the vaccines
the mandated
vaccines you want to so we we do not
collect that information as far as how
many have opted out of vaccines we we do
we we do have information as far as
those that have claimed medical or
religious exemptions for school entry
but we don't have uh specific data on
opt out and we also have those that are
have the percent percent of those that
are up to date on their
vaccines
followup I guess this could be a
follow-up so do parents or Guardians are
you aware of any parents or Guardians
who request additional vaccines on top
of the required
vaccines uh so so I guess two two
comments to that one is that we don't
get patient specific information at the
health department about who declines and
who wants vaccines that's probably a
better question for um uh a primary care
provider but I I will say that you know
the the list of uh required vaccines
protect against 10 different diseases
not all you know not all recommended
vaccines are on that list um you know
it's maybe about 50 to 60% of the all
recommended vaccines are on that list
it's a rough estimate um and so I I
think there are people out there that
get all the recommended vaccines not the
ones on the required list but I we don't
have those
numbers representative kleang thank you
Mr chair so reading through the the
outline part that you said in the bill
to prevent transmission uh of any
disease so the question I have I'm
seeing this sheet here with a bunch of
bunch of these different things that
that are given for immunizations now the
question I have specifically to that is
any of these immunizations on this have
a potential to spread the pro or
transmit the disease the same way yeah
uh thanks for that question
representative I I don't have that sheet
so I'm I'm not sure what exactly you
were looking
at I'll I'll respond to the perhaps the
the prior um the
prior testimony about pusis po people
getting vaccinated with pus potentially
serving as a reservoir um you know as I
mentioned that's that's uh I I don't I
don't know that data I'm not sure I
haven't I'm not familiar with the
article that the person was was
referring to um you know I will say that
anytime you have a lower efficacy
vaccine and again that the pertusus of
all the ones that are on the required
list pertusus you know most of the
vaccines on the required list are like
95 plus perc effective at preventing
disease when you have a vaccine that's
that effective which is most of them um
they're they're going to be pre
effective at preventing not only the
disease but likely transmission as well
right I mean you see this with with
measles um you you you see the the you
know this is why we can eradicate
certain diseases pressus um may be
slightly different in that the efficacy
is focused more around preventing severe
disease 80 to 85% effective so it's
certainly possible that uh somebody
could have a more mild illness um be in
a a school setting and then spread it to
other people but in terms of how
commonly that happens we we don't have
we we don't have data on it and you know
whether vaccination leads to increased
spread again I I don't I don't know that
there's good data around that or I don't
know what the data was at the price
prior person was referring to follow
thank you um so I guess how would you
collect the data because it doesn't
sound like you have the information to
answer that effectively so how would you
obtain
that uh that that's a good that's a good
question
um there would have to be uh trying to
think about you know what kind of study
would be you know what kind of study
would would be required of that um you
know we we investigate every person
diagnosed with tus so that we can
identify people that may be exposed uh
to get them um appropriate an for
example antibiotic profilaxis to prevent
coming down with infection um so you
know we have data in terms of uh how how
often pressus is diagnosed but that's um
probably a subset of all the people with
pressus out there so there would have to
be you know large screening trials that
are conducted um in you know certain
populations I I don't I don't know that
those Studies have been have been
done one final one yeah just to clarify
so you said that that you guys do get
the information for prasa specifically
or you said you have for for
investigation thank you is that data is
that data somewhere uh it's it's all
it's all online on our our website uh we
list a uh publish a monthly reportable
disease list um where uh we we put the
numbers of people with different
diseases that are reported to us again
that's those are just the people that
are tested and diagnosed and then
reported to us um pressus is one of
those areas where you know symptoms at
least in the early stages can M can
mimic other types of infections and so
testing may not be done people whether
they're vaccinated or not could be out
there you know spreading the disease and
if we get alerted to that we do our
investigation representative McGrath did
you have your hand up
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my
question can you tell us what
the current definition of what a vaccine
is my understanding is that the
definition was changed
recently and do you know what the change
was and why that happened you remember U
this is I assume somewhere in RSA 141c
yes it so so the the uh the definition
was Chang CH by Senate Bill 559 last
session so that it was to include the R
so that the RSV vaccine would be
included uh in the the vaccine for the
universal vaccine purchasing program so
it was worded to and I we can pull up
the exact wording but so that a monocon
antibody was included in the definition
of
vaccine or immunization I should
say okay any any other
questions saying none thank you thank
you very
much also signed up to speak is Victoria
Shaheen from New Hampshire families for
vaccines
micone there you go thank you uh I'd
like to voice my strong opposition to
House Bill 679 which places a brand new
requirement that a vaccine must be shown
quote in clinical trials to prevent
transmission of any disease um as
pointed out this is not how clinical
trials are conducted um I think the bill
also neglects to consider some of the
fundamental principles of virology and
infectious disease transmission uh
vaccines are designed to keep people
from being hospitalized and uh from
dying uh they are tested for safety and
efficacy very rigorously in clinical
trials um AKA how good they are at
keeping people out of the hospitals and
out of the
morgs um it is not possible uh to my
knowledge to incorporate um transmission
blocking properties as a clinical end
point in a trial um I think that would
need to be demonstrated before we could
actually legislate that um so it seems
like the bill is trying to make a
requirement out of something that isn't
done or cannot be done in the first
place in order to create an impossible
standard that no vaccine could ever meet
uh again aimed at limiting access um so
as I mentioned vaccines are tested for
safety and efficacy however transmission
Dynamics are indeed studied during the
open label period and any postmarket
surveillance we collect epidemiological
data um
we we it has been demonstrated that
vaccination can reduce uh viral load
that an infected person is carrying um
so uh one thing about viral replication
is that it is the only predictable thing
about it is that it's very chaotic and
the virus's goal is to reach host cells
in an unvaccinated individual there are
billions and billions more copies of
viruses being made and being expelled
typically into the air uh for other
people to catch so A reduced viral load
does indeed reduce transmission um
vaccines lessen the severity of symptoms
so you may not be you know explosively
coughing or sneezing all over the person
next to you if you're vaccinated you're
going to be shedding less virus you're
going to be less contagious that is a
lowering of transmission uh also
duration of disease generally uh
vaccines limit the severity of disease
so you're contagious for a shorter
period of time again if you've taken
statistics uh it's a numbers game you're
reducing transmission Again by
shortening the length of uh acute
symptoms um and finally more rapid
clearance of infection uh altogether so
uh that is what vaccines are designed to
do and that is what they do um so again
I think to set vaccines up for failure
in a clinical trial by setting an
impossible standard will limit access
will decrease uptake and will will uh
demonstrate the reemergence of a number
of uh diseases we have not seen in a
long time nor should we and I will close
uh by mentioning I think this bill also
fails to consider diseases that are not
uh transmitted personto person like
tetanus um which is something I would
never uh wish on anyone especially a
child so um how would you prove that the
tetus vaccine prevents transmission
which doesn't occur in the first place
um or also uh the rabies vaccine so and
from my understanding there is a bill
floating around here somewhere that uh
legalizes proposes to legalize keeping
wild squirrels and raccoons as pets so I
would hate to see us lose a rabies
vaccine based on this recommendation so
again I oppose this Bill thank you very
much oh any questions representative
R you've stated a couple of times that
it would limit access by removing these
vaccines from the Mandate how would it
limit
access um so well I
think first of all if if uh vaccines
aren't required we know um that their
uptake will go down so that I think
creates a lower demand um for these
vaccines a lower demand creates a less
of an incentive for manufacturers to
actually make these vaccines uh so I
could see um you know Supply going down
and when there's limited Supply Access
is limited um so that that would be my
my
answer any other
questions thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is Julie Kim
from The New Hampshire American Academy
of pedi
Pediatrics hello again everyone thank
you for having me today um again I'm
speaking for on behalf of the
pediatricians in New Hampshire over 200
of us to urge you to oppose House Bill
679 approved childhood vaccines help to
protect kids in a number of ways not
just by preventing illness but it could
also reduce the severity of symptoms
you've heard all this before and it can
reduce the risk of transmission to
others by either reducing the duration
of disease so hence reducing the risk of
transmission or and also reducing load
of um disease burden so there are other
benefits besides just preventing the
disease depending on the vaccine and the
vaccine present pre preventable disease
in question the benefits of vaccination
differ what is consistent is that in all
cases the FDA and other Global
Regulators only approve vaccines for use
if they determine that the data to use
them has a favorable benefit and risk
profile to the child who's going to
receive the vaccine and then again after
a vaccine is approved it is subject to
ongoing real world monitoring to ensure
that the benefits continue to outweigh
the any potential risks as was just
mentioned um this bill would prevent us
from administering important disease
like tetanus because that is not a a
transmittable disease in the way from
Human to human transmission but we know
tetus is important for children and we
have good and - tested interventions for
this and then finally this bill is a
reminder that there's some legislative
intrusion into the practice of medicine
and this has the potential for creating
unintended consequences through changes
in long-standing policies that are meant
to protect the health and safy safety of
our state citizens our young children
and then the older people that they are
in contact with so for this reason the
the New Hampshire AAP urges you to
oppose House Bill 679 thanks
thank you any
questions thank
you also signed up to speak is
representative Janet Lucas on behalf of
Meg obaba
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for your Indulgence today for
the record I'm Janet Lucas I represent
Grafton District Grafton County district
7 which is Campton I am reading the
testimony of a constituent so I will not
be taking questions to the members of
the committee my name is mag overb I
reside in Campton I am a lifelong New
Hampshire resident and I am a pharmacist
in a multihospital health system I am
submitting this testimony in opposition
to HB
679 as a pharmacist I am concerned about
the nature of this bill it seems
relatively innocuous to a lay person it
is just one sentence nothing in this
section shall require a vaccine that has
been shown in clinical trials to prevent
transmission of any disease close quote
in spite of this I believe that it is
meant as an attack on our current
vaccine laws vaccines are meant to
prevent clinical and subclinical
infections in vaccinated persons they
are not intended to stop transmission of
disease vaccines prevent infection not
transmission an example of an agent
intended to stop the transmission of a
disease would be a mask which can
prevent the transmission of respiratory
diseases one could surmise then that the
intent of this bill is to effectively
eliminate RSA 141c
20-a I would venture a guess that the
sponsoring legislators of this bill will
not be proposing a mask mandate for all
New Hampshire residents as an
alternative to to the currently required
vaccinations I truly do not understand
the dogged anti-science dedication of
this legislative session to cause harm
and death to children in New Hampshire
it is frankly appalling thank you for
your consideration Meg overball doctor
of Pharmacy
rph thank
you also signed up to speak is Pam
denapoli uh from the New Hampshire
School nurses
Association uh thank you my name is Pam
daple and um I submitt a written
testimony for the New Hampshire school
Nurses Association who opposes this bill
um but what I'd like to do today is just
to give you the realities of what it is
to be a school nurse so we see probably
40 to 60 students a day in most of the
Manchester schools and every winter we
do what we can to decrease the number of
communicable diseases within our schools
things like vomiting diarrhea cough and
colds we send parents home a letter
saying please keep your children home
when they're sick this year at times
we've had over half of the students in
any one class absent with these
communicable diseases so despite all of
our efforts for infection control we
can't control communicable diseases what
we can control is vaccine preventable
diseases so the more students that we
can have vaccinated the greater chance
that it's going to decrease transmission
than it is to increase transmission what
we've heard is that these uh vaccines
are to prevent disease and severity of
disease and not transmission but the
more children that we can vaccinate the
less chance that we are going to have
the minimal chances of disease
transmission we also know that there are
certain children children who um have
breakthrough diseases so despite being
um vaccinated we see at times children
don't build up sufficient immunity and
may transmit the disease some
individuals cannot develop immunity
after vaccines and infants who are too
young or may have not completed their
vaccine series May transmit the disease
and get the disease and have serious
consequences so um in most counties it
it's been asked today about whether or
not most most parents refuse uh vaccines
so in only one County in New Hampshire
in Co county is
95.7% uh transmission or uh vaccine
coverage in all of our other counties we
haven't reached the recommended 95%
coverage for vaccines so if we uh make
uh vaccines recommended versus mandated
we risk falling way below 95% that we
haven't even achieved yet so uh for the
sake of the School nurses and all that
we have to do in a day um we really
don't want to be also excluding children
who have vaccine preventable diseases
thank you thank you representative
kessle wi thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question so does the
school system I'm curious with the
nurses do they have access to which
children have taken the vaccine and who
haven't we well if if you're in the
school system you have to give us either
um evidence that you had had vaccines or
the religious exemption form that we
talked about last
week anyone else thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is Risa
Evans from uh Children's Health
defense uh you've asked for eight
minutes I can't give you eight minutes
three minutes pleas whatever you can
give me I wasn't sure how it worked
thank you um thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee um so I think
everybody here we all cherish our own
bodily autonomy including the right to
refuse unwanted medical interventions
both for ourselves and for our children
and I thought and I don't know if this
is true but I thought most people would
agree that before we mandate require a
vaccine for people who don't want them
for their children the vaccine would
need to meet a minimum of three
conditions first what we were talking
about before it would need to be safe
second it would be necessary to stop the
spread of a dangerous infectious disease
that poses a threat to Public Health
Public Health rationale and third you
would want before mandating a vaccine to
make sure that it actually sort of
satisfied that public health rationale
that it stops transmission of the
disease um and so what I want to submit
to you today is that requiring um
vaccines to stop transmission or some
sort of proof that they can stop
transmission whether it's through a
clinical trial or otherwise before the
vaccine can be mandated makes sense not
just from an ethical standpoint but also
from a legal standpoint and to do that I
just want to talk briefly about the
leading US Supreme Court case on vaccine
mandates which some or all of you may
have heard of it's called Jacobson
versus Massachusetts and it's a case
that was um that was decided in 1905 and
has really been cited especially in
recent years as the justification the
legal justification for for current
vaccine mandates um and you know the
case is very interesting because it's
been interpreted by a lot of Courts very
broadly to sort of permit any and all
mandates but if you if you read the case
closely and I think courts are going to
start doing this in fact The Jacobson
case really kind of limits the ability
of a government to impose mandates um to
circumstances where a vaccine stops a
very serious um is is targeted at a very
serious infectious disease and it
actually stops transmission so just just
briefly The Jacobson case was decided in
1905 during this um a a small poox out
break in Cambridge Massachusetts and the
Cambridge Board of Health passed a a a
regulation pursuant to a state statute
that it gave it um the authority to do
this and it said you have to have a
small a small pox vaccine or pay a $5
fine and Mr Jacobson was convicted of
violating the ordinance and he argued
all the way up to the Supreme Court that
the requirement that he take the small
poox uh vaccine basically violated his
due process rights to bodily autonomy
and to Liberty and um and so the Supreme
Court upheld the case and um it said you
know unequivocally that a community has
the right to protect itself against an
epidemic of disease that threatens the
safety of its members and the court said
that the rights of individuals in
respect to their own individual liberty
May at times of great dangers be subject
to restraints um that the safety of the
general public demands um and so you
know with that in mind it upheld the
smallpox mandate um so but what ja up
what Jacobson doesn't say is that any
and all mandates are allowable in fact
what the ca what the court said
specifically was that the the the
Mandate was enacted because the the um
Health Board found it necessary to
protect the um public from the um
disease of small pox serious disease and
the prevailing understanding at the time
was that the vacine prevented
transmission of small poox and it was on
these grounds that the court upheld it I
just really urge you to keep that in
mind as you're as you're considering
this thank Youk any questions
representative plaz off and then
representative marel thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question so
we heard that uh even uh vaccines uh
that are S as sterilizing vaccines don't
stop 100% of transmission uh but at the
same time maybe it's moment medical
question but we have antibiotics we have
antiviral uh drugs and agents and some
other Medical Treatments that might to
certain extent limit the
transmission so legally speaking why we
mandating vaccines but uh why but not
other agents that might limit
transmission to certain
extent um I I'm not I'm not sure that I
from a medical standpoint I can't can't
answer that I mean just from a legal
standpoint I think the justification for
vaccines you know is that they prevent
Transmission in some sort of unique way
that can't be done you know that's I
mean because you're you're you're a a
Mand a vaccine mandate is a mandate that
you you know allow your body to be
penetrated with a needle and injected
with a substance that you may or may not
want and so to you know um to sort of
allow the state to require that you know
there has to be a very strong
justification and I think the strong
justification and actually they talked
about that in the in the Jacobson case
was that um it was believed that this
was the best way of preventing the
spread of small poox was through the
vaccination so if it's not the best way
then that would be another sort of you
know reason to
reconsider representative
Marquel yes thank you for thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question so basically if you're looking
at Jacobson and what you're talking
about the essential holding would be
rational basis review correct um I I
think not I mean I that that's how some
courts have interpreted it but I think
really if you look closely at it it
balances the um liberty interest of the
individual against the needs of the
community and it determines that the you
know that the that that under these
circumstances um that you know that that
the needs of the community are are are
greater and are also served by by
something that clearly meets the you
know the end that it was designed for
which was to stop disease the other
thing I think that important to remember
is that since Jacobson was decided the
US Supreme Court has recognized a whole
host of Rights about bodily autonomy
that were sort of unheard of in 1905
including the right to reject unwanted
Medical Treatments even when they're
life-saving and so you know I I thought
a lot of commentators are sort of urging
the court the court system to kind of
revisit Jacobson in light of the more
modern case law that really is much more
protective of of individual liberty than
than Jacobson was but I would say that
under you know under under Jacobson or
under the more current case law I've
outlined it actually I have a statement
here which I can share with you no no
well representative Mel do you have
anything else uh yes I had a followup
followup please okay thank you so but on
the other hand what we're talking about
here and following up with you on this
for example passing Yoda review
Wisconsin uh where parents have a right
to limit their education based I'm sure
you're familiar with that case okay okay
basically that was a case where Amish
people were allowed to terminate
education at the eth grade uh based on
their culture um also followup USV Lee
which I think 1982 which also says a
state can have a an overwhelming
interest over can have a stronger
interest uh outweighs the right of the
individual but to addressing your point
as a matter of law since um states can
regulate for the health safety and
well-being being uh you would agree
would you not that states can regulate
for the health and safety of their
population absolutely so in other words
you would have to agree would you not
that if the um if this body were to pass
this particular legislation it would
become law it would also be
constitutional using rational basis
review I I'm not sure I'm following the
question okay well in other words
rational basis review stands for the
proposition that uh uh a state can enact
a regulation that is rationally related
to a legitimate government objective so
if it's a legitimate government
objective in terms of vaccinations no
matter how you treat it this this
particular statute if it became law
would in fact be constitutional wouldn't
it yes that if it limited if it limited
mandates to to to you know V vaccines
that actually stop transmission I mean I
think they obviously other issues that
might might be at play but yeah but that
that piece of it would certainly be a
step in the right direction I think okay
thank you thank you thank you ma'am
thank
you also signed up to speak is Colleen
fer from the New Hampshire Nurses
Association good afternoon
again I'm submitting testimony again on
behalf of over 1250 nurses who are
members of the New Hampshire nurses ass
Association our missions to improve the
health of the people of New Hampshire
I've been a nurse for over 36 years in
multiple Public Health roles and
witnessed the societal benefits of
childhood vaccination and preventing
death and disease over the course of
their lifetimes us children born between
1994 and 2018 who are vaccinated
according to the recommended
immunization schedule will prevent
419 million in illnesses
26.8 million
hospitalizations and 93,000 deaths the
research shows that loosening vac
childhood vaccination requirements for
school will decrease vaccination rates
if you have tried to seek care recently
you will know firsthand that New
Hampshire's Health Care system is
already overburdened it is not unusual
to wait out 8 hours to be seen in
emergency room or months for a primary
care
appointment imagine how much worse
accessing care would be with fewer
vaccinated children not to mention the
unnecessary deaths from vaccine
preventable disease learning about the
measles outbreak in Texas has been
heartbreaking during January 1 to August
15 2024 a total of 219 measel cases were
reported in the United States exceeding
the number of cases reported annually
during the 2020 to 2023
range 100 of the 219 cases 190 or
86% were among people who were
unvaccinated or had unknown vaccination
status as lawmakers you are in a
position to significantly impact Public
Health in New Hampshire by voting itl on
HB
679 the nurses doctors and multiple
healthc care providers are counting on
you to make decisions that will not
increase the significant burden healthc
care providers in New Hampshire already
feel thank you for your service to the
people of New
Hampshire thank you any questions
representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so sometimes you
know when you when you live in a free
Society some things can be a little bit
inconvenient and I think that kind of
happens when when we talk about mandates
we certainly can mandate um and uh the
lady who was right up before talked
about the Jacobson case which kind of
laid out the framework where and I'm not
a lawyer like representative marel but
it kind of laid out that a kind of a
litmus test um where there has to be a
compelling State you know interest and
so when you look at like something like
measles versus something like
tness um how do you do you draw no
distinction uh between the two uh
relative to what we just heard in terms
of a compelling State need or do you or
do you do you kind of measure them the
same way I do not because I believe that
one death of a child is one death too
many
see representative Castle Rings thank
you Mr chair I just got to ask you the
statistics that you cited where did
where those come from just curious so
there yeah I I'll be handing this
testimony in yeah but it uh there's a
couple of resources um one is from the
CDC one is from the um MMR report from
2023 okay okay I'm seeing no other
questions thank you thank you
and also signed up to speak is Melissa
blasich from new bill New Hampshire You'
asked for five minutes please keep it to
three I'm
going thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'm Melissa blasik I'm here
representing rebuild NH uh sterilizing
immunity refers to an immune response
that completely prevents a pathogen from
establishing an infection in a host
effectively stopping it from replicating
and being transmitted to others one
could say the gold standard example of a
vaccine like this is the small pox
vaccine
um I because I'm trying to keep this
brief obviously I think previous
speakers have gone through a lot of the
vaccines on the New Hampshire schedule
that are not an example of this um last
week I came before this committee to
discuss a bill that did not directly
address the merits of vaccine mandates
and yet the subject kept getting brought
up and I want to restate what I said
then mandates breed skepticism and good
ideas do not require Force I'm not here
to discuss the personally protective
benefits of these vaccines
but that's what they are personally
protective we do not mandate any other
pharmaceutical product with personally
protective benefits we don't mandate
that a diabetic take insulin or someone
with high cholesterol take a Statin
because people have the right to make
their own choices about their own health
accepting risks and taking personal
responsibility the purpose of the
vaccine mandates in RSA 141c is to
mandate vaccines of everyone who is able
to receive a vaccine to protect those
who are not able
if the vaccine cannot prevent
transmission however I believe that this
argument is negated it is time that we
start rethinking the idea of mandated
vaccines and I think that hb70 uh 679 is
a very good place to start um if I have
a couple more minutes so uh just quickly
go through I have some studies I'm going
to send in but um it does appear that
the only vaccines on the New Hampshire
school schedule that actually do stop
transmission are the MMR vaccine and
Poss possibly be um but the rest of them
do not actually have that ability these
are personally
protective um benefits only um that is
it I will take any questions thank you
representative Woods thank you Mr chair
and uh thank you for taking my question
uh transmission is a key element but um
can you
identify that there is a uh would you
agree that there is a difference between
five % transmission and 95%
transmission uh and the impact so just
incorporating the term transmission
doesn't really identify the benefit that
one would generate would that be
correct thank you for the question um I
understand what you're saying but again
the idea of mandates again we're not
trying to take away anybody's vaccine
access here but the idea of mandating a
vaccine there should be a very high
threshold to have that type of of
government dictate and that kind of high
threshold should be that there is no way
that you can give somebody who is
vulnerable and can't get that vaccine
that disease and that is simply not the
case with the rest of these vaccines but
I do understand what you're
saying representative
mlan thank you and thank you for taking
my question so um so for a disease like
technus for example um if we go back to
the Jacobson case just because it was
brought up and we were talking about a
technus vaccine in
1905 um where do you think uh the court
would have come down at that time we
know where they came down on small talks
in the decision sure where do you think
they would have come down and this is
speculative sure um with respect to
tetanus thank you for the question so
tetanus is a non-communicable disease so
it cannot spread from person to person
so I do believe that if it if I'm
speculating right um if it was the same
court as Jacobson I I do not believe
that they would have said that that met
the threshold for to be
mandated thank you representative paza
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so if we require
vaccines that don't stop transmission or
increase transmission should be there
some uh informed consent especially
given that we heard today about some
oncological kids who are vulnerable uh
and uh some other situations that I know
sometimes people vaccinate siblings to
protect somebody imun compromised so and
if we mandate it and if we know that
it's like 5% or 90% or sometimes it's
over 100% if it's actually in C
transmission and I heard the it I saw
the data that pertusus is not the only
one that can increase transmission so
should should we
notify families if we are mandating
something like that um thank you for the
question I believe that all medical
procedures and interventions should have
full informed consent and I think that
that is some of the reason why there is
vaccine hesitancy and and skepticism
because mandates breed skepticism but
also because there is not typically
fully informed consent when it comes to
vaccines um
yeah okay thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is Louise
Spencer from Kent
Street and I'm sorry I thought I wasn't
going to speak again but I just had a
couple quick things to add thank you Mr
chair and thank you the committee um I
just wanted to make a point that I think
what really breeds distrust um is uh
misinformation and disinformation so I
just wanted to add that but um regarding
my daughter who had uh whooping cough
she was lucky in that she had had one
dose of the vacc before she was exposed
to a person who was undervaccinated and
who didn't realize they had whipping
cough um our doctor was very clear that
had she not had that dose um she very
well would have ended up in the hospital
and it would have been a much more
serious situation even though as it
stood it was a very serious in situation
indeed so you know we can talk about
transmission um you know complete
blocking of disease or we can think
about what um you know lessening harm
and certainly in my daughter's case you
know having some protection was was
probably the difference between life or
death for her um I also I don't know if
this committee notes the sign-ins from
the um from the portal in and includes
those in the um we aware of yes okay do
they they get added to the
record um that I don't know so I'm just
noting that on 664 there are 205 people
signed in um in support and
814 signed in opposed and on this bill
203 signed in in support and 793 signed
in um opposed so I just thought I would
let folks know that that's how it's
running thank you thank you very much
thanks very much representative bazov
thank you uh Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so you testified how
doctor was uh advertising vaccines to
you and uh giving you scary data about
uh the disease uh uh what what kind of
information your doctor read to you from
vaccine ins regarding side
effects what information did I get about
the side effects yeah yes doctor um I I
actually got quite a bit of information
about the side effects and in fact my
daughter had um not a particularly great
reaction to the the first dose of the
vaccine um so we had extensive
conversations about whether or not um
she would get the second
dose and the third I believe there are
three doses um it's a little bit shaky
In My Memory right now um the fact that
she then developed whooping cough um he
chose to give her the vaccine without
the whooping cough uh component I
believe but later as an adult she got
the booster and had with all three
components and had no trouble but we did
have um my doctor was very good I have
to say about having extensive
discussions and then informing me what
to look for uh when my daughter was
crying and you know upset after that
first dose I called my doctor and we
discussed how to proceed also when my
brother had
HIV um we uh discussed at length about
polio vaccines and how to keep him safe
for the period of time um but since it
was an attenuated um vaccine it it was
Rel it was safe to him but they my
doctor still said it's best to just not
have contact with your brother for a
period of time just to be extra safe
thank you all right uh thank you very
much thank you no one else has signed up
to testify on HB 679 so I am going to
close the public hearing and we are
going to go into executive session I
know we um I know representative hartnet
you need to leave by what um
410 okay representative
I have a question that does doesn't
pertain to any of these bills but I
wanted to ask HHS should I just go over
and ask the doctor myself sure if it
doesn't to these bills sure okay thank
you but we are going into executive
session
momentarily uh five
minutes move it or lose
it
e
e e
okay is everyone
here I think everyone's
here okay I'd like to open the executive
session um we have we had eight bills on
on the docket for today we've already
exec one I don't think we're going to
make it through the other seven in the
next uh 35 minutes uh be a miracle if we
did but uh as we proceed please if you
do have anything to say please be brief
because you know we do want to get
through as much as we can start off with
HB 357 representative Drew did you have
a
motion I do I move that
we OTP HB
357 and representative delus you have
you have a second and would you like to
speak to your motion representative Drew
I would
um my Logic on this bill is very
straightforward uh regardless of what
you think about vaccines the ability of
the government the state government to
mandate vaccines is something that
should be a state government
responsibility not a rulemaking
authority of D HHS so that's why I'm
supporting this
bill uh representative delus did you
want to speak to you a second or does
anyone else wish to speak to this
thank you representative
Weber I just think that it's
um
not helpful to Simply
abandon the notion
of
um The rulemaking Authority that has
served us very very well for a long
period of time and uh which could stand
Us in good stead if if the need presents
presented it so uh with that I won't
repow all the ground that's already been
plowed but um I don't think it's I don't
think it's a wise decision on our part
okay thank you representative
mlan yeah thank you Mr chair so um I
think a lot has changed since 20 years
ago when rule making Authority was
granted and so uh we can mandate
obviously the question is what is the
the best way to do it I think the legisl
is the most transparent I like that part
of the bill I'm disappointed uh by the
fact that uh the three vaccines that
were brought in under rule making
Authority were not included I think it
would have made a clean bill so if this
does pass and I will vote for it but if
it does pass I will be bringing in a
legislation next year to bring in uh the
other three
vaccines representative
Weber how about we put this off till
next week and bring in the amendment now
I I'm not going to bring in an amendment
and and the reason I'm not going to do
that is the prime sponsor asked me not
to who has obviously done a lot more
research with these vaccines than I have
so out of respect to him I said I would
not uh bring it in that being said um I
I don't have the same reservations he
does and I will bring them in uh next
year uh just to test out the new
system anyone else before we go to a
vote representative lontine
or yes I I think that uh the inability
of the state legislature to be able to
act swiftly if there is an outbreak
um DHHS you know opposed the bill for
for that reason um I I don't think that
the state legislature is really the
appropriate
place for to make decisions
in public health emergencies and in um
the specifics
of um you know vaccine
policy so I'm going to oppose the bill
um quickly representative woods and
representative hartnet well just just my
personal flavor here I think this is
I'll say it strongly an egregious
misfire on the practice of
medicine to subject
like with Barella with the
chickenpox you've not had the chance to
treat people who had reflex sympathetic
distrophy after chicken fox it is
unbelievable taking this out would
subject U
kids to this some of the others as well
but to me uh we we want to protect the
public public and we want to have the
public have a choice for
sure but we have to be careful that
we're not making choices for other
people
too not just for ourselves and trust me
when I'm taking care of patients that I
pick on RSD refect sympathetic distrophy
uh and that and that's you once you have
it I mean it the the the virus stays in
you that's how you get shingles
and sometimes it's just the itchy itchy
itchy uh but trust me uh it's it's
debilitating if you get it I mean uh I
won't go into a great detail but to me
this we have to be very careful of
trying to practice medicine and this is
really this is really bad
medicine representative hartnet yeah not
to belabor the point I agree with
representative lontine we don't we
shouldn't be in effect practicing
medicine it's really we need to leave
that to the people in the department and
if we object to what they're doing then
you know they should move
on
okay all right with that I'll ask the
clerk to call the roll motion is out to
pass on HB
357 rep Maser yes rep mlan yes rep damus
yes rep co uh rep Hill
yes rep PA off yes clerk votes yes rep
marel yes rep McGrath yes rep kessing
yes rep Weber no rep McKay no rep Woods
no rep Palmer absolutely not rep tez NOP
rep lontine no rep Harnet no rep Lucas
no and rep McDonald yes
vot is 10 to eight motion
passes who's doing the Minority
Report thank
you so not consent calendar no no no no
yes I could have told you that uh presum
presumably the minority would be itl
correct uh yes I I assume the Min
will
right okay okay
um next up is HB 358
and
um rep McGrath window okay yes
representative McGrath thank you Mr
chair I'd like to move uh House Bill 358
ought to
pass and representative marel yes I
second the motion representative McGrath
you wish to speak to your
motion sure my understanding is um the
original
Bill inadvertently created a specific
form that had to be filled out this just
takes away the requirement for a
specific government
form okay anyone
else represented
Weber we were presented with Co copies
of the government form which were simple
clear and provided clear opt outs and I
see no reason to change what wasn't
broken to begin
with representative Woods uh yes um I
will vote against this just on the basis
of the uh one of our charges is the
public
good to to do that we need information
good
information and one of the ways we do it
is with simple forms not a big complex
form but a simple form and by collecting
information on this sheet it helps us do
our job for the public
good and um I appreciate the fact that
it's simple just to scratch something on
a piece of paper but if my kid wanted to
go on a field trip would be a form like
that not just a scratch piece of paper
and I think we can at least do the same
we would do for our patients and our um
constituents that we would do for our
kids
okay anyone else seeing no other
discussion motion is ought to pass on HB
358 I'll ask the par to call the
rooll rep merer yes rep mlan yes rep
damus yes rep Hill
yes rep poov yes clerk votes yes rep
marel yes rep McGrath yes rep kessing
yes rep Weber
no rep McKay we almost had you rep Woods
no rep Palmer no rep taes no rep lontine
no rep Harnet no rep Lucas no rep
McDonald yes vot is 10 to8 motion
passes who will do the minority
reportate I have to send this off right
after
so you need to do
it thank you representative Woods
okay and that'll be itl
right okay should we get into HB 377 we
have enough time yep okay and you have
an amendment representative merer
yes I would like to move
OTP on amendment
number 2025 d 0956
okay and representative uh
0956 representative Maser moves of the
amendment and representative kessle ring
seconds uh representative mea do you
wish to speak to your motion yes I will
keep it simple um it's literally uh line
nine it changed the word sex to
biological sex the definition and then
lines um 17 through 26 it just um in
speaking with uh lawyers afterward it
aligned the substantiative pro
prohibition language with the SP Sketti
Supreme Court case so um when and if
that passes this legislation will
already be in line with
that okay other
discussion
representative okay sure
okay we we have a copy of that
representative for
representative uh Weber's amendment is
coming around representative masers is
on the floor right now for the
committee as everybody had a well let me
know when you've had a chance to read
representative maser's Amendment and uh
you're ready to
discuss which one are we working on um
five six
26 37
9566 0956 H is representative ma that
one 0926 is representative
926 is representative wers yes that's
why they're very close in
numbers yeah I got let me just dou
I may not have very sorry I'm I'm seeing
significant differences between this and
what was originally proposed yep because
I mentioned it aligns just with the
Sketti case so it's exact language from
that but it it um includes definition of
person that were not included in the
original it um
includes significant
changes uh based on a case that I have
not read um and I just wanted to note
that there were significant differences
if I may uh I I would speak about it if
that's appropriate representative um my
my concern is um as one who opposed the
underlying bill I also oppose the
amendment because I think the intent is
the same and I think that the um
although I have not
actually um analized the amendment in
depth I believe that the effect of the
amendment as of the bill is going to be
very harmful for people who are
deserving of our care and our welcoming
and our acceptance and are deserving of
good medical care to the best of the
standards and abilities that we have at
this point in time and therefore I'm
going to be voting
no any other discussion on the
amendment uh uh 0956 representative me's
amendment to
377 representative palaz off and then
representative Palmer and then
representative lontine uh thank you Mr
chair I agree that there are some
language changes uh from original Bill
line 17 to 21 but uh definition of
person was included in original bill and
it's included also in representative
Weber Amendment as well so person is in
the original Bill I'm sorry you're quite
you're quite right my eyeballs bounc
thank you for the correction
representative pmer um this is sort of a
procedural question because um
uh representative Weber's bill has
something that I I think is very
important which is if you have someone
who's in the in midtreatment
um allowing for that to continue is is
pretty important um and I'm just
wondering whether we'll if
we will we get a chance to vote on that
Amendment yes oh yes we have to do this
one first yeah they I mean we have to
deal with what's on the you know before
us at the moment and if I may Mr
chairman once once we have finished
passing
all the things we have passed um if we
were to pass more than one OS would uh
to the extent possible
integrate and they're not they're not
mutually exclusive because the language
of one and the language of other the
other aren't the same
issues representative
lontine um yeah I'm a little concerned
by the addition of biological sex um
because there are some uh infants born
with ambiguous genitalia that might be
considered what you call hermaphrodite
or sometimes referred to Middle sex
that's so if that
child um were to pursue some of these
treatments
um that that last Clause as a perception
is inconsistent with the Minor's
biological sex as defined in this
chapter um it's not really clear how the
rules would apply in that case and
you're sort of limiting what their
options are and what the parent might
pursue in order to help that child
transition through puberty because there
they could be you don't know what their
biological sex is it's
ambiguous and if it often doesn't um
become clear until a child goes through
puberty that they're leaning one way or
or the
other and these are children who really
are going to need some help as are all
of the children who consider some
themselves
trans but
you it's very broad representative merer
it does say you know down on 20 line 27
and 28 that um shall not apply to a
procedure undertaken to treat a minor
born with born with a medically
verifiable disorder of sex development
that's that's in
there anyone else representative Woods
uh yeah I have some concerns that uh on
line 18 it says so says
engage among other things Council uh
Council can be you know either for or
line 18 sorry um I'm sorry U okay wait
no I'm I'm on the wrong
with my apologies my
apologies anyone else oh I had another
the issue about biologic sex uh uh this
is a true story uh came up at uh
actually Health and Human Services uh
committee uh a lady in her
mid-30s um arrived for fertility
evaluation
turns out after investigation she was
not she she was a he was married and
couldn't get pregnant but turns out she
was
a biologic
he and um the question is if in fact who
determines the biologic
sex in that situation someone determined
that this individual was a she but turns
out was a he had undescended testicles
uh and everything let's just say that uh
this was a
13-year-old who uh made the appearance
as a female uh and in during the
evaluation uh wanted
to make that change um again understand
we're having a good discussion very
broad sort of a cultural discussion and
I think that's healthy uh but I just
have concerns because all of us that are
at least Physicians no we treat the
individual uh and unfortunately I think
although some of this is well intended
uh we're going to sweep everybody under
the same rug and I have some concerns
representative merer yeah again I'll
repeat it
mentions miners born with a medically
verifiable disorder of sex development
that sounds to me like that would fall
under
that represent
Weber and I'm just going to say that the
definition of disorders of sex
development in 332m Colon
2 uh is a list and it's not it doesn't
provide for anything that isn't on the
list so the list includes 46xx
chromosomes with or without
viralization
viralization presence of both aarian and
testicular tissue other abnormal sex
chromos
structures abnormal sex steroid hormone
hormone production or action or
ambiguous genitalia I don't know if that
covers the entire range of
possibilities but what we have heard in
testimony is that there seem to be an
inverinate variety of possibilities and
I would be very sorry to restrict to
just those if there are in fact
uh individuals who have other conditions
that would need
treatment representative
lontine yes swallowing up with rep
Weber's comments like how do we not how
do we know that gender dysphoria which
we heard testimony from many parents
saying that their child asserting
themselves to be of the opposite sex
from which they were born
that that is
not something the inherent that they
were born
with they their belief their gender
dysphoria and why why are we saying that
we're going to
deny treatment and medical care for that
individual I feel like this bill is
essentially
saying what whatever their experience is
not real and we do not believe you we do
not
believe um any of the the treatments and
therapies that have happened of
which all of the the
parents and trans children who came to
testify were very
happy with their process that they have
gone through and the
adults and you're this bill is
essentially saying we don't believe
you're real and we don't uh believe that
you're entitled to this Medical Care
your own
choice okay I one one one one more
comment I mean we've got two amendments
and a bill to vote on so representative
McGrath um I don't think that's the
focus of where we're going with the
bill I think the focus is just how
powerful and dangerous these medications
are to give two
examples every women woman undergoing
menopause at a certain time would get
estrogens now nobody gets estrogens
because they're dangerous
it's extremely rare for a doctor to
prescribe
estrogens to a
patient another example
is the um teenage boys that were taking
hormones to build up their
muscles and how
dangerous everybody found out it was
with the the Roid Rage that was
happening and they were beating up their
girlfriends or whatever the stories
were so this is I think more
about yeah we can affirm the kids and
love the kids but let's let them wait
till they're older to get to assume the
risk of what of what these drugs do to
them all right thank you I know there's
um one quick comment represent hard
because part of the reason I'm rushing
is because I want to get you out of here
okay um I'm you know to be honest with
you I'm just struggling with the bills
and the Amendments coming at as quickly
but if I think about the original Bill
the original bill was really about
medicine we don't want medicine when I
read the amendment now what I'm reading
is well we don't want you talking about
this uh with a young person it's just
you see that well what's what is line 23
and 2 through 25 mean enabling a minor
to identify with or live as a reported
ident in system with the minus
biological sex treating purported
discomfort or distress yeah but that
that leads in from the first
paragraph about the hormones and sex
Lacross seex hormones and puberty
blockers that enable a minor to identify
with so those two points pertain to the
first paragraph that are specific to the
medications that enable this yeah I just
uh I I guess I'm reading this further as
just flat out anti-trans legislation
you're welcome to read it best yeah it
is not that I don't you're welcome to
read I don't think any of us are going
to change each other's mind is that a
fair
statement um so and again representative
haret I
know you know this is why I'm trying to
get this thing done for it you know I I
I don't think it's going to matter at
this point if we debate it further
with respect chairman he has to leave so
that's I understand that but I am not
going to let that statement go
unchallenged because the people to whom
this
matters is our
constituents and their
children who came to us and said this
treatment is necessary to them and has
enabled them to live Better Lives lives
and we had overwhelming testimony in
that respect and so to say that whatever
we say here doesn't matter to anybody it
matters to them that was not my
intention representative weo I was just
say I understand that but I need them
anyone who's watching this to hear that
and I'm going to say if that were the we
could we could keep going on this for
another hour but we are acknowledging
that representative Harnet has to leave
so that's why we are trying to get
through this I could we could talk about
this for another hour we're not because
of that my only point for anyone who hit
is hearing my comments is I think every
member of the committee pretty much
knows how they're going to vote on this
that's true uh and that that's my only
Point uh no disrespect intended to
anyone who testified or any opposing
points of view representative TS I just
want to make one last comment that
despite everyone's positions that uh
this is counter to Medical Practice and
evidence and psychological knowledge
just regardless of what your own beliefs
might be so it's it's just not
evidence-based okay I think at this
point let let's go to the vote on the
amendment again it's on ought to pass
H Mr
clerk rep merer yes rep mlan yes rep
damus yes rep Hill yes
yes rep poov yes clerk votes yes rep
marel yes rep McGrath yes rep kessing
yes rep Weber no rep McKay no rep Woods
no rep Palmer no rep taes no rep lontine
no rep hartnet no rep Lucas no rep
McDonald yes vot is 10 to8 motion
passes okay next up is amendment
0926 representative
Weber thank you and
um for the um change that mine made all
it did was add the two lines on line 29
and line 30 uh which say paragraph one
of the section shall not apply to a
procedure undertaken to Freedom minor oh
I'm sorry no I've got that wrong uh I
thought it was
there uh yes I'm sorry it's on the back
page two did did did
you your motion was not seconded was it
I don't
believe representative wood seconds
thank you Mr
clerk thank you uh proceed
representative sorry sorry for the
interruption it's well I'm sorry for
addressing the wrong section and putting
you in the wrong space uh on page two
lines 1 two and three simply allow
patients under 18 years of age may
continue to be treated with a
prescription consistent with those
referenced under this section if such
treatment was commen commenced before
and is still active on the effective
date of this act for some minors who
have been treated for a significant
amount of time
the discontinuation of treatment is
going to be very harmful so uh this is
basically a grandfather clause that lets
those who have started continue uh even
though we don't allow others to
begin okay representative Woods um I
would just support that because
basically under AMA guidelines
Physicians who undertake treatment of an
individual have to follow certain
guidelines and um that includes um
an adequate
consent that would include this kind of
treatment were we to legislate that that
would in fact be the practice of
medicine to say all right doctor you
have to
stop that is indeed interfering with the
doctor patient relationship going into
the office and say sorry you're
done that's
malpractice um I I I think this is a
very important
Clause
um and for the reasons I just mentioned
thank you final comment representative
pazo thank you Mr chair there are some
interesting Arguments for this amendment
but I feel uh it's a significant uh
change that needs not just discussing
but public hearing and maybe it can
happen in Senate but right now I'm not
comfortable with my knowledge adopting
it okay the motion is out to pass on
Amendment 0926 H Mr clerk if you're
ready no I'm not ready all right
representative mlan so I yeah I'm I I
got to consider this because
uh so I don't know that I adequately
understand the
consequences of stopping a treatment
that's
underway uh so if we pass both these
bills both these Amendment what happens
well representative wber explain that OS
would reconcile them is that correct
representative Weber that's my
understanding my understanding is that
they would take the two different
Provisions they would probably be
renumbered or put in a different order
but the two sets of of uh mine is simply
an addition onto whatever else is in the
bill so it wouldn't interfere with any
language that you've already approved in
uh representative
masers they will take one uh make it
into one committee
Amendment sometimes there's a problem
with getting the amendment at the last
minute but representative haret you're
about to leave right yeah we're not
going to be able to finish this
today well in deference to the the
Democrats in the room representative
hartnet needs to leave what procedurally
what do we do can we continue this or
you are the chairman yes no no but I but
well we can we if we could just vote on
this and vote on the bill and we'd be
done so that would be
quick we would have to
caucus we don't have time to caucus then
I would suggest we put this off until
next week that you recess the executive
session that you Reen notice it the fact
that we're in the middle of a bill yeah
that that was I was it was a procedural
question not a political question right
no I I I'm I'm trying to give you what I
think is the procedural answer we are in
the middle of a bill but I think that
because it's an individual executive
session you can
recess I mean representative uh hartnet
was you know a very forthcoming first
thing this morning that he had to leave
and personally I think it would be
inequitable for us to proceed if if and
I think that's very kind and I think the
but I think you can simply recess now
and Rec convene the executive session
when you notice all of the bills next
week okay yeah that does that make sense
every represent to Pro you would you
would represent uh you would recess to a
Time
certain well we we'll be reconvening at
9:30 next Wednesday morning yes
exactly what you said at which time we
will consider this and all the other
bills that we have yet to exact for the
committee's information in case you
didn't know we have now heard all of our
bills all of the public hearings have
been held so it's exclusively an
executive session that will be occurring
next Wednesday morning so so well but
we' it's going to be a marathon
executive session and all the reports
are going to have to be done next
Wednesday right after we're done so
bring uh and your laptop yeah so anyway
anyone else with any thoughts before we
adjourn thank you representative hartner
thank you sorry thank you for the
consideration we appreciate that all
right with that uh we'll we'll stand
adjourned until next Wednesday morning
at 9:30 again executive session only
next
week thank you